thank you
big data is a term I'm sure you are all
familiar with
Big Data as a technology has grown
massively over a decade and a half when
internet users boomed and companies
started generating vast amounts of data
it became more popular with the Advent
of AI machine learning mobile technology
and The Internet of Things
big data analytics helps companies from
different sectors such as automobile
manufacturing e-commerce and Logistics
to manage processes streamline used data
sets in real time as well as improve
their organization's decision making
capability
big data and analytics can enable
organizations to get a better
understanding of their customers and
help to narrow down their targeted
audience thus helping to improve
companies marketing campaigns
now there is no doubt that the big data
market is steadily growing and as per
Fortune business insights
the global big data market is expected
to grow from
231.43 billion dollars in 2021 to
549.73 billion US dollars in 2028 at a
cagr of 13.2 percent
as per monster.com annual Trends report
big data analytics is most likely going
to be the top in demand skill for 2022
at least 96 percent of companies are
definitely planning or likely to plan to
hire new staff with relevant skills to
fill future big data analytics related
roles in 2022 this indicates that the
career opportunities and Big Data are
very high and the scope is really good
now if you are looking for a career in
Big Data in 2022 on the screen you can
see some of the top Big Data companies
for 2022 so we have Oracle e-commerce
leader Amazon hpe Tech Giant IBM and
Salesforce
now
let's look at the agenda for today's
video on Big Data full course 2022 so we
will start off by learning how to become
a big data engineer and then we will see
the crucial skills for Big Data next we
will understand big data analytics and
look at the top applications in Big Data
after that
we are going to learn about Big Data
tutorial and understand the most popular
Big Data framework that is Hadoop next
we are going to look at the different
tools that are part of the Hadoop
ecosystem then we are going to learn
about Apache spark and understand the
spark architecture
finally we are going to close our full
course video session by learning the top
Hadoop interview questions so let's
begin
today I'm going to tell you how you can
become a big data engineer now it should
come as no surprise for you guys to know
that organizations generate as well as
use a whole lot of data this vast volume
of data is called Big Data companies use
big data to draw meaningful insights and
take business decisions and Big Data
Engineers are the people who can make
sense out of this enormous amount of
data now let's find out who is a big
data engineer a big data engineer is a
professional Who develops maintains
tests and evaluates the company's Big
Data infrastructure in other words
develop Big Data Solutions based on a
company's requirements they maintain
these solutions they test out these
Solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with various tools and systems
of the organization and finally they
evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design Implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of ETL or the extract transform load
process and they need to research as
well as propose new ways to acquire data
improve the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data Architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
Big Data Solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages I can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice and more practice
some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for Big Data
engineering are python Java and C plus
the second skill that you require is to
have in-depth knowledge about dbms and
SQL you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a
database you need to know how SQL can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write SQL queries for any
relational database Management Systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for Big Data
engineering mySQL rackle database and
the Microsoft SQL Server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with ETL and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct
product as well as use a data warehouse
so that you can perform the ETL
operation or the extract transform and
load operations now as a big data
engineer you'll be constantly tasked
with extracting unstructured data from a
number of different sources transforming
it into meaningful information and
loading it into other data storages
databases or data warehouses now what
this is is basically aggregating
unstructured data from multiple sources
analyzing it so that you can take Better
Business decisions some of the tools use
purpose are Talent IBM data stage
pentahoe and Informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most Big Data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as Hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like Linux and Unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by Big Data
Engineers are Unix Linux and Solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with Hadoop based analytics
since Hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to Big Data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with Apache
Hadoop based Technologies Technologies
like htfs Hadoop mapreduce Apache
edgebase Hive and pig the sixth skill
that you require is to have worked with
real-time processing Frameworks like
Apache spark now as a big data engineer
you'll have to deal with vast volumes of
data so for this data you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for large scale real-time data
processing now spark can process live
streaming data from a number of
different sources like Facebook
Instagram Twitter and so on it can also
perform interactive analysis and data
integration and now we're at our final
skill requirement which is to have
experience with data mining and modeling
so as a data engineer you'll have to
examine massive pre-existing data so
that you can discover patterns as well
as new information with this you will
create predictive models for your
business so that you can make better
informed decisions some of the tools
used for this are are rapidminer Vega
and 9. now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary as well as other roles
they can look forward to now the average
salary of a big data engineer in the
United States is approximately ninety
thousand dollars per year now this
ranges from sixty six thousand dollars
all the way to 130 000 dollars per annum
in India the average salary is around 7
lakh rupees and ranges from 4 lakhs to
13 lakhs per annum after you've become a
big data engineer some of the job roles
that you can look forward to at that of
a senior Big Data engineer a business
intelligence architect and a data
architect now let's talk about
certifications that a big data engineer
can opt for first off we have the
Cloudera CCP data engineer a cloud in a
certified professional data engineer
possesses the skills to develop reliable
and scalable data pipelines that result
in optimized data sets for a variety of
workloads it is one of the industry's
most demanding performance-based
certification CCP evaluates and
recognizes the candidate's Mastery of
the technical skills most sought after
by employers the time limit for this
exam is 240 minutes and it costs 400
next we have the IBM certified data
architect Big Data certification an IBM
certified Big Data architect understands
the complexity of data and can Design
Systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the Google Cloud
certified data engineer a Google
Certified data engineer enables
data-driven decision making by
collecting transforming and Publishing
data they should also be able to
leverage deploy and continuously train
pre-existing machine learning models the
length of the certification exam is two
hours and its registration fee is 200
now let's have a look at how simply
learn can help you become a big data
engineer simplylearn provides the Big
Data architect Masters program this
includes a number of different courses
like big data Hadoop and Spark developer
Apache spark and Scala mongodb developer
and administrator big data and Hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in demand
skills and tools 12 plus real life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like Kafka Apache spark
Flume Edge base mongodb Hive big map
produce Java Scala and much more now why
don't you head over to simplylearn.com
and get started on your journey to get
certified and get ahead we all use
smartphones but have you ever wondered
how much data it generates in the form
of texts phone calls emails photos
videos searches and music approximately
40 exabytes of data gets generated every
month by a single smartphone user now
imagine this number multiplied by 5
billion smartphone users that's a lot
for our mind even process isn't it in
fact this amount of data is quite a lot
for traditional Computing systems to
handle and this massive amount of data
is what we term as Big Data let's have a
look at the data generated per minute on
the internet
2.1 million Snaps are shared on Snapchat
3.8 million search queries are made on
Google one million people log on to
Facebook 4.5 million videos are watched
on YouTube
188 million emails are sent that's a lot
of data so how do you classify any data
as Big Data this is possible with the
concept of five V's volume velocity
variety veracity and value let us
understand this with an example from the
healthcare industry Hospitals and
Clinics across the world generate
massive volumes of data 2 314 exabytes
of data are collected annually in the
form of patient records and test results
all this data is generated at a very
high speed which attributes to the
velocity of Big Data variety refers to
the various data types such as
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data examples include Excel
records log files and x-ray images
accuracy and trustworthiness of the
generated data is termed as veracity
analyzing all this data will benefit the
medical sector by enabling faster
disease detection better treatment and
reduced cost this is known as the value
of Big Data but how do we store and
process this big data to do this job we
have various Frameworks such as
Cassandra Hadoop and Spark let us take
Hadoop as an example and see how Hadoop
stores and processes Big Data
Hadoop uses a distributed file system
known as Hadoop distributed file system
to store Big Data if you have a huge
file your file will be broken down into
smaller chunks and stored in various
machines not only that when you break
the file you also make copies of it
which goes into different nodes this way
you store your big data in a distributed
way and make sure that even if one
machine fails your data is safe on
another
mapreduce technique is used to process
Big Data a lengthy task a is broken into
smaller tasks
b c and d now instead of one machine
three machines take up each task and
complete it in a parallel fashion and
assemble the results at the end thanks
to this the processing becomes easy and
fast this is known as parallel
processing
now that we have stored and processed
our big data we can analyze this data
for numerous applications in games like
Halo 3 and Call of Duty designers
analyze user data to understand at which
stage most of the users pause restart or
quit playing this Insight can help them
rework on the storyline of the game and
improve the user experience which in
turn reduces the customer churn rate
similarly Big Data also helped with
disaster management during Hurricane
Sandy in 2012. it was used to gain a
better understanding of the storm's
effect on the east coast of the U.S and
necessary measures were taken it could
predict the Hurricane's landfall five
days in advance which wasn't possible
earlier these are some of the clear
indications of how valuable big data can
be once it is accurately processed and
analyzed back in the early 2000s there
was relatively less data generated but
with the rise of various social media
platforms and multinational companies
across the globe the generation of data
has increased by Leaps and Bounds
according to the IDC the total volume of
data is expected to reach 175 zettabytes
in 2025. that's a lot of data
so we can Define Big Data as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using the
traditional ways let's now have a look
at the challenges with respect to Big
Data
the first challenge with big data is its
storage storing big data is not easy as
the data generation is endless in
addition to this storing unstructured
data in our traditional databases is a
great challenge unstructured data refers
to data such as photographs and videos
the Second Challenge was processing Big
Data data is only useful to us if it is
processed and analyzed processing Big
Data consumes a lot of time due to its
size and structure
to overcome these challenges of big data
we have various Frameworks such as
Hadoop Cassandra and Spark let us have a
quick look at Hadoop and Spark
so what is Hadoop it is a framework that
stores big data in a distributed way and
processes it parallely how do you think
Hadoop does this
well Hadoop users are distributed file
system known as Hadoop distributed file
system to store Big Data if you have a
huge file your file will be broken down
into smaller chunks and stored in
various machines this is why it is
termed as distributed storage
map reduce is the processing unit of
Hadoop here we have multiple Machines
working parallely to process Big Data
thanks to this technique the processing
becomes easy and fast
let's now move on to spark spark is a
framework that is responsible for
processing data both in batches and in
real time spark is used to analyze data
across various clusters of computers
now that you have understood Big Data
Hadoop and Spark let's look into few of
the different job roles in this domain
career opportunities in this field are
Limitless as organizations are using big
data to enhance their products business
decisions and marketing effectiveness
so here we will understand in depth as
to how to become a big data engineer in
addition to this we will also look into
the various skills required to become a
Hadoop developers path developer and a
big data architect
starting off with a big data engineer
role do you know who a big data engineer
is
well Big Data Engineers are
professionals who develop maintain test
and evaluate a company's Big Data
infrastructure they have several
responsibilities firstly they are
responsible for Designing and
implementing software systems they
verify and maintain these systems for
their ingestion and processing of data
they built robust systems extract
transform load operations known as the
ETL process is carried out by Big Data
Engineers they also research various new
methods to obtain data and improve its
quality
Big Data Engineers are also responsible
for building data architectures that
meet the business requirements they
provide a solution by integrating
various tools and programming languages
in addition to the about
responsibilities their primary
responsibility is to mine data from
Plenty of different sources to build
efficient business models lastly they
also work closely with data Architects
data scientists and data analysts those
are quite a lot of responsibilities let
us now have a look at the skills
required to achieve these
responsibilities
as you can see on your screens we have
listed the top top seven skills needed
to be possessed by a big data engineer
starting off the essential skill is
programming a big data engineer needs to
have hands-on experience in any one of
the programming languages such as Java C
plus plus or python
as a big data engineer you should also
have in-depth knowledge of bbms and SQL
this is because you have to understand
how data is managed and maintained in a
database hence you need to know how to
write SQL queries for any rdbms systems
some of the commonly used database
Management systems for Big Data
engineering are MySQL Oracle database
and the Microsoft SQL Server
as mentioned earlier carrying out an e
carrying out an ETL operation is a big
data engineer's responsibility now you
need to know how to construct as well as
use a data warehouse so that you can
perform these CTL operations as a big
data engineer you will be continuously
tasked with extracting data from various
sources transforming them into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages some of the
tools used for this purpose are Talent
IBM data stage pentaho and Informatica
next up we have the fourth skill that
you require which is knowledge about
operating systems
Big Data tools run on operating systems
hence a sound understanding of Unix
Linux windows and Solaris is mandatory
the fifth skill that you require is to
have experience with Hadoop based
Analytics
and swarup is one of the most commonly
used Big Data engineering tools it's
understood that you need to have
experience with Apache hadoop-based
Technologies like hdfs mapreduce Apache
Pig Hive and Apache headspace
the sixth skill that you require is to
have worked with real-time processing
Frameworks like Apache spark as a big
data engineer you would deal with large
volumes of data so for this you need an
analytics engine like spark which can be
used for both batch and real-time
processing spark can process live
streaming data from several different
sources like Facebook Instagram Twitter
and so on
and now we are at a final skill
requirement which is to have experience
with data mining and data modeling as a
big data engineer you would have to
examine Master pre-existing data so that
you can discover patterns and new
information this will help you create
predictive models that will help you
make various business business decisions
some of the tools used for this are are
rapidminer Becca and nime
now let's talk about a big data
engineer's salary in the US a big data
engineer's average annual salary is
around 102 000 dollars per annum in
India a big data engineer makes about 7
lakh rupees per annum
that was all about our first role Big
Data engineer moving on to our second
role we have Hadoop developer
as the name suggests a Hadoop developer
looks into the coding and programming of
the various Hadoop applications this job
role is more or less similar to that of
a software developer
moving on to the skills required to
become a Hadoop developer at first it is
a knowledge of the Hadoop ecosystem a
Hadoop developer should have in-depth
knowledge about the Hadoop ecosystem and
its components which include headspace
big scoop Flume Uzi Etc you should also
have data modeling experience with olap
and oltp knowledge of SQL is required
like a big data engineer a Hadoop
developer must also know popular tools
like pentaho Informatica and talent
finally you should also be well versed
in writing Pig Latin scripts and
mapreduce jobs
the average annual salary of a Hadoop
developer in the US is nearly 76 000 per
annum in India a Hadoop developer makes
approximately 4 lakh 57 000 rupees per
annum
moving to our third job role we have
spark developer we saw What spark is now
let's understand what a spark developer
does
spark developers create spark jobs using
python or Scala for data aggregation and
transformation they also write analytics
code and design data processing
Pipelines
a spark developer needs to have the
following skills they need to know spark
and its components such as spark core
spark streaming spark machine learning
library
Etc they should also know the scripting
languages like python or Perl just like
the previous job roles a spark developer
should also have basic knowledge of SQL
queries and a database structure
in addition to the above a spark
developer is also expected to have a
fairly good understanding of Linux and
its commands
moving to the average annual salary of a
spark developer it is nearly eighty one
thousand dollars per annum in the US in
India a spark developer earns nearly 5
lakh 87 000 rupees per annum
let's now move on to our final job role
that is big data architect so let's
understand who a big data architect is
well a big data architect is a
professional who is responsible for
Designing and planning Big Data Systems
they also manage large-scale development
and deployment of Hadoop applications
moving on to the skills required to
become a big data architect first up the
individual must have Advanced Data
Mining and data analysis skills Big Data
Architects should also be able to
implement and use a nosql database and
cloud computing techniques
they must also have an idea of various
Big Data Technologies like Hadoop
mapreduce hbase Hive and so on finally
Big Data Architects must hold experience
with agile and scrum Frameworks
let's now have a look at the average
annual salary of a big data architect in
the United States and India in the U.S a
big data architect earns a whopping
hundred and eighteen thousand dollars
per annum meanwhile in India a big data
architect makes nearly 19 lakh rupees
per annum these are huge numbers right
so now that we have understood the job
roles of a big data engineer Hadoop
developer spark developer and a big data
architect let us have a look at the
companies hiring these professionals
as you all can see on your screens we
have IBM Amazon American Express Netflix
Microsoft and Bosch to name a few let us
now understand why big data analytics is
required with an example so all of you
listen to music online isn't it here we
will take an example of Spotify which is
a Swedish audio streaming platform and
see how big data analytics is used here
Spotify has nearly 96 plus million users
and all these users generate a
tremendous amount of data data like the
songs which are played repeatedly the
numerous likes shares and the user's
search history all these data can be
termed as Big Data here with respect to
Spotify have you ever wondered what
Spotify does with all this big data well
Spotify analyzes this big data for
suggesting songs to its users I'm sure
all of you might have come across the
recommendation list which is made
available available to each one of you
by Spotify each one of you will have a
totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so Spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because Spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by Spotify now that we
have understood by big data analytics is
required let us know on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term Big Data many a times
but do you know what exactly Big Data
means well we will understand the term
Big Data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
process and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as I talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of Facebook Facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages
Etc Big Data also contains data of
different formats like structured data
semi-structured data and unstructured
data data like your Excel sheets all
fall under structured data this data has
a definite format your emails fall under
semi-structured and your pictures and
videos all fall under unstructured data
all this data together make up for Big
Data it is very tough to store process
and analyze big data using rtbms if you
have looked into our previous videos you
would know that Hadoop is the solution
to this Hadoop is a framework that
stores and processes Big Data it stores
big data using the distributed storage
system and it processes big data using
the parallel processing method hence
storing and processing big data is no
more a problem using Hadoop big data in
its raw form is of no use to us we must
try to derive meaningful information
from it in order to benefit from this
big data do you know Amazon uses big
data to monitor its items that are in
its fulfillment centers across the globe
how do you think Amazon does this well
it is done by analyzing big data which
is known as big data analytics what is
big data analytics in simple terms big
data analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from Big Data this
information could be your hidden
patterns unknown correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step I will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management
BDO which is a Philippine banking
company uses big data analytics for risk
management risk management is an
important aspect for any organization
especially in the field of banking risk
management analysis comprises a series
of measures which are employed to
prevent any sort of unauthorized
activities identifying fraudulent
activities with a main concern for BDO
it was difficult for the bank to
identify the fraud still from a long
list of suspects BDO adopted big data
analytics which helped the bank to
narrow down the entire list of suspects
thus the organization was able to
identify the fraudster in a very short
time this is how big data analytics is
used in the field of banking for risk
management let us now see how big data
analytics is used for product
development and Innovations with an
example all of you are aware of
Rolls-Royce cars right do you also know
that they manufacture jet engines which
are used across the world what is more
interesting is that they use big data
analytics for developing and innovating
this engine a new product is always
developed by trial and error method big
data analytics is used here to analyze
if an engine design is good or bad it is
also used to analyze if there can be
more scope for improvement based on the
previous models and on the future
demands this way big data analytics is
used in designing a product which is of
higher quality using big data analytics
the company can save a lot of time if
the team is struggling to arrive at the
right conclusion big data can be used to
zero in on the right data which have to
be studied and thus the time spent on
the product development is less big data
analytics helps in quicker and better
decision making in organizations the
process of selecting a course of action
from various other Alternatives is known
as decision making lot of organizations
take important decisions based on the
data that they have data driven business
decisions can make or break a company
hence it is important to analyze all the
possibilities thoroughly and quickly
before making important decisions let us
now try to understand this with an use
case Starbucks uses big data analytics
for making important decisions they
decide the location of their new outlet
using big data analytics choosing the
right location is an important factor
for any organization the wrong location
will not be able to attract the required
amount of customers positioning of a new
outlet a few miles here or there can
always make a huge difference for an
outlet especially a one like Starbucks
various factors are involved in choosing
the right location for a new outlet for
example parking adequacy has to be taken
into consideration it would be
inconvenient for people to go to a store
which has no parking facility similarly
the other factors that have to be
considered are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and
thoroughly thus Starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
Delta and American Airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does every everything they can
in order to provide good service and
experience to its customers Delta
Airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers Journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customers
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the Airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose Delta for
their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis Delta Airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is life
cycle of big data analytics here we will
look into the various stages as to how
data is analyzed from scratch the first
stage is the business case evaluation
stage here the motive behind the
analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
have to see if the data that we received
is fit for analysis or not not all the
data that we receive will have
meaningful information some of it will
surely just be corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data data
is now fit for analysis well it is not
we still have to figure out which data
will be compatible with the tool that we
will be using for analysis if we find
data which is incompatible we first
extract it and then transform it to a
compatible form depending on the tool
that we use in the next stage all the
data with the same Fields will be
integrated this is known as the data
aggregation stage the next stage which
is the analysis stage is a very
important stage in the life cycle of big
data analytics right here in this step
the entire process of evaluating your
data using various analytical and
statistical tools to discover meaningful
information is done like we have
discussed before the entire process of
deriving meaningful information from
data which is known as analysis is done
here in this stage the result of the
data analysis stage is then graphically
communicated using tools like Tableau
power bi click view this analysis result
will then be made available to different
business stakeholders for various
decision making this was the entire life
cycle of big data analytics we just saw
how data is analyzed from scratch now we
will move on to a very important topic
that is the different types of big data
analytics well we have four different
types of big data analytics as you see
here these are the types and below this
are the questions that each type tries
to answer we have descriptive analytics
which asks the question what has
happened then we have diagnostic
analytics which asks why did it happen
Predictive Analytics asking what will
happen and prescriptive analytics which
questions by asking what is the solution
we will look into all these four one by
one with an use case for each we we will
first start off with descriptive
analytics as mentioned earlier
descriptive analytics asks the question
what has happened it can be defined as
the type that summarizes past data into
a form that can be understood by humans
in this type we will look into the past
data and arrive at various conclusions
for example an organization can review
its performance using descriptive
analytics that is it analyzes its past
data such as Revenue over the years and
arrives at a conclusion with the profit
by looking at this graph we can
understand if the company is running at
a profit or not thus descriptive
analytics helps us understand this
easily we can simply say that
descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like Facebook likes tweets
Etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the Dow Chemical Company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the underutilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly 4 million dollars annually
so we now see here that descriptive
analytics not only helps us derive
meaningful information from the past
data but it can also help companies in
cost reduction if it is used wisely let
us now move on to our next type that is
diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data Discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it init solves
bi query tool is an example of
diagnostic analytics we can use Query
tool for Diagnostic analytics now that
you know why diagnostic analytics is
required and what diagnostic analytics
is I will run you through an example
which shows where diagnostic analytics
can be used all of us shop on e-commerce
sites right have you ever added items to
your cart but ended up not buying it yes
all of us might have done that at some
point an organization tries to
understand why its customers don't end
up buying their products although it has
been added to their cuts and this
understanding is done with the help of
diagnostic analytics an e-com homicide
wonders why they have made few online
sales although they have had a very good
marketing strategy there could have been
various factors as to why this has
happened factors like the shipping fee
which was too high or the page that
didn't load correctly not enough payment
options available and so on all these
factors are analyzed using diagnostic
analytics and the company comes to a
conclusion as to why this has happened
thus we see here that the root cost is
identified so that in future the same
problem doesn't occur again let us now
move on to the third type that is
Predictive Analytics as the name
suggests Predictive Analytics makes
predictions of the Future IT analyzes
the current and historical facts to make
predictions about future it always asks
the question what will happen next
Predictive Analytics is used with the
help of artificial intelligence machine
learning data mining to analyze the data
it can be used for predicting custom
customer Trends market trends customer
Behavior Etc it solely works on
probability it always tries to
understand what can happen next with the
help of all the past and current
information a company like PayPal which
has 260 plus million accounts always has
the need to ensure that their online
fraudulent and unauthorized activities
are brought down to nil fear of constant
fraudulent activities have always been a
major concern for PayPal when a
fraudulent activity occurs people lose
trust in the company and this brings in
a very bad name for the brand it is
inevitable that fraudulent activities
will happen in a company like PayPal
which is one of the largest online
payment processes in the world but
PayPal uses analytics wisely here to
prevent such fraudulent activities and
to minimize them it uses Predictive
Analytics to do so the organization is
able to analyze pass data which includes
a customer's historical payment data a
customer's Behavior Trend and then it
builds an algorithm which works on
predicting what is likely to happen next
with respect to their transaction with
the use of big data and algorithms the
system can gauge which of the
transactions are valid and which could
be potentially a fraudulent activity by
doing so PayPal is always ready with
precautions that they have to take to
protect all their clients against
fraudulent transactions we will now move
on to our last type that is prescriptive
analytics prescriptive analytics as the
name suggests always prescribes a
solution to a particular problem the
problem can be something which is
happening currently hence it can be
termed as the type that always asks a
question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and Predictive Analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and where prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit do you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seed selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flights fare is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days Seasons like Christmas and
and school vacations also weekends the
rates will be much higher than weekdays
another factor which determines a
flight's fare is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight Fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flights fare will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight's fare by
doing so the airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of Big Data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are few of the tools that I will be
talking about today we have Hadoop
mongodb talindi Kafka Cassandra spark
and storm we will look into each one of
them one by one we will first start off
with Hadoop when you speak of Big Data
the first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is Hadoop isn't it as I
mentioned earlier Apache Hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
Hadoop uses mapreduce big and high for
analyzing this big data Hadoop is easily
one of the most famous Big Data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is a cross-platform
document oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb Talon D provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in Big Data
integration talente opens to studio is a
free open source tool for processing
data easily on a big data environment
Cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to Hadoop in its
feature of fault tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes Cassandra is preferred for
real-time processing spark is another
tool that is used for data processing
this data processing engine is developed
to process data way faster than Hadoop
mapreduce this is done in a way because
spark does all the processing in the
main memory of the data nodes and thus
it prevents unnecessary input output
overheads with the disk whereas map
reduce is disk based and hence spark
proves to be faster than Hadoop
mapreduce storm is a free big data
computational system which is done in
real time it is one of the easiest tools
for Big Data analysis it can be used
with any programming language this
feature makes storm very simple to use
finally we will look into another big
data tool which is known as Kafka Kafka
is a distributed streaming platform
which was developed by LinkedIn and
later given to Apache software
Foundation it is used to provide
real-time analytics result and it is
also used for fault tolerant storage
these were few of the big data analytics
tools now let us move on to our last
topic for today that is big data
application domains here we will look
into the various sectors where big data
analytics is actively used the first
sector is e-commerce nearly 45 percent
of the world is online and they create a
lot of data every second big data can be
used smartly in the field of e-commerce
by predicting customer Trend forecasting
demands adjusting the price and so on
online retailers have the opportunity to
create better shopping experience and
generate higher sales if big data
analytics is used correctly having big
data doesn't automatically lead to a
better marketing strategy meaningful
insights need to be derived from it in
order to make right decisions by
analyzing big data we can have
personalized marketing campaigns which
can result in better and higher sales in
the field of Education depending on the
market requirements new courses are
developed the market requirement needs
to be analyzed correctly with respect to
the scope of a course and accordingly a
scope needs to be developed there is no
point in developing a course which has
no scope in the future hence to analyze
the market requirement and to develop
new courses we use big data analytics
here there are a number of uses of big
data analytics in the field of
healthcare and one of it is to predict a
patient's health issue that is with the
help of the their previous medical
history big data analytics can determine
How likely they are to have a particular
health issue in the future the example
of Spotify that we saw previously showed
how big data analytics is used to
provide a personalized recommendation
list to all its users similarly in the
field of media and entertainment big
data analytics is used to understand the
demands of shows songs movies and so on
to deliver personalized recommendation
lists as we saw with Spotify big data
analytics is used in the field of
banking as we saw previously with a few
use cases big data analytics was used
for risk management in addition to risk
management it is also used to analyze a
customer's income and spend patterns and
to help the bank predict if a particular
customer is going to choose any of the
bank offers such as loans credit cards
schemes and so on this way the bank is
able to identify the right customer who
is interested in its offers it has
noticed that telecom companies have
begun to embrace big data to gain profit
big data analytics helps in analyzing
Network traffic and call data records it
can also improve its service quality and
improve its customer experience let us
now look into how big data analytics is
used by governments across the world in
the field of law enforcement big data
analytics can be applied to analyze all
the available data to understand crime
patterns intelligent Services can use
Predictive Analytics to forecast the
crime which could be committed in Durham
the police department was able to reduce
the crime rate using big data analytics
with the help of data police could
identify whom to Target where to go when
to petrol and how to investigate crimes
big data analytics helped them to
discover patterns of crime emerging in
the area before we move on to the
application locations let's have a quick
look at the big data market revenue
forecast worldwide from 2011 to 2027. so
here's a graph in which the y-axis
represents the revenue in billion US
Dollars and the x-axis represents the
years as it is seen clearly from the
graph big data has grown until 2019 and
statistics predict that this growth will
continue even in the future this growth
is made possible as numerous companies
use big data in various domains to boost
their revenue we will look into few of
such applications the first Big Data
application we will look into is weather
forecast imagine there is a sudden storm
and you're not even prepared that would
be a terrifying situation isn't it
dealing with any calamities such as
hurricane storms floods would be very
inconvenient if we are caught off guard
the solution is to have a tool that
predicts the weather of the coming days
well in advance this tool needs to be
accurate and to make such a tool big
data is used so how does big data help
here well it allows us to gather all the
information required to predict the
weather information such as the climate
change details wind direction
precipitation previous weather reports
and so on after all this data is
collected it becomes easier for us to
spot a trend and identify what's going
to happen next by analyzing all of this
big data a weather prediction engine
works on this analysis it predicts the
weather of every region across the world
for any given time by using such a tool
we can be well prepared to face any
climate change or any natural Calamity
let's take an example of a landslide and
try to understand how big data is used
to tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the University of Melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and Applied Mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your pre previous browsing history and
your purchase data Publishers then
display what you like in the form of ads
which will in turn catch your interest
in looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
Revenue Big Data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations Etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made Available to You by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
History your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing so the site is able to retain
and engage its customer for a longer
time next is customer churn analysis in
simple words customer churn happens when
a customer stops a subscription with a
service predicting and preventing this
is of Paramount importance to any
organization by analyzing the behavioral
patterns of previously churned customers
an organization can identify which of
their current customers are likely to
churn by analyzing all of this data the
organization can then Implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of Starbucks big data is
effectively used by the Starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the the store they visit and to
the time they purchase all of this data
is fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new Starbucks location the
system analyzes all their data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is Healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available Big Data
medical researchers are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence Personal Care is
very important person care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history and individuals medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
Medical Treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's re-admission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics Big Data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
American Healthcare Company United
Healthcare uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the Healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics Logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vehicle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available Workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also Finds Its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
our use case of UPS as you know UPS is
one of the biggest shipping company in
the world they have a huge customer
database and they work on data every
minute UPS uses big data to gather
different kinds of data regarding the
weather the traffic jams the geography
the locations and so on after collecting
all this data they analyze it to
discover the best and the fastest route
to the destination in addition to this
they also use big data to change the
routes in real time this is how
efficiently UPS leverages Big Data next
up we have a very interesting sector
that is the travel and tourism sector
the global tourism Market is expected to
grow in the near future big data is used
in various ways in this sector let us
look into a few of them hotels can
increase their revenue by adjusting the
room tariffs depending on the peak
Seasons such as holiday seasons festive
seasons and so on the tools industry
uses all of this data to anticipate the
demand and maximize their revenue big
data is also used by Resorts and hotels
to analyze various details regarding
their competitors this analysis result
helps them to incorporate all the good
facilities their competitors are
providing and by doing so the hotel is
able to flourish further a customer
always comes back if they are offered
good packages which are more than just
the basic ones looking into a customer's
past travel history likes and
preferences hotels can provide its
customers with personalized experiences
which will interest them highly
investing in an area which could be the
Hub of Tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
Homestay networks Airbnb and see how big
data is used by them Airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences Airbnb filters
out the best result Big Data Works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
Law and Order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself Big Data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region this
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop governments have
to always be on the lookout for better
development a public survey voices the
opinion of a country's citizens
analyzing all the data collected from
such service can help governments build
better policies and services which will
benefit its citizens let us now move on
to our use case did you know that the
New York Police Department uses big data
analytics to protect its citizens the
department prevents and identifies
Crimes by analyzing a huge amount of
data which includes fingerprints certain
emails and records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes now when we talk
about evolution of big data we have
known that data has evolved in last five
years like never before now in fact
before going to Big Data or before
understanding these Solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards Big
Data technology in solution I would like
to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in big day why is there a
certain rush in Industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on Technologies which allow them
to use The Spectator think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use Legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided not to ignore any
data as being economical now we can talk
about different platforms through which
data is generated take an example of
social media like Twitter Facebook
Instagram WhatsApp YouTube
you have e-commerce and various portals
say eBay Amazon Flipkart alibaba.com and
then you have various Tech Giants such
as Google Oracle sap Amazon Microsoft
and so on so lots of data is getting
generated every day in every business
sector the point here is that
organizations have slowly started
realizing that they would be interested
in working on all the data now the
question which I asked was why are the
organizations interested in big data and
some of you might have already answered
or thought about that organizations are
interested in doing precise analysis or
they want to work on different formats
of data such as structured unstructured
semi-structured data organizations are
interested in gaining insights or
finding the hidden treasure in the
so-called big data and this is the main
reason where organizations are
interested in
now there are various use cases there
are various use cases we can compare
that organizations from past 50 or more
than 50 years have been handling huge
amount of data they have been working on
huge volume of data but the question
here is have they worked on all the data
or have they worked on some portion of
it what have they used to store this
data and if they have used something to
store this data what is happening what
is what is changing now when we talk
about the businesses we cannot avoid
talking about the dynamism involved now
any organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
Solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on WhatsApp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on YouTube did
you guys know that YouTube is the second
largest search engine after Google every
minute users send 31.25 million messages
and watch 2.77 million videos on
Facebook Walmart handles more than 1
million customer transactions every hour
Google 40 000 search queries are
performed on Google per second that is
3.46 million searches a day in fact you
could also say that a lot of times
people when they are loading up the
Google page is basically just to check
their internet connection however that
is also generating data IDC reports that
by 2025 real-time data will be more than
a quarter of all the data and by 2025
the volume of Digital Data will increase
to 163 Zeta bytes that is we are not
even talking about gigabytes or
terabytes anymore we are talking about
petabytes exabytes and zetabytes and
zetabytes means 10 to the power 21 bytes
so this is how data has evolved now you
can talk about different companies which
would want to use their data to take
business decisions they would want to
collect the data store it and analyze it
and that's how they would be interested
in drawing insights for the business now
this is just a simple example about
Facebook and what it does to work on the
data now before we go to Facebook you
could always check in Google by just
typing in companies using big data and
if we say companies using big data we
should be able to find a list of
different companies which are using big
data for different use cases there are
various sources from where you can find
we could also search for solution that
is Hadoop which we'll discuss later but
you could always say companies using
Hadoop and that should take you to the
Wiki page which will basically help you
know what are the different companies
which are using this so-called solution
called Hadoop okay now coming back to
what we were discussing about so
organizations are interested in Big Data
as we discussed in gaining insights they
would want to use the data to find
hidden information which probably they
ignored earlier now take an example of
rdbms what is big biggest drawback in
using an rdbms now you might think that
rdbms is known for stability and
consistency and organizations would be
interested in storing their data in
Oracle or db2 or MySQL or Microsoft SQL
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
question which I would ask is do we have
access to 100 of data being online in
rdbms the answer is no we would only
have 10 or 20 or 30 percent of data
online and rest of the data would be
archived which means that if an
organization is interested in working on
all the data they would have to move the
data from the archived storage to the
processing layer and that would involve
bandwidth consumption now this is one of
the biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do
not have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited I had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of Facebook now
this shows what Facebook does with its
big data and we'll come to what is Big
Data but let's understand the use case
now Facebook collects huge volumes of
user data whether that is SMS whether
that is likes whether that is
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles Now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect Facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way Beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize The
Experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user Behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what Facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
into Facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how Facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that receive the most
comments and likes okay there was
something called as I voted that was
used for 2016 elections with reminders
and directions to tell users their time
and place of polling also something
called as safety checks in incidents
such as earthquake hurricane or mass
shooting Facebook gives you safety
checks now these are some examples where
Facebook is using big data and that
brings us to the question what is Big
Data this was just an example where we
discussed about one company which is
making use of that data which has been
accumulated and it's not only for
companies
social media oriented like Facebook
where data is important take an example
of IBM take an example of JPMorgan Chase
type
example of G of G or any other
organization which is collecting huge
amount of data they would all want to
gather insights they would want to
analyze the data they would want to be
more precise in building their services
or Solutions which can take care of
their customers so what is Big Data big
data is basically a term it is used to
describe the data that is too large and
complex to store in traditional
databases and as I gave an example it's
not just about storing the data it is
also about what you can do with the data
it also means that if there is a lot of
dynamism involved can you change the
underlying storage and handle any kind
of data that comes in now before we get
into that let's just understand what is
Big Data so big data is basically a term
which has been given to categorize the
data if it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five V's of Big Data volume velocity
variety value velocity although these
are five V's but then there are other
V's which also categorize the data as
Big Data such as volatility validity
viscosity virality of data okay so these
are five V's of big data and if the data
has one or all of these characteristics
then it can be considered as big
including the other ways which I just
mentioned so volume basically means
incredible amount of data huge volumes
of data data generated every second now
that could be used for batch processing
that could be used for real-time stream
processing okay you might have data
being generated from different kind of
devices like your cell phones your
social media websites online
transactions variable devices servers
and these days with iot we are also
talking about data of getting generated
via internet of things that is you could
have different devices which could be
communicating to to each other you could
be getting data from Radars or leaders
or even camera sensors so there is a
huge volume of data which is getting
generated and if we are talking about
data which has huge volume which is
getting generated constantly or has been
accumulated over a period of time we
would say that is Big Data velocity now
this is one more important aspect of big
data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure mine or analyze the data then we
are certainly talking about Big Data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here I would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this I
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if I look at this log file
and if I would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be it is structured data it
has specific delimiters such as space it
has data which is separated by space and
if I had a hundred or thousand or
million rows which had similar kind of
data I could certainly store that in a
table I could have a predefined schema
to store this data so I would call the
one which is highlighted as structured
but if I look at this portion where I
would look at a combination of this kind
of data where some data has a pattern
and some data doesn't now this is an
example of semi-structured data so if I
would have a predefined structure to
store this data probably the pattern of
data would break the structure and if I
look at all the data then I would
certainly call it unstructured data
because there is no clear schema which
can Define the
now this is what I mean by variety of
data that is structured data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be easily understood you
have semi-structured which could be like
in XML or Json or even your Excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructed
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or
cleaning up of data happening and then
finally you would want to draw value
from that data but from all the data
collected what percentage of data gives
us value and if all my data can give me
value then why wouldn't I use it this is
an aspect of big data right veracity now
this means the quality of data billions
of dollars are lost every year by
organizations because the data which was
collected was not of
probably they collected lot of data and
then it was erroneous take an example of
autonomous driving projects which are
happening in Europe or us where there
are car fleets which are on the road
collecting data via radar sensors and
Camera sensors and when this data has to
be processed to train algorithms it has
realized that sometimes the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate or had lot
of errors and all this process of
collecting the data becomes a repetitive
task because the quality of data was not
good this is just one example we can
take example from healthcare industry or
stock markets or financial institutions
and so on so on so extracting loads of
data is not useful if the data is messy
or poor in quality and that basically
means that veracity is a very important
V of big data now apart from veracity
volume variety velocity and value we
have the other v such as viscosity how
dense the data is validity is the data
still valid volatility is my data
volatile or virality is the data viral
now all of these different V's
categorize the data as big data now here
we would like to talk on a big data case
study
have taken an example of Google which
obviously is one of the companies which
is churning and working on huge amount
of data now it's actually said that if
you compare one grain of sand with one
byte of data then Google is processing
or Google is handling Whole World's sand
every
that is the kind of data which Google is
Google is now in early 2000 and since
then when the number of Internet users
started growing Google also faced a lot
of
restoring increasing user data and using
the traditional servers to manage that
now that was a challenge which Google
started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could Right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second no doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 MBS of data and consumed
tens of billions of CPU Cycles based on
these queries so the requirement was
that they wanted to have a large
distributed highly fault tolerant file
system large to store to capture process
huge amount of data distributed because
they could not rely just on one server
even if that had multiple disks stacked
up that was not an efficient Choice what
would happen if this particular machine
failed what would happen if the whole
server was down so they needed a
distributed storage and a distributed
computing environment they needed
something which can be highly fault
tolerant right so this was the
requirement which Google had and the
solution which came out as a result was
GFS Google file system now let's look at
how GFS works so normally in any
particular Linux system or Linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set of processes you would have set
of files and directories which could
store the data GFS was different so to
facilitate GFS we which would store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had one master
and multiple chunk servers or you could
say slave servers slave machines Master
machine was to contain metadata was to
contain data about data when we say
metadata we are talking about
information about data and then you have
the chunk servers or the slave machines
which could be storing data in a
distributed fashion now any client or an
API or an application which would want
to read the data would first Contact the
master server it would contact the
machine where the master process was
running and client would place a request
of reading the data or showing an
interest of reading the data internally
what it is doing is it is requesting for
metadata your API or an application
would want to know from where it can
read the data Master server which has
metadata where that is in Ram or disk we
can discuss that later but then Master
server would have the metadata and it
would know which are the chunk servers
or the slave machines where the data was
stored in it
is fashion Master would respond back
with the metadata information to the
client and then client could use that
information to read
to these these slave machines where
now this is what the process or set of
processes work together to make GFS So
when you say a chunk server we would
basically have the files getting divided
into fixed size chunks now how would
they get divided so there would be some
kind of Chunk size or a block size which
would determine that if the file is
bigger than the pre-decided chunk size
then it would be split into smaller
chunks and be distributed across the
chunk servers or the slave machines if
the file was smaller then it would still
use one chunk or a block to get stored
on the underlying slave machines so
these chunk servers or slave machines
are the ones which actually store the
data on local disks as your Linux files
client which is interacting with Master
for metadata and then interacting with
chunk servers for read write operations
would be the one which would be
externally connecting to the cluster so
this is how it would look so you have a
Master which would obviously be
receiving some kind of heartbeats from
the chunk servers to know their status
and receive information in the form of
packets which would let the master know
which machines were available for
storage which machines already had data
and master would build up the metadata
within itself the files would be broken
down into chunks for example we can look
at file one it is broken down into chunk
one and
and file 2 has one chunk which is one
portion of it and then you have file to
recite you on some other chunk server
which also lets us know that there is
some kind of Auto replication for this
file system right and the data which is
getting stored in the chunk could have a
data of 64 MB now that chunk size could
be changed based on the data size but
Google file system had the basic size of
the chunk as 64 MB each chunk would be
applicated on multiple servers the
default replication was three and that
could again be increased or decreased as
per requirement this would also mean
that if a particular slave machine or a
chunk server would die or would get
killed or would crash there would never
be any data loss because a replica of
data residing on the failed machine
would still be available on some other
slave server chunk server or slave
machine now this helped Google to store
and process huge volumes of data in a
distributed Manner and does have a fault
tolerant distributed scalable storage
which could allow them to store huge
amount of data now that was just one
example which actually led to the
solution which today we call
and when we talk about Big Data here I
would like to ask you some questions
that if we were talking about the rdbms
case take an example of uh something
like NASA which was working on a a
project called seti search of
extraterrestrial intelligence now this
was a project where they were looking
for a solution to take care of their
problem the problem was that they would
roughly send some waves in space capture
those waves back and then analyze this
data to find if there was any
extraterrestrial objects
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer computing now volunteer
Computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their RAM and storage from
their machines when they are
then how would that happen basically
download some kind patch on their
machine which would run as a screensaver
and if the user is not using seen some
portion of data could be transferred to
these machines
machines intermittent storage and
processing using lab now this sounds
very interesting and this sounds very
easy however it would have its own
challenges right think about security
think about integrity but those those
problems are not bigger as much as is
the requirement of bandwidth and this is
the same thing which happens in rdbms if
you would have to move data from
archived solution to the processing
layer that would consume huge amount of
bandwidth Big Data brings its own
challenges huge amount of data is
getting generated every day now the
biggest challenge is storing this huge
volume of data and especially when this
data is getting generated with a lot of
variety when it can have different kind
of formats where it could be viral it
could be having a lot of value and
nobody has looked into the veracity of
data but the primary problem would be
handling this huge volume of data
variety of the data would bring in
challenges of storing it in Legacy
systems if processing of the data was
required now here again I would suggest
you need to think what is the difference
between reading a data and process
So reading might just mean bringing in
the data from disk and doing some i o
operations and processing would mean
reading the data probably doing some
Transformations on it extracting some
useful information from it and then
storing it in the same format or
probably in a different format so
processing this massive volume of data
is the Second Challenge organizations
don't just store their big data they
would eventually want to use it to
process it to gather some insights now
processing and extracting insights from
Big Data would take huge amount of time
unless and until there was an efficient
solution to handle and process this big
data securing the data that's again a
concern for organizations
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the CPU Cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to Hadoop
data its own benefits and here we have a
solution which is a
now what is Hadoop it open source
framework for storing data and running
applications on clusters of commodity
Hardware Hadoop is an open source
framework and before we discuss on two
main components of Hadoop it would be
good to look into the link which I was
suggesting earlier that is companies
using Hadoop and any person who would be
interested in learning Big Data should
start somewhere here where you could
list down different companies what kind
of setup they have why are they having
Hadoop what kind of processing they are
doing and how are they using these
so-called Hadoop clusters to process and
in fact store capture and process huge
amount of data another link which I
would suggest is looking at different
distributions of
of any person who is interested in
learning in Big Data
about different distributions of Hadoop
now in Linux we have different
distributions like Ubuntu Centos Red Hat
Suzy dbn in the same way you have
different distributions of Hadoop which
we can look on the Wiki page and this is
the link which talks about products that
include Apache Hadoop or derivative
works and Commercial support basically
means that Apache Hadoop the sole
products that can be called a release of
Apache Hadoop come from apache.org
that's an open source community and then
you have various vendor-specific
distributions like Amazon web services
you have cloud data you have Horton
works you have IBM's big inside you have
map R all these are different
distributions of
so basically all of these
vendor-specific distributions are
depending or using on core Apache Hadoop
in brief we can say that these are the
vendors which take up the Apache Hadoop
package it within a cluster management
solution so that users who intend to use
Apache Hadoop would not have
difficulties of setting up a cluster
setting up a framework they could just
use a vendor specific distribution with
its cluster installation Solutions
clustered management solution and easily
plan deploy install and manage a cluster
let's rewind to the days before the
world turn digital back then minuscule
amounts of data were generated at a
relatively sluggish Pace all the data
was mostly documents and in the form of
rows and columns storing or processing
this data wasn't much trouble as a
single storage unit and processor
combination would do the job but as
years passed by the internet took the
World by storm giving rise to tons of
data generated in a multitude of forms
and formats every microsecond
semi-structured and unstructured data
was available now in the form of emails
images audio and video to name a few all
this data became collectively known as
Big Data although fascinating it became
nearly impossible to handle this big
data and a storage unit processor
combination was obviously not enough so
what was the solution
multiple storage units and processors
were undoubtedly the need of the hour
this concept was incorporated in the
framework of Hadoop that could store and
process vast amounts of any data
efficiently using a cluster of commodity
Hardware Hadoop consisted of three
components that were specifically
designed to work on big data in order to
capitalize on data the first step is
storing it the first component of Hadoop
is its storage unit the Hadoop
distributed file system or hdfs
storing massive data on one computer is
unfeasible hence data is distributed
amongst many computers and stored in
blocks so if you have 600 megabytes of
data to be stored hdfs splits the data
into multiple blocks of data that are
then stored on several data nodes in the
cluster 128 megabytes is the default
size of each block hence 600 megabytes
will be split into four blocks a b c and
d of 128 megabytes each and the
remaining 88 megabytes in the last block
e so now you might be wondering what if
one data node crashes do we lose that
specific piece of data well no that's
the beauty of hdfs hdfs makes copies of
the data and stores it across multiple
systems for example when block a is
created it is replicated with a
replication factor of 3 and stored on
different data nodes this is termed the
replication method by doing so data is
not lost at any cost even if one data
node crashes making hdfs fault tolerant
after storing the data successfully it
needs to be processed this is where the
second component of Hadoop mapreduce
comes into play in the traditional data
processing method entire data would be
processed on a single machine having a
single processor this consumed time and
was inefficient especially when
processing large volumes of a variety of
data to overcome this mapreduce splits
data into parts and processes each of
them separately on different data nodes
the individual results are then
aggregated to give the final output
let's try to count the number of
occurrences of words taking this example
first the input is split into five
separate parts based on full stops the
next step is the mapper phase where the
occurrence of each word is counted and
allocated a number after that depending
on the words similar words are shuffled
sorted and grouped following which in
the reducer phase all the grouped words
are given a count finally the output is
displayed by aggregating the results all
this is done by writing a simple program
similarly mapreduce processes each part
of Big Data individually and then sums
the result at the end this improves load
balancing and saves a considerable
amount of time
now that we have our mapreduce job ready
it is time for us to run it on the
Hadoop cluster this is done with the
help of a set of resources such as RAM
Network bandwidth and CPU multiple jobs
are run on Hadoop simultaneously and
each of them needs some resources to
complete the task successfully to
efficiently manage these resources we
have the third component of Hadoop which
is yarn yet another resource negotiator
or yarn consists of a resource manager
node Manager application master and
containers the resource manager assigns
resources node managers handle the nodes
and monitor the resource usage in the
node the containers hold a collection of
physical resources suppose we want to
process the mapreduce job we had created
first the application Master requests
the container from the node manager once
the node manager gets the resources it
sends them to the resource manager this
way yarn processes job requests and
manages cluster resources in Hadoop in
addition to these components Hadoop also
has various Big Data tools and
Frameworks dedicated to managing
processing and analyzing data the Hadoop
ecosystem comprises several other
components like Hive Pig Apache spark
Flume and scoop to name a few the Hadoop
ecosystem works together on big data
management before we dive into the
technical side of Hadoop we're going to
take a little detour to try to give you
a visual understanding and relate it to
maybe a more life setup and we're going
to go to the farm in this case so we
have in a farm far away I almost wish
they'd put far far away it does remind
me a little bit of a Star Wars theme so
we're going to look at fruit at a farm
we have Jack who harvestses grapes and
then sells it in the nearby town after
harvesting he stores his produce in a
storage shed or a storage room in this
case we found out though is there was a
high demand for other fruits so he
started harvesting apples and oranges as
well hopefully it has a couple fills
with these different fruit trees growing
and he said up there and you can see
that he's working hard to harvest all
these different fruits but he has a
problem here because there's only one of
him so he can't really do more work so
what he needs to do then is hire two
more people to work with him with this
harvesting is done simultaneously so
instead of him trying to harvest all
this different fruit he now has two more
people in there who are putting their
food away and harvesting a forum now the
storage room becomes a bottleneck to
store and access all the fruits in a
single storage area so they can't fit
all the fruit in one place so Jack
decides to distribute the storage area
and give each one of them a separate
storage and you can look at this
computer terms we have our people that
are the processors we have our fruit
that's a data and you can see it's
storing it in the different storage
rooms so you can see me popping up there
getting my uh hello I want fruit basket
of three grapes two apples and three
oranges I'm getting ready for a
breakfast with family a little large
family my family's not that large to
complete the order on time all of them
work parallely with their own storage
space so here we have a process of
retrieving or querying the data and you
can see from the one storage space he
pulls out three grapes she pulls out two
apples and then another storage room he
pulls out three oranges and we complete
a nice fruit basket and this solution
helps them to complete the order on time
without any hassle all of them are happy
and they're prepared for an increase in
demand in the future so they they now
have this growth system where you can
just keep hiring on new people they can
continue to grow and develop a very
large farm so how does this story relate
to Big Data and I hinted at that a
little bit earlier the limited data only
one processor one storage unit was
needed I remember back in the 90s they
would just upgrade the computer instead
of having a small computer you would
then spend money for a huge Mainframe
with all the flashing lights on it then
the Craig computers were really massive
nowadays A lot of the computers it sits
on our desktop are powerful as the
mainframes they had back then so it's
pretty amazing how time has changed but
you used to be able to do everything on
one computer and you had structured data
and a database you stored your
structured data in so most of the time
you're acquiring databases SQL queries
just think of it as a giant spreadsheet
with rows and columns where everything
has a very specific size and fits neatly
in that rows and columns and back in the
90s this was a nice setup you just
upgraded your computer you would get
yourself a nice big sun computer or
Mainframe if you had a lot of data and a
lot of stuff going on and it was very
easy to do soon though the data
generation increased leading to high
volume of data along with different data
formats and so you can imagine in
today's world this year we will generate
more data than all the previous years
summed together we will generate more
data just this year than all the
previous years sum together and that's
the way it's been going for some time
and you can see we have a variety of
data we have our structured data which
is what we're you think about a database
with rows and columns and easy to look
at nice spreadsheet we have our
semi-structured data they have emails as
an example here that would be one
example your XML your HTML web pages and
we have unstructured data if you ever
look through your folder on photos I
have photos that were taken on my phone
with high quality I've got photos from a
long time ago I got web photos low
quality so just in my pictures alone
none of them are the same you know there
certainly are groups of them that are
but overall there are a lot of variety
in size and setup so a single processor
was not enough to process such high
volume of different kinds of data as it
was very time consuming you can imagine
that if you are Twitter with millions of
Twitter feeds you're not going to be
able to do a query across one server
there's just no way that's going to
happen unless people don't mind waiting
a year to get the history of their
tweets or look something up hence we
start doing multiple processors so
they're used to process high volume of
data and this saved time so we're moving
forward we've got multiple processors
the single storage unit became the
bottlenecked due to which network
overhead was generated so now you have
your network coming in and each one of
these servers has to wait before it can
grab the data from the single stored
unit maybe have a SQL Server there with
a nice setup or a file system going the
solution was to use distributed storage
for each processor this enabled easy
access to storage origin access to data
so this makes a lot of sense you have
multiple workers multiple storage units
just like we had our storage room and
the different fruit coming in your
variety you can see that nice parallel
to working on a farm now we're dealing
with a lot of data it's all about the
data now this method worked and there
were no network overhead generated
you're not getting a bottleneck
somewhere where people are just waiting
for data being pulled or being processed
this is known as parallel processing
with distributed storage so parallel
processing distributed storage and you
can see here the parallel processing is
your different computers running the
processes and distributed storage here
is a quick demo on on setting up
Cloudera quick start VM in case you are
interested in working on a standalone
cluster you can download the Cloudera
quick start VM so you can just type in
download Cloud error quick start VM and
you can search for package now this can
be used to set up a quick start VM which
would be a single node Cloudera based
cluster so you can click on this link
and then basically based on the platform
which you would be choosing to install
such as using a VM box or which version
of Cloudera you would install so here I
can select a platform so I can choose
virtual box and then you can click on
get it now so give your details and
basically then it should allow you to
download the quick start VM which would
look something like this and once you
have the zip file which is downloaded
you can unzip it which can then be used
to set up a single node Cloudera cluster
so once you have downloaded the zip file
that would look something like this so
you would have a quick start virtual box
and then a virtual boss disk now this
can be used to set up a cluster ignore
these files which are related to Amazon
machines and we you don't need to have
that so you would just have this and
this can be used to set up a cloud
cluster so for this to be set up you can
click on file import Appliance and here
you can choose your quick start VM by
looking into downloads quick start VM
select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of CPU Ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image dot vmdk file into your VM box
once this is done we will have to change
the specifications or machines to use
two CPU cores minimum and give a little
more RAM because Cloudera quick start VM
is very CPU intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive I will give
two CPU cores and 5gb RAM and that
should be enough for us to bring up a
quick start VM which gives us a Cloudera
distribution of Hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in Cloudera cluster
working with stfs and other Hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
VM for our practice here the importing
of Appliance is done and we see Cloudera
quick start machine is added to my list
of machines I can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned I would
like to give it more RAM and more CPU
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least five and
click on processor and let's give it two
CPU cores which would at least be better
than using one CPU core Network it goes
for Nat and that's fine click on OK and
we would want to start this machine so
that it uses two CPU cores 5gb RAM and
it should bring up my Cloudera quick
start VM now let's go ahead and start
this machine which has our quick start
VM it might take initially some time to
start up because internally there will
be various Cloudera Services which will
be starting up and those Services need
to be up for our Cloudera quick start VM
to be accessible so unlike your Apache
Hadoop cluster where we start our
cluster and we will be starting all our
processes in case of Cloudera it is your
Cloudera SCM server and agents which
take care of starting off of your
services and starting up of your
different roles for those Services I
explained in my previous session that
for a Cloudera cluster it would be these
Services let me show you that so in case
of Apache cluster we start our services
that is we start our cluster by running
script and then basically those scripts
will individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloud data we would always have a
Cloudera SCM server which would be
running on one machine and then
including that machine we would have
cloud and ICM agents which would
on multiple machines similarly if we had
a hortonworks cluster we would have
ambari server starting up on the first
machine and the number agents running on
other machines so pure server component
knows what are the services which are
set up what are their configurations and
agents running on every node are
responsible to send heartbeats to the
server receive instructions and then
take care of starting and stopping off
of individual roles on different
machines in case of our single node
cluster setup in quick start VM we would
just have one SCM server and one ICM
agent which will start on the machine
then take care of
all the role which need to be started
for your different services so we will
just wait for our machine to come up and
basically have clouded SCM server and
agent running and once we have that we
need to follow few steps so that we can
have the Cloudera admin console
accessible which allows you to browse
the cluster look at different Services
look at the roles for different services
and also work with your cluster either
using command line or using the web
interface that is Hue now that my
machine has come up and it already is
connected to the internet which we can
see here we need to do certain things so
that we can have our admin console
accessible at this point of time you can
click on Terminal and check if you have
access to the cluster so here type in
hostname and that shows you your host
name which is quickstart.cloudera we can
also type in hdfs command to see if we
have access and if my cluster is working
these commands are same as you would
give them in a Apache Hadoop cluster or
in any other distribution of Hadoop
sometimes when your cluster is up and
you have access to the terminal it might
take few seconds or few minutes before
there is a connection established
between Cloudera CM server and cloud and
ICM agent running in the background
which takes care of your cluster I have
given hdfs DFS list command which
basically should show me what by default
exists on my sdfs let's just give it a
couple of seconds before it shows us the
output we can also check by giving a
service Cloudera SCM server status and
here it tells me that if you would want
to use Cloudera Express free run this
command it needs 8GB of RAM and it leads
to Virtual CPU cores and it also
mentions it may take several minutes
before Cloud error manager has started I
can log in as root here and then give
the command service Cloudera SCM server
status remember the password for root is
clouded out so it basically says that if
you would want to check the settings it
is good to have Express Edition running
so we can close this my sdfs access is
working fine let's close the terminal
and here we have launch Cloudera Express
click on this and that will give you
that you need to give a command which is
Force let's copy this command let's open
a different terminal and let's give this
command like this which will then go
ahead and shut down your Cloudera Based
Services and then it will restart it
only after which you will be able to
access your admin console so let's just
give it a couple of minutes before it
does this and then we will have access
to our admin console here if you see it
is starting the Cloudera manager server
again it is waiting for Cloudera manager
API then starting the cloud data manager
agents and then configuring the
deployment as per the new settings which
we have given as to use the express
edition of cloud error once all this is
done it will say the cluster has been
restarted and the admin console can be
accessed by ID and password as clouded
up we'll give it a couple of more
minutes and once this is done we are
ready to use our admin console now that
deployment has been configured client
configurations have also been deployed
and it has restarted the Cloudera
Management Service a it gives you an
access to Quick Start admin console
using user username and that's what is
Cloudera let's try accessing it so we
can open up the browser here and let's
change this to 7180 that's the default
port and that shows the admin console
which is coming up now here we can log
in as Cloud era Cloud error and then
let's click on login now as I said
Cloudera is very CPU intensive and
memory intensive so it would slow down
since we have not given enough GB Ram to
our Cloud error cluster and thus it will
be advisable to stop or even remove the
services which we don't need now as of
now if we look at the services all of
them look in a stop status and that's
good in one way because we can then go
ahead and remove the services which we
will not use in the beginning and later
we can anytime add services to the
cluster so for example I can click on
key value store here and then I can
scroll down where it says delete to
remove this service from the admin
console now anytime you are removing a
particular service it will only remove
the service from the management by Cloud
attack manager all the role groups under
this service will be removed from host
templates so we can click on delete now
if this service was depending on some
other service it would have prompted me
with a message that removed the relevant
services on which this particular
service depends if the service was
already running then it would have given
me a message that the service has to be
stopped before it can be deleted from
the cloud error at
now this is my admin console which
allows you to click on Services look at
the different roles and processes which
are running for this service we anyways
have access to our Cloud era cluster
from the terminal using our regular sdfs
or yarn or mapred commands now I removed
a service I will also remove solar which
we will not be using for the beginning
but then it depends on your choice so we
can here scroll down to delete it and
that says that before deleting the solar
service you must remove the dependencies
on the service from the configuration of
following services that is Hue now Hue
is a web interface which allows you to
work with your sdfs and that is
depending on this so click on configure
service dependency and here we can make
sure that our Hue service does not
depend on a particular service we are
removing so that then we can have a
clean removal of the service so I'll
click on none and I will say save
changes once this is done then we can go
ahead and try removing the solar service
from our admin console which will reduce
some load on my Management console which
will also allow me to work faster on my
cluster now here we have removed the
dependency of hue on solar so we can
click on this and then we can delete
remember I am only doing this so that my
cluster becomes little lighter and I can
work on my focus services at any point
of time if you want to add more services
to your cluster you can anytime do that
you can fix different configuration
issues like what we see here with
different warning messages and here we
have these Services which are already
existing now if we don't need any of the
service I can click on the drop down and
click on delete again this says that's
group 2 also has relevance to Hue so Hue
as a web interface also depends on scope
too as of now we'll make it none at any
point of time later you can add the
services by clicking the add service
option now this is a cluster to which
you have admin access and this is a
quick start VM which gives you a single
node Cloud error cluster which you can
use for Learning and practicing so here
we'll click on scope 2 and then we will
say delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console is managing right so
once this is done we have removed three
services which we did not need we can
even remove scoop as a client and if we
need we can add that later now there are
various other alerts which your cloud
data admin console shows and we can
always fix them by clicking on the
health issues or configuration issues we
can click here and see what is the
health issue it is pointing to if that
is a critical one or if that can be
ignored so it says there is an issue
with a clock offset which basically
relates to an ntp service network time
protocol which makes sure that one or
multiple machines are in the same time
zone and are in sync so for now we can
click on suppress and we can just say
suppress for all hosts and we can say
look into it later and confirm so now we
will not have that health issue reported
that probably the ntp service and the
machines might not be in sync now that
does not have an impact for our use case
as of now but if we have a Kerberos kind
of setup which is for security then
basically this offset and time zone
becomes important so we can ignore this
message and we are still good to use the
cluster we also have other configuration
issues and you can click on this which
might talk about the Heap size or the
ram which is available for machines it
talks about zookeeper should be in odd
numbers Hue does not have a load
balancer sdfs only has one data node but
all of these issues are not to be
worried upon because this is a single
node cluster setup so if you want to
avoid all of these warnings you can
always click on suppress and you can
avoid and let your cluster be in all
but that's nothing to worry so we can
click on cluster and basically we can
look at the services so we have removed
some Services which we don't intend to
use now I have also suppressed a offset
warning which is not very critical for
my use case and basically I am good to
start the cluster at any point of time
as I said if you would want to add
services this is the actions button
button which you can
services we will just say restart my
cluster which will restart all the
services one by one starting from
zookeeper as the first service to come
up we can always click on this Arrow
Mark and see what is happening in the
services what services are coming up and
in which order if you have any issues
you can always click on the link next to
it which will take you to the logs and
we can click on close to let it happen
in the background so this will basically
let my services restart one by one and
my cluster will then become completely
accessible either using Hue as a web
interface or quick start terminal which
allows you to give your commands now
while my machines are coming up you can
click on host and you can have a look at
all the hosts we have as of now only one
which will also tell you how many rolls
or processes are running on this machine
so that is 25 rolls it tells you what is
the disk usage it tells you what is the
physical memory being used and you using
this host tab we can add new host to the
cluster we can check the configuration
we can check all the hosts
gnostics you can look at the logs which
will give you access to all the logs you
can even select the sources from which
you would want to have the logs or you
can give the host name you can click on
search
build your own charts you can also do
the admin stuff by adding different
users or enabling security using the
administration tab so since we have
clicked on restart of a cluster we will
slowly start seeing all the services one
by one coming up starting with zookeeper
to begin with and once we have our
cluster up and running whether that is
showing all services in green or in a
different status we still should be able
to access the service now as we saw in
Apache Hadoop cluster even here we can
click on sdfs and we can access the web
UI once our hdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web UI link which will
allow you to check things from from sdfs
web interface similarly yarn as a as a
service also has a web interface so as
soon as the service comes up under your
quick links we will have access to the
yarn UI and similarly once the service
comes up we will have access to Hue
which will give you the web interface
which allows you to work with your stfs
which allows you to work with your
different other components within the
cluster without even using the command
line tools or command line options so we
will have to give it some time while the
Cloudera SCM agent on every machine will
be responsible for your
you can always click here it tells that
there are some running commands in the
background which are trying to
still go to the terminal and we can
switch as hdfs user remember sdfs user
is the admin user and it does not have a
password unless you have set one so you
can just log in as hdfs which might ask
you for password initially which we do
not have so the best way to do this is
by logging in as root where the password
is cloud error and then you can log in
as hdfs so that then onwards you can
give your sdfs commands to work with
your file system now since my services
are coming up right now when I try to
give a sdfsdfs command it might not work
or it might also say that it is trying
to connect to the name node which is not
up yet so we will have to give it some
time and only once the name node is up
we will be able to access our hdfs using
commands so this is how you can quickly
set up your quick start and then you can
be working using the command line
options from the terminal like what you
would do in Apache Hadoop cluster you
could
you could web interfaces which allow you
to work with your cluster now if this
usually takes more time so you will have
to give it some time before your
services are up and running and for any
reason if you have issues
might require you to restart your
cluster several times in the beginning
before it gets accustomed to the
settings what you have given and it
starts up the services at any point of
time if you have any error message then
you can always go back and look in logs
and see what is happening and try
starting your cluster so this is how we
set up a quick start VM and you can be
using this to work with your cloud data
cluster we'll start with the big data
challenges and the first thing with the
big data is you can see here we have a
nice chaotic image with all these
different inputs server racks all over
the place graphs being generated just
about everything you can imagine and so
the problems that come up with big data
is one storing it how do you store this
massive amount of data and we're not
talking about a terabyte or 10 terabytes
we're talking a minimum of 10 terabytes
up to petabytes of data and then the
next question is processing and so the
two go hand in hand because when you're
storing the data that might take up a
huge amount of space or you might have a
small amount of data that takes a lot of
processing and so either one will drive
a series of data or processing into the
Big Data Arena so with storing data
storing Big Data was a problem due to
its massive volume just straight up
people would have huge backup tapes and
then you'd have to go through the backup
tapes for hours to go find your data and
a simple query could take days and then
processing processing Big Data consumed
more time and so the Hadoop came up with
a cheap way to process the data it used
to be like I've had some processes that
if I ran on my computer without trying
to use multiple cores and multiple
threads would take years to process just
a simple data analysis can get that
heavy in the data processing and so
processing can be as big of a problem as
the size of the data itself so Hadoop as
a solution this is the solution to Big
Data and big data storage storing Big
Data was a problem due to its massive
volume so we take the Hadoop file system
or the hdfs and now we're able to store
huge data across a large number of
machines and access it like as one file
system and processing Big Data consumed
more time we talked about some processes
you can't even do on your computer so
would take years now the Hadoop with the
map reduce processing Big Data was
faster and I'm going to add a little
notation right here that's really
important to note that Hadoop is the
beginning when we talk about data
processing they've added new processes
on top of the map reduce that even
accelerate it your spark set up and some
other different functionalities but
really the basis of all of it where it
all starts with the most basic concept
is your Hadoop mapreduce let us now look
into the hdfs in detail in the
traditional approach all the data was
stored in a single Central database with
the rise of Big Data a single database
was not enough for storage and I
remember the old Sun computers or the
huge IBM machines with all the flashing
lights now all the data on one of those
can be stored on your phone it's almost
a bit of humor how much this has
accelerated over the years the same
thing with our rise of Big Data no
longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out buy a
sun computer and put it on that one Sun
computer no more can you buy a Craig
machine or an Enterprise IBM server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have three different
databases going on so you might actually
saw this in one where they divided up
the user accounts a through G so on by
the letter and so the first query would
say what's the first letter of this
whatever ID it was and then it would go
into that database to find it so it had
a database telling it which database to
look for stuff that was a long time ago
and to be honest it didn't work really
well nowadays so that was a distributed
database you'd have to track which
database you put it in so what is hdfs
Hadoop distributed file system hdfs is a
specially designed file system for
storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodity is an interesting
term because I mentioned Enterprise
versus commodity and I'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master Daemon there's only one active
name node it manages the data nodes and
stores all the metadata so it stores all
the mapping of where the data is on your
Hadoop file system now the name node is
usually an Enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid name known machine and so
then we have our data nodes our data
node data node data node we have three
here the data node is the slave there
can be multiple data nodes and it stores
the actual data and this is where your
commodity Hardware comes in the best
definition I've heard of commodity
Hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at Hardware that's not as
high-end so where you might have your
main Master node is your Enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the Hadoop file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we are at a log
it just keeps so big until it's too big
or our main Enterprise computer that we
spent all that money on so it would
break actually fails because they still
fail the solution we make copies of the
edit log and the fs image files so
that's pretty straightforward you just
copy them over so you have both the most
recent edits going on and the long term
image of your file system and then we
also create a secondary name node is a
node that maintains the copies of the
edit log and the fs image it combines
them both to get an updated version of
the fs image now the secondary name node
only came in the last oh I guess two
three years where it became as part of
the main system and usually your
secondary name node is also an
Enterprise computer and you'll put them
on separate racks so if you have three
racks of computers you would have maybe
the first two racks would have the name
node and the second rack would have the
secondary name node and the reason you
put them on different racks is you can
have a whole rack go down you could have
somebody literally trip over the power
cable or the switch that goes between
the racks is most common goes down well
if the switch goes down you can usually
switch to the secondary name node and
while you're getting your switch
replaced and replacing that Hardware
because of the way the hdfs works it
still is completely functional so let's
take a look at the name node we have our
edit log our FS image and we have our
secondary name node and you take that it
copies the edit log over and it copies
the fs image and you can see right here
you have all the different contents on
your main name node now also on your
secondary name node and then your
secondary name node will actually take
these two your edit log and your FS
image and it will make a copy so you
have a full FS image that contains its
current it's up to date the secondary
nade node creates a periodic checkpoint
of the files and then it updates the new
FS image into the name node now it used
to be this all occurred on the name node
before you had a secondary name node so
now you can use your secondary node to
both back up everything going on the
name node and it does that lifting in
the back where you're combining your
edit log and bring your FS image so it's
current and then you end up with a new
edit log and a new you have your FS
image updated and you start a fresh edit
log this process of updating happens
every hour and that's how it's scheduled
you can actually change those schedules
but that is the standard is to update
every hour so let's we took a look at
the the master node and the you know the
name node and the secondary name node
let's take a look at the cluster
architecture of our Hadoop file system
the hdfs cluster architecture so we have
our name node in this store orders of
metadata and we have our block location
so we have our FS image plus our edit
log and we have the backup FS image and
edit log and then we have so you have
your rack we have our switch on top
remember I was talking about the switch
that's the most common thing to go in
the rack is the switches and underneath
the rack you have your different data
nodes you have your data node one two
three four five maybe you have 10 15 on
this rack you can stack them pretty high
nowadays uh used to be you'd only get
about 10 servers on there but now you
see racks that contain a lot more and
then you have multiple racks so we're
not talking about just one rack we also
have you know rack two rack three four
five six and so on until you have Rack
in so if you had a hundred data nodes we
would be looking at 10 racks of 10 data
nodes each and that is literally 10
commodity server computers hardware and
we have a core switch which maintains
Network bandwidth and connects the name
node to the data nodes so just like each
rack has a switch that connects all your
nodes on the rack you now have core
switches that can all the racks together
and these also Connect into our name
node setup so now I can look up your FS
image and your edit log and pull that
information your metadata out so we've
looked at the architecture from the name
node coming down and you have your
metadata at your Block locations this
then sorts it out you have your core
switches which connect everything all
your different racks and then each
individual rack has their own switches
which connect all the different nodes
and to the core switches so now let's
talk about the actual data blocks what's
actually sitting on those commodity
machines and so the Hadoop file system
splits massive files into small chunks
these chunks are known as data blocks
each file in the Hadoop file system is
stored as a data block and we have a
nice picture here where it looks like a
Lego if you ever played with the Legos
as a kid it's a good example we just
stack that data right on top of each
other but each block has to be the same
symmetry has to be the same size so that
it can track it easily and the default
size of one data block is usually 128
megabytes now you can go in and change
that this standard is pretty solid as
far as most data is concerned when we're
loading up huge amounts of data and
there's certainly reasons to change it
the 128 megabytes is pretty standard
block so why 128 megabytes if the block
size is smaller then there will be two
mini data blocks along with lots of
metadata which will create overhead so
that's why you don't really want to go
smaller on these data blocks unless you
have a very certain kind of data
similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as I pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your Lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between 1 and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is divided now let's look into how
files are stored in Hadoop file system
so we have a file a text let's see it's
520 megabytes we have block a so we take
128 megabytes out of the 520 and we
store it in block a and then we have
Block B again we're taking 128 megabytes
out of our 520 storing it there and so
on Block C block D and then block e we
only have eight megabytes left so when
you add up 128 plus 128 plus 128 plus
128 you only get 512 and so that last
eight megabytes goes into its own block
the final block uses only the remaining
space for storage data node failure and
replication and this is really where
Hadoop shines this is what makes it this
is why you can use it with commodity
computers this is why you can have
multiple racks and have something go
down all the data blocks are stored in
various data nodes you take each block
you store it at 128 megabytes and then
we're going to put it on different nodes
so here's our block a Block B Block C
from our last example and we have node
one node two node three node four node 5
node 6. and so each one of these
represents a different computer it
literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node 5 crashes well that's a big deal I
mean we might not even have just node
five you might have a whole rack go down
and if you're a company that's building
your whole business off of that you're
going to lose a lot of money so what
does happen when node 5 crashes or the
first rack goes down the data stored in
node 5 will be unavailable as there's no
copy stored elsewhere in this particular
image so the Hadoop file system
overcomes the issue of data node failure
by creating copies of the data this is
known as the replication method and you
can see here we have our six nodes
here's our block a but instead of
storing it just on the first machine
we're actually going to store it on the
second and fourth notes so now it's
spread across three different computers
and in this if these are on a rack one
of these is always on a different rack
so you might have two copies on the same
rack but you never have all three on the
same rack and you always have you never
have more than two copies on one node
there's no reason to have more than one
copy per node and you can see we do the
same thing with Block B Block C is then
also spread out across the different
machines and same with block D and
blocky node 5 crashes will the data
blocks BD and E be lost well in this
example no because we have backups of
all three of those on different machines
the blocks have their copies and the
other nodes due to which the data is not
lost even if the node 5 crashes and
again because they're also stored on
different racks even if the whole rack
goes down you are still up and live with
your Hadoop file system the default
replication factor is three and total
we'll have three copies of each data
block now that can be changed for
different reasons or purposes but you
got to remember when you're looking at a
data center this is all in one huge room
these switches are connecting all these
servers so they can Shuffle the data
back and forth really quick and that is
very important when you're dealing with
big data and you can see here each block
is by default replicated three times
that's the standard there is very very
occasions to do four and there's even
fewer reasons to do two blocks I've only
seen four used once and it was because
they had two data centers and so each
data center kept two different copies
rack awareness in the Hadoop file system
rack is a collection of 30 to 40 data
nodes rack awareness is a concept that
helps to decide where the replica of the
data block should be stored so here we
have rack one we have our data node one
to four remember I was saying they used
to be you'd only put 10 machines and
then it went to 20 now it's 30 to 40. so
you can have a rack with 40 servers on
it then we have rack two and rack three
and we put block one on there replicas a
block a cannot be in the same rack and
so I'll put the replicas onto a
different rack and notice that these are
actually these two are on the same rack
but you'll never have all three stored
on the same Rack in case the whole rack
goes down and replicas of block a are
created in rack two and they actually do
they do by default create the replicas
onto the same rack and that has to do
with the data exchange and maximizing
your processing time and then we have of
course our Block B and it's replicated
onto rack 3 and Block C which will then
replicate onto rack one and so on for
all of your data all the way up to block
D or whatever how much ever data you
have on there hdfs architecture so let's
look at where the architecture is a
bigger picture we looked at the name
node and we stores the metadata names
replicas home food data three so it has
all your different info your metadata
stored on there and then we have our
data nodes and you can see our data
nodes are each on different racks with
our different machines and we have our
name node and you're going to see we
have a heartbeat or pulse here and a lot
of times one of the things that confuses
people sometimes in class is they talk
about nodes versus machines so you could
have a data node that's a Hadoop data
node and you could also have a spark
node on there Sparks a different
architecture and these are each daemons
that are running on these computers
that's why you refer to them as nodes
and not just always as serve servers and
machines so even though I use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine and so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data node
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey I'm here I'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack one and rack two
and our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and replicates it
in three different locations and then we
have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer the client is you've logged
in external to this Hadoop file system
and you're sending it instructions and
so the client whatever instructions or
script you're saying ending is first
request a name node to read the data the
name node allows a client to read the
requested data from the data nodes the
data is read from the data nodes and
sent to the client and so you can see
here that basically the the name node
connects the client up and says here
here's a data stream and now you have
the query that you've sent out returning
the data you asked for and then of
course it goes and finishes it and says
oh metadata operations and it goes in
there and finalizes your request the
other thing the name node does is you're
sending your information because the
client sends the information in there is
your block operations so your block
operations are performs creation of data
so you're going to create new files and
folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
cues the metadata the metadata goes into
it stores the metadata and then it goes
into block operations and maybe you're
sending the data to the Hadoop file so
system maybe you're querying maybe
you're asking it to delete if you're
sending data in there it then does the
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the Hadoop file system the
Hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our Hadoop file system client
that's you on your computer and the
client jvm on the client node so we have
our client jvm or the Java virtual
machine that it's going through and then
your client node and we're zooming in on
the read mechanism so we're looking at
this picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and I also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our name node up
here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can I get the Block
locations and so it goes by using the
RPC see remote procedure call it gets
those locations and the name node first
checks if the client is authorized to
access the requested file and if yes it
then provides a block location and a
token to the client which is shown to
the slave for authentication so here's
the name node it tells the client hey
here's the token the client's going to
come in and get this information from
you and it tells the client oh hey
here's where the information is so this
is what it's telling your script you
sent to query your data whether you're
writing your script in one of the many
setups that you have available through
the Hadoop file system or a connection
through your code and so you have your
client machine at this point then reads
so your FS data input stream comes
through and you have and you can see
right here we did one and two which is
verify who you are and give you all the
information you need then three you're
going to read it from the input stream
and then the input stream is going to
grab it from the different nodes where
it's at and it'll Supply the tokens to
those machines saying hey this client
needs this data here's a token for that
we're good to go let me have the data
the client will show the Authentication
token to the data nodes for the read
process to begin so after reaching the
end of the data block the connection is
closed and we can see here where we've
gone through the different steps get
Block locations we have step one you
open up your connection you get the
Block locations by using the RPC then
you actively go through the fs data
input stream to grab all those different
data brings it back into the client and
then once it's done it closes down that
connection and then once the client or
in this case the programmer you know
manager's gone in and pig script you can
do that there's an actual coding in each
in Hadoop or pulling data called pig or
Hive once you get that data back we
close the connection delete all those
randomly huge series of tokens so they
can't be used anymore and then it's done
with that query and we'll go ahead and
zoom in just a little bit more here and
let's look at this even a little closer
here's our Hadoop file system client and
our client jvm our Java virtual machine
on the client node and we have the data
to be read block a Block B and so we
request to read block A and B it goes
into the name node two then it sends the
location in this case IP addresses of
the blocks for the dn1 and dn2 where
those blocks are stored then the client
interacts with the data nodes through
the switches and so you have here the
core switch so your client node comes in
three and it goes to the core switch and
that then goes to rec switch one rack
switch 2 and rack switch 3. now if
you're looking at this you'll
automatically see a point of failure in
the core switch and certainly you want a
high-end switch mechanism for your core
switch you want to use Enterprise
hardware for that and then when you get
to the racks that's all commodity all
your rack switches so if one of those
goes down you don't care as much you
just have to get in there and swap it in
and out really quick you can see here we
have block a which is replicated three
times and so is Block B and it will pull
from there so we come in here and here
the data is read from the dn1 and dn2 as
they are the closest to each other and
so you can see here that it's not going
to read from two different racks it's
going to read from one rack whatever the
closest setup is for that query the
reason for this is if you have 10 other
queries going on you want this one to
pull all the data through one setup and
it minimizes that traffic so the
response from the data nodes to the
client that read the operation was
successful it says Ah we've read the
data we're successful which is always
good we like to be successful I don't
know about you I like to be successful
so if we're looking at the read
mechanism let's go ahead and zoom in and
look at the right mechanism for the
Hadoop file system sorry hdfs rate
mechanism and so when we have the hdfs
write mechanism here's our client
machine this is again the programmer on
their in-computer and it's going through
the client Java machine or Java virtual
machine the jvm this is all occurring on
the client node somebody's office or
maybe it's on the local server for the
office so we have our name node we have
data nodes and we have the distributed
file system so the client first executes
create file on distributed file system
says hey I'm going to create this file
over here then it goes through the RPC
call just like our read did The Client
First executes create file in the
distributed file system then the DFS
interacts with the name node to create a
file name node then provides a location
to write the data and so here we have
our hdfs client and the fs data output
Stream So this time instead of the data
going to the client it's coming from the
client and so here the client writes the
data through the fsdata output stream
keep in mind that this output stream the
client could be a streaming code it
could be I mean you know I always refer
to the client as just being this
computer that your programmer is writing
on it could be you have your SQL Server
there where your data is it's current
with all your current sales and it's
archiving all that information through
scoop one of the tools in the Hadoop
file system it could be streaming data
it could be a connection to the stock
servers and you're pulling stock data
down from those servers at a regular
time and that's all controlled you can
actually set that code up to be
controlled in many of the different
features in the Hadoop file system and
some of the different resources you have
that sit on top of it so here the client
writes the data through the fs data
output screen and the fs data output
stream as you can see goes into right
packet so it divides it up into packets
128 megabytes and the data is written
and the slave further replicates it so
here's our data coming in and then if
you remember correctly that's part of
the fs data setup is it tells it where
to replicate it out but the data node
itself is like oh hey okay I've got the
data coming in and it's also given the
tokens of where to send the replications
to and then acknowledgment is sent after
the required replicas are made so then
that goes back up saying hey successful
I've written data made three
replications on this as far as our you
know going through the pipeline of the
data nodes and then that goes back and
says after the data is written the
client performs the close method so the
client's done and says okay I'm done
here's the end of the data we're
finished and after the data is written
the client performs a close method and
we can see here just a quick reshape we
go in there just like we did with the
read we create the connection this
creates a name node which lets it know
what's going on step two step three that
also includes the tokens and everything
and then we go into step three where
we're now writing through the fs data
output stream and that sorts it out into
whatever data node it's going to go to
and which also tells it how to replicate
it so that data node then sends it to
other data nodes so we have a
replication and of course you finalize
it and close everything up marks it
complete to the name node and it deletes
all those magical tokens in the
background so that they can't be reused
and we go ahead and just do this with an
example the same setups and whether
you're doing a read or write they're
very similar as we come in here from our
client and our name node and you can see
right here we actually depicting these
as the actual rack and the switch is
going on and so as the data comes in you
have your request like we saw earlier it
sends the location of the data nodes and
this actually turns your your IP
addresses your Dynamic node connections
they come back to your client your hdfs
client and at that point with the tokens
it then goes into the core switch and
the core switch hey here it goes the
client interacts with the data nodes
through the switches and you can see
here where you're writing in block a
replication of block a and a second
replication of block a on the second
server so blocking is replicated on the
second server and the third server at
this point you now have three
replications of block a and it comes
back and says it acknowledges it says
hey we're done and that goes back into
your Hadoop file system to the client it
says okay we're done and finally the
success written to the name node and it
just closes everything down a quick
recap of the Hadoop file system and the
advantages and so the first one is
probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant whole racks can go down
switches can go down even your main name
node could go down if you have a
secondary name node something we didn't
talk too much about is how scalable it
is as it uses distributed storage you
run into there and you're oh my gosh I'm
out of space or I need to do some
heavier processing me just add another
rack of computers so you can scale it up
very quickly that's a linear scalability
where it used to be if you bought a
server you would have to pay a lot of
money to get that the Craig computer
remember the big Craig computers coming
out in the Craig computer runs 2 million
a year just the maintenance to liquid
cool it that's very expensive compared
to just adding more racks of computer
and extending your data center so it's
very cost effective since commodity
Hardware is used we're talking cheap
knockoff computers we still need your
high-end Enterprise for the name node
but the rest of them literally it is a
tenth of the cost of storing data on
more traditional high-end computers and
then the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security and provides data
security for your data so all Theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into
pulling data or putting data into the
Hadoop file system and you can see here
I have Oracle virtual machine virtual
box manager I have a couple different
things loaded on there Cloudera is one
of them so we should probably explain
some of these things if you're new to
Virtual machines the Oracle virtual box
allows you to spin up a machine as if it
is a separate computer so in this case
this is running I believe Centos a Linux
and it creates like a box on my computer
so the Centos is running on my machine
while I'm running my Windows 10 it
happens to be a Windows 10 computer and
then underneath here I can actually go
under let me just open up the general
might be hard to see there and you can
see I can actually go down to system
processor I happen to be on an 8 core it
has 16 dedicated threads registers of 16
CPUs but eight cores and I've only
designated this for one CPU so it's only
going to use one of my dedicated threads
on my computer and this the Oracle
virtual machine is open source and you
can see right here we're on the oracle
www.oracle.com
just do a search for downloading
virtualbox if you search for virtualbox
all one word it will come up with this
page and then you can download it for
whatever operating system you're working
with there certainly are a number of
different options and let me go and
point those out if you're setting this
up as a for demoing for yourself the
first thing to note for doing a virtual
box and doing a Cloudera or Horton setup
on that virtual box for doing the Hadoop
system to try it out you need a minimum
of 12 gigabytes it cannot be a Windows
10 home edition because you'll have
problems with your virtual setup and
sometimes you have to go turn on the
virtual settings so it knows it's in
there so if you're on a home setup there
are other sources there's Cloudera and
we'll talk a little bit about Cloudera
here in just a second but they have the
Cloudera online live we can go try the
Cloudera setup I've never used it but
Cloudera is a pretty good company
Cloudera and hortonworks are two of the
common ones out there and we'll actually
be running a Cloudera Hadoop cluster on
on our demo here so you have Oracle
virtual machine you also have the option
of doing it on different VMware that's
another one like virtual machine this is
more of a paid service there is a free
setup for just doing it for yourself
which will work fine for this and then
in the Cloudera like again they have the
new online setup where you can go in
there to the online and for Cloudera you
want to go underneath the Cloudera quick
start if you type in a search for
Cloudera quick start it'll bring you to
this website and then you can select
your platform in this case I did virtual
box there's VMware we just talked about
Docker Docker is a very high-end virtual
setup unless you already know it you
really don't want to mess with it then
your KVM is if you're on a Linux
computer that sets up multiple systems
on that computer so the two you really
want to use are usually the virtual box
or do an online setup and you can see
here with the download if you're going
into the Horton versions called
hortonworks and they call it sandbox so
you'll see the term hortonworks sandbox
and these are all test demos you're not
going to deploy a single node Hado
systems that would just be kind of
ridiculous and defeat the whole purpose
of having a Horton or having a Hadoop
system if it's only installed on one
computer in a virtual node so a lot of
different options if you're not on a
professional Windows version or you
don't have at least 12 gigabytes Ram to
run this uh you'll want to try and see
if you can find an online version and of
course simply learn has our own Labs if
you sign up for our classes we set you
up I don't know what it is now but last
time I was in there was a five node
setup so you could get around and see
what's going on whether you're studying
for the admin side or for the
programming side in script writing and
if I go into my Oracle virtual box and I
go under my Cloudera and I start this up
and each one has their own flavors
Horton uses just a login so you log
everything in through a local host
through your Internet Explorer or like
use Chrome Cloudera actually opens up a
full interface so you actually are in
that setup and you can see when I've
started it let me go back here I once I
downloaded this this is a big download
by the ways I had to import The
Appliance in virtualbox the first time I
ran it it takes a long time to configure
the setup and the second time it comes
up pretty quick and with the Cloudera
quick start again this is a pretend
single node it opens up and you'll see
that it actually has Firefox here so
here's my web browser I don't have to go
to a local host I'm actually already in
the quick start for Cloudera and if we
come down here you can see getting
started I have some information analyze
your data manage your cluster your
general information on there and what I
always want to start to do is to go
ahead and open up a terminal window so
open up a terminal widen this a little
bit let me just maximize this out here
so you can see so we are now in a
virtual machine this virtual machine is
Centos Linux so I'm on a Linux computer
on my Windows computer and so when I'm
on this terminal window this is your
basic terminal if I do list you'll see
documents Eclipse these are the
different things that are installed with
the quick start guide on the Linux
system so this is a Linux computer and
then Hadoop is running on here so now I
have Hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a Hadoop file
system DFS minus LS now notice the ls is
the same I have LS for list and LS for
list and I click on here it'll take just
a second reading the Hadoop file system
and it comes up with nothing so a quick
recap let's go back over this three
different environments I have this one
out here let's just put this in a bright
red so you can actually see it I have
this environment out here which is my
slides I have this environment here
where I did a list that's looking at the
files on the Linux Centos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the Hadoop file
system so three completely separate
Enviro experiments and then we connect
them and so right now we have I have
whatever files I have my personal files
and the um of course we're also looking
at the screen for my Windows 10 and then
we're looking at the screen here here's
our list there that's looking at the
files and this is the screen for Centos
Linux and then this is looking at the
files right here for the Hadoop file
system so three completely separate
files this one here which is the Linux
is running in a virtual box so this is a
virtual box I'm using one core to run it
or one CPU and everything in there is it
has its own file system you can see we
have our desktop and documents and
whatever in there and then you can see
here we right now have no files and our
Hadoop file system and this Hadoop file
system currently is stored on the Linux
machine but it could be stored across 10
Linux machines 20 a hundred this could
be stored across in petabytes I mean it
could be really huge or it could just be
in this case just a demo where we're
putting it on just one computer and then
once we're in here let me just see real
quick if I can go under view zoom in
view zoom in this is just a standard
browser so I could use any like the
Control Plus and stuff like that to zoom
in and this is very common to be in a
browser window with the Hadoop file
system so right now I'm in a Linux and
I'm going to do oh let's just create a
file go file my new file and I'm going
to use VI and this is a VI editor just a
basic editor and we go ahead and type
something in here one two three four
maybe it's columns 44 66 77 of course I
do file system just like your regular
computer can also so in our buy editor
you hit your colon I actually work with
a lot of different other editors and
we'll write quit VI so let's take a look
and see what happened here I'm in my
Linux system I type in LS for list and
we should see my new file and sure
enough we do over here there it is let
me just highlight that my new file and
if I then go into the Hadoop system hdfs
DFS minus LS for list we still show
nothing it's still empty so what I can
simply do is I can go hdfs DFS minus put
and then we're going to put my new file
and this is just going to move it from
the Linux system because I'm in this
file folder into the Hadoop file system
and now if we go in and we type in our
list for a new file system you will see
in here that I now have just the one
file on there which is my new file and
very similar to Linux we can do cat and
the cat command simply evokes reading
the file so hdfs DFS minus cat and I had
to look it up remember Cloudera the the
format is going to be a user then of
course the path location and the file
name and in here when we did the list
here's our list so you can see it lists
our file here and we realize that this
is under a user Cloud Dara and so I can
now go user Cloudera my new file and the
minus cat and we'll be able to read the
file in here and you can see right here
this is the file that was in the Linux
system is now copied into the Cloudera
system and it's one three four five that
what I entered in there and if we go
back to the Linux and do list you'll
still see it in here my new file and we
can also do something like this in our
hdfs minus MV and we'll do my new file
and we're going to change it to my new
new file and if we do that underneath
our Hadoop file system the minus MV will
rename it so if I go back here to our
Hadoop file system LS you'll now see
instead of my new file it has my new new
file coming up and there it is my new
new files we've renamed it we can also
go in here and delete this so I can now
come in here so in our hdfs DFS we can
also do a remove and this will remove
the file and so if we come in here we
run this we'll will see that when I come
back and do the list the file is gone
and now we just have another empty
folder with our Hadoop file system and
just like any file system we can take
this and we can go ahead and make
directory create a new directory so MK
for make directory we'll call this my
dir so we're going to make a directory
my der it'll take it just a second and
of course if we do the list command
you'll see that we now have the
directory in there give it just a second
there it comes myder and just like we
did before I can go in here and we're
going to put the file and if you
remember correctly from our files in the
setup I called it my new file so this is
coming from the Linux system and we're
going to put that into my dir that's the
Target in my Hadoop setup and so if I
hit enter on there I can now do the
Hadoop list and that's not going to show
the files remember I put it in a
subfolder so if I do the quadrupt just
this will show my directory and I can do
list and then I can do my
dur for my directory and you'll see
underneath the my directory in the
Hadoop file system it now has my new
file put in there and with any good
operating system we need a minus help so
just like you can type in help in your
Linux you can now come in here and type
in hdfs help and it shows you a lot of
the commands in there underneath the
Hadoop file system most of them should
be very similar to the Linux on here and
we can also do something like this a
Hadoop version and the Hadoop version
shows up that we're in Hadoop 2.60
CDH is it where Cloudera 5 and compiled
by Jenkins and it has a date and all the
different information on our Hadoop file
system so this is some basics in the
terminal window let me go ahead and
close this out because if you're going
to play with this you should really come
in here let me just maximize the
Cloudera and it opens up in a browser
window and so once we're in here again
this is a browser window which you could
access might look like any access for a
Hadoop file system one of the fun things
to do when you're first starting is to
go under huge you'll see it up here at
the top has Cloudera Hue Hadoop near
hbase your Impala your spark these are
standard installs now and Hue is
basically an overview of the file system
and so come up here and you can see
where you can do queries as far as if
you have a hbase or a hive The Hive
database we can go over here to the top
where it says file browser and if we go
under file browser now this is the
Hadoop file system we're looking at and
once we open up the file browser you can
now see there's my directory which we
created and if I click on my directory
there's my new file which is in here and
if I click on my new file it actually
opens it up and you can see from our
Hadoop file system this is in the Hadoop
file system the file that we created so
we covered the terminal window you can
see here's a terminal window up here it
might be if you were in a web browser
it'll look a little different because it
actually opens up as a web browser
terminal window and we've looked a
little bit at Hue which is one of the
most basic components of Hadoop one of
the original components for going
through and looking at your data in your
databases of course now they're up to
the Hue four it's gone through a number
of changes and you can see there's a lot
of different choices in here for other
different tools in the Hadoop file
system and I'll go ahead and just close
out of this and one of the cool things
with the virtual uh box I can either
save the machine State send the shutdown
signal or power off the machine I'll go
ahead and just power off the machine
completely now suppose you have a
library that has a collection of huge
number of books on each floor and you
want to count the total number of books
present on each floor what would be your
approach you would say I will do it
myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing So when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you're talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its RAM and CPU cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person one who would be
taking care of books on floor one and
Counting them person two on floor 2 then
you have someone on floor 3 and someone
on floor four so every individual would
be counting the books on every floor in
parallel so that reduces the time
consumed for this activity and then
there should be some mechanism where all
these Counts from every floor can be
aggregated so what is each person doing
here each person is mapping the data of
a particular floor or you can say each
person is doing a kind of activity or
basically a task on every floor and the
task is counting the books on every
floor now then you could have some
aggregation mechanism that could
basically reduce or summarize this total
count and in terms of map reduce we
would say that's the work of reducer so
when you talk about Hadoop map reduce it
processes data on different node
machines now this is the whole concept
of Hadoop framework right that you not
only have your data stored across
machines but you would also want to
process the data locally so instead of
transferring the the data from one
machine to other machine or bringing all
the data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of Hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will Aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your map
reduce Works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
Hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes Excel
and that amount of data which needs to
be processed on a huge cluster we could
also use mapreduce programming model and
run a mapreduce algorithm in a local
mode but what does that mean if you
would go for a local mode it basically
means it would do all the mapping and
reducing on the same node using the
processing capacity that is RAM and CPU
cores on the same machine which is not
really efficient in fact we would want
to have our map reduce work on multiple
nodes which would obviously have mapping
phase followed by a reducing phase and
intermittently there would be data
generated there would be different other
phases which help this whole processing
so when you talk about Hadoop map reduce
you are mainly talking about two main
components or two main phases that is
mapping and reducing mapping taking care
of map tasks reducing taking care of
reduced tasks so you would have your
data which would be stored on multiple
machines now when we talk about data
data could be in different formats we
could or the developer could specify
what is the format which needs to be
used to understand the data which is
coming in that data then goes through
the mapping internally there would be
some shuffling sorting and then reducing
which gives you your final output so the
way we Access Data from sdfs or the way
our data is getting stored on sdfs we
have our input data which would have one
or multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a Hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 MB which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if I have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster I would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of logs
creating a load on name nodes Ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every Chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to hdfs where it is sorted and
Shuffle world and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduce Stars would be used or
what data goes to which Reserve you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing phase
which is taken care by a reducer class
internally the reducer reduce function
provided by developers which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on hdfs now in case of
Hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in part k your
data could be in afro text CSV tsv
binary format and all of these formats
are supported however remember if you
are talking about data being compressed
then you have to also look into what
kind of splitability the compression
mechanism supports otherwise when
mapreduce processing happens it would
take the complete file as one chunk to
be processed so sdfs accepts input data
in different formats this data is stored
in sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as I said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when I
say individual element I could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of delimiter
or without delimiter are broken down
into individual elements and thus your
mass creates key value pairs now these
key value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
Aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you would
say finally your output is getting
stored in the designated directory as a
list of aggregated key value pairs which
gives you your output so when we talk
about mapreduce one of the key factors
here is the parallel processing which it
can offer so we know that we our data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs be processed and
the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on on multiple data nodes
slave nodes in each slave node would
have again one or multiple disks to
process this data basically we have to
go for parallel processing approach we
have to use
now let's look at the mapreduce workflow
to understand how it works so basically
you have your input data stored on sdfs
now this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieve by using
something called as chaining of mappers
so here you have your data getting
stored on sdfs now input format is
basically something to define the input
specification and how the input files
will be split so there are various input
formats now we can search for that so we
can go to Google and we can basically
search for Hadoop map reduce Yahoo
tutorial this is one of the good links
and if I look into this link I can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
Define how input files have split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
passes lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also also search
for output format which takes care of
how the data is handled after the
processing is done so the key value
pairs provided to this output collector
are then returned to Output files the
way they are written is governed by
output format so it functions pretty
much like input format as described in
earlier right so we could set what is
the output format to be followed and
again you have text output sequence file
output format null output format and so
on so these are different classes which
take care of how your data is handled
when it is being read for processing or
how is the data being written when the
process is done so based on the input
format the file is broken down into
splits and this logically represents the
data to be processed by individual map
tasks or you could say individual mapper
functions so you could have one or
multiple splits which need to need to
assist depending on the file size
depending on what properties have been
set now once this is done you have your
input splits which are subjected to
mapping phase internally you have a
record reader which communicates with
the input split and converts the data
into key value pairs suitable to be read
by mapper and what is mapper doing it is
basically working on these key value
pairs the map task giving you an
intermittent output which would then be
forwarded for further processing now
once that is done and we have these key
value pairs which is being worked upon
my map your map task
as a part of your mapper function are
generating your key value pairs which
are your intermediate outputs to be
processed further now you could have as
I said a combiner phase or internally a
mini reducer phase Now combiner does not
have its own class so combiner basically
uses the same class as the reducer class
provided by the developer and its main
work is to do the reducing or its main
work is to do some kind of mini
aggregation on the key value pairs which
were generated by map so once the data
is coming in from the combiner then we
have internally a partitioner phase
which decides how outputs from combiners
are sent to the reducers or you could
also say that even if I did not have a
combiner partitioner would decide based
on the keys and values based on the type
of keys how many reducers would be
required or how many reduced tasks would
be required to work on our output which
was generated by map task now once
partitioner has decided that then your
data would be then sorted and shuffled
which is then fed into the reducer so
when you talk about your reducer it
would basically have one or multiple
reduced tasks now that depends on what
or what partitional decided or
determined for your data to be processed
it can also depend on the configuration
properties which have been set to decide
how many radio Stars should be used now
internally all this data is obviously
going through sorting and shuffling so
that you're reducing your aggregation
becomes an easier task once we have this
done we basically have the reducer which
is the code for the reducer is provided
by the developer and all the
intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output file s now this is how your map
reduce Works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or accessed from sdfs or even used
as an input for further mapreduce kind
of processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner phase which is
optional which is not mandatory then you
have a partitioner phase which decides
on how many reduce tasks or how many
reducers would be used to work on your
data internally there is sorting and
shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
map reduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an API which intends to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of Hadoop yarn
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
Hadoop version one we had job tracker
and then the slaves were called task
trackers in Hadoop version 2 instead of
job tracker you have manager angel of
task trackers you have node managers so
basically your resource manager has to
assign the job to the task trackers or
node managers so your node managers as
we discussed in yarn are basically
taking care of processing which happens
on every node so so internally there is
all of this work Happening by resource
manager node managers and application
Master then you can refer to the yarn
based tutorial to understand more about
that so here your processing Master is
basically breaking down the application
into tasks what it does internally is
once your application is submitted you
are application to be run on yarn
processing framework is handled by
resource manager now forget about the
yarn part as of now I mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how yarn handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running with in the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some RAM and CPU cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your mapreduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on sdfs
[Music]
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a Hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
your reducing phase and mapping phase is
taken care by your mapper function and
your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your Apache Hadoop cluster
or even in your cloud data cluster now
we can build our own mapreduce programs
we can package them as jar transfer them
to the cluster and then run it on a
Hadoop cluster on yarn or we could be
you using already provided default
program so let's see where they are now
these are my two machines which I have
brought up and basically this would have
my Apache Hadoop cluster running now we
can just do a Simple Start hyphen all
dot SH now I know that this script is
deprecated and it says instead you start
DFS and start young but then it will
still take care of static of my cluster
on these two nodes where I would have
one single name node two data nodes one
secondary name node one resource manager
and two node managers now if you have
any doubt in how this cluster came up
you can always look at the previous
sessions where we had a walkthrough in
setting up a cluster on Apache and then
you could also have your cluster running
using Less Than 3 GB of your total
machine RAM and you could have a Apache
cluster running on your machine now once
this cluster comes up we will also have
a look at the web UI which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the UI is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up I
can just do a JPS to look at Java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on C1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my M1 machine which is my second
machine which I have configured here I
can always do a JPS and that shows me
the processes running which also means
that my cluster is up with two data
nodes with two node managers and here I
can have a look at my web UI so I can
just do a refresh and the same thing
with this one just do a refresh so I had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web UI using your name
nodes host name and 570 Port it tells me
what is my cluster ID what is my block
pool ID it helps you information of what
is the space usage how many live nodes
you have and you can even browse your
file system so I have put in a lot of
data here I can click on browse the file
system and this basically shows me
multiple directories and these
directories have one or multiple files
which we will use for our map reduce
example now if you see here these are my
directories which have some sample files
although these files are very small like
8.7 kilobytes if you look into this
directory if you look into this I have
just pulled in some of my Hadoop logs
and I have put it on my sdfs these are a
little bigger files and then we also
have some other data which we can see
here and this is data which I've
downloaded from web now we can either
run a map reduce on a single file or in
a directory which contains multiple
files let's look at that before looking
a demo on map reduce also remember
mapreduce will create a output directory
and we need to have that directory
created plus we need to have the
permissions to run the mapreduce job so
by default since I'm running it using
admin ID I should not have any problem
but then if you intend to run mapreduce
with a different user then obviously you
will have to ask the admin or you will
have to give the user permission to read
and write from sdfs so this is the
directory which I have created which
will contain my output once the map
reduce job finishes and this is my
cluster file system if you look on this
UI this shows me about my yarn which is
available for taking care of any
processing it as of now shows that I
have total 8GB memory and I have 8v
cores now that can be depending on what
configuration we have set or how many
nodes are available we can look at nodes
which are available and that shows me I
have two node managers running each has
8GB memory and 8 V cores now that's not
true actually but then we have not set
the configurations for node managers and
that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8GB RAM and 8B cores
now this is my yarn UI we can also look
at scheduler which basically shows me
the different queues if they have been
configured where you will have to run
the jobs we'll discuss about all these
in later in detail now let's go back to
our terminal and let's see where we can
find some sample applications which we
can run on the cluster so once I go to
the terminal I can well submit the
mapreduce job from any terminal now here
I know that my Hadoop related
directories here and within Hadoop you
have various directories we have
discussed that in binaries you have the
commands which you can run in s bin you
basically have the startup scripts and
here you also notice there is a share
directory in the end if you look in the
Shell directory you would find Hadoop
and within Hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
mapreduce now this map reduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a cloud
error cluster you would have to go into
opt Cloudera parcel CDH slash lib and in
that you would have directories for sdfs
mapreduce or sdfs yarn where you can
still find the same jars it is basically
a package which contains your multiple
applications now how do we run a map
reduce we can just type in Hadoop and
hit enter and that shows me that I have
an option called jar which can be used
to run a jar file now at any point of
time if you would want to see what are
the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example I could say jar x v f and I
could say user local Hadoop share Hadoop
map reduce and then list down your jar
file so I'll say Hadoop map reduce
examples and if I do this this should
basically unpack it to show me what
classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a LS and here if you look in LS
org since I and the command from your
phone directory I can look into org
patchy Hadoop examples which shows me
the classes which I have and those
classes contain which mapper or reducer
class
so it might not be just mapper and
reducer but you can always have a look
so for example I am targeting to use
word count program which does a word
count on files and gives me a list of
words and how many times they occur in a
particular file or in set of files and
this shows me that what are the classes
which belong to word count so we have a
in some reducer so this is my reducer
class I have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word count now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so I can say Hadoop jar and give your
path so I'll say Hadoop jar user local
Hadoop share Hadoop map reduce Hadoop
map reduce examples and if I hit on
enter that will show me what are the
inbuilt classes which are already
available now these are certain things
which we can use now there are other our
files also for example I can look at
Hadoop and here we can look at the jar
files which we have in this particular
path so this is one Hadoop mapreduce
examples which you can use you can
always look in other jar files like you
can look for Hadoop mapreduce client job
client and then you can look at the test
one so that is also an interesting one
so you can always look into Hadoop map
reduce client job client and then you
have something ending with this so if I
would have tried this one using my
Hadoop jar command so in my previous
example when we did this it was showing
me all the classes which are available
and that already has a word count now
there are other good programs which you
can try like terrajen to generate dummy
data Terra saw to check your sorting
performance and so on and Terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a Hadoop jar as I said on Hadoop
mapreduce I think that was client and
then we have job client and then test
start now this has a lot of other
classes which can be used or programs
which can be used for doing a stress
testing or checking your cluster status
and so on one of them interesting one is
test the fsio but let's not get into all
the details in first instance let's see
how we can run a map reduce now if I
would want to run a map reduce I need to
give Hadoop jar and then my jar file and
if I hit on enter it would say it needs
the input and output it needs which
class you want to run so for example I
would say word count and again if I hit
on enter it tells me that you need to
give me some input and output to process
and obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our yarn
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in in local
mode but let's first try how it runs on
the cluster so how do we do that now
here I can do a hdfs LS slash command to
see what I have on my sdfs now through
my UI I was already showing you that we
have set of files and directories which
we can use to process now we can take up
one single file so for example if I pick
up new data and I can look into the
files here what we have and we can
basically run a map reduce on a single
file or multiple file so let's take this
file whatever that contains and I would
like to do a word count so that I get a
list of words and their occurrence in
this file so let me just copy this now I
also need my output to be written and
that will be written here so here if I
want to run a map reduce I can say
Hadoop which we can pull out from
history so Hadoop jar word count now I
need to give my input so that will be
new data and then I will give this file
which we just copied now I am going to
run the word count only on a single file
and I will basically have my output
which will be stored in this directory
the directory which I have created
already Mr output so let's do this
output and this is fair enough now you
can give many other properties you can
specify how many map jobs you want to
run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once I go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our Hadoop
clusters now obviously internally it
will be looking for name node now we
have some issue here and it says the
output already exists what is does that
mean so it basically means that Hadoop
will create an output for you you just
need to give a name but then you don't
need to create it so let's give let's
append the output with number one and
then let's go ahead and run this so I've
submitted this command now this can also
be done in background if you would want
to run multiple jobs on your cluster at
the same time so it takes total input
paths to processes one so that is there
is only one split on which your job has
to work now it will internally try to
contact your resource manager and
basically this is done so here we can
have a look and we can see some counters
here now what I also see is for some
property which it is missing it has run
the job but it has run in a local mode
it has run in a local mode so although
we have submitted so this might be
related to my yarn settings and we can
check that so if I do a refresh when I
have run my application it has completed
it would have created an output but the
only thing is it did not interact with
your yarn it did not interact with your
resource manager we can check those
properties and here if we look into the
job it basically tells me that it went
for mapping and reducing it would have
created an output it worked on my file
but then it ran in a local mode it ran
in a local mode so mapreduce remember is
a programming model right now if you
you get the facilities of
run cluster where yarn takes care of
resource management if you don't run it
on yarn and run it on a local mode it
will use
means RAM and CPU cores for processing
but then we can quickly look at the
output and then we can also try running
this on yarn so if I look into my hdfs
and if I look into my output Mr output
that's the directory which was not used
actually let's look into the other
directory which is ending with one and
that should show me the output created
by this map reduce although it ran in
the local mode it fetched an input file
from your sdfs and it would have created
output in sdfs now that's my part file
which is created and if you look at part
minus r minus these zeros if you would
have more than one reducer running then
you would have multiple such files
created we can look into this what does
this file contain which should have my
word count and here I can say cat which
basically shows me what is the output
created by my map reduce let's have a
look into this so the file which we gave
for processing has been broken down and
now we have the list of words which
occur in the file plus a count of those
words so if there is some word which is
in is more then it shows me the count so
this is a list of my words and the count
for that so this is how we run a sample
mapreduce job I will also show you how
we can run it on yeah now let's run
mapreduce on yarn and initially when we
tried running a map reduce it did not
hit yarn but it ran in a local mode and
that was because there was a property
which had to be changed in mapreduce
hyphen site file so basically if you
look into this file the error was that I
had given a property which says
mapred.framework.name and that was not
the right property name and it was
ignored and that's why it ran local mode
so I change the property to mapreduce
dot framework.name restarted my cluster
and everything should be fine now and
that map red hyphen site file has also
been copied across the nodes now to run
a map reduce on a Hadoop cluster so that
it uses yarn and yarn takes care of
resource allocation on one or multiple
machines so I'm just changing the output
here and now I will submit this job
which should first connect to the
resource manager and if it connects to
the resource manager that means our job
will be run using yarn on the Clusters
rather than in a local mode so now we
have to wait for this application to
internally connect to resource manager
and once it starts there we can always
go back to the web UI and check if our
application has reached yarn so it shows
me that there is one input part to be
processed that's my job ID that's my
application ID which you can even
monitor status from the command line now
here the job has been submitted so let's
go back here and just do a Refresh on my
yarn UI which should show me the new
application which is submitted it tells
me that it is an accepted State
application master has already started
and if you click on this link it will
also give you more details of how many
map and reduced tasks would run so as of
now it says the application Master is
running it would be using node which is
M1 we can always look into the logs we
can see that there is a one task attempt
which is being made and now if I go back
to my terminal I will see that it is
waiting to get some resources from the
cluster and once it gets the resources
it will first start with the mapping
phase where the mapper function runs it
does the map tasks one or multiple
depending on the splits so right now we
have one file and one split so we will
have just one map task running and once
the mapping phase completes then it will
get into reducing which will finally
give me my output so we can be toggling
through these sessions so here I can
just do a refresh to see what is
happening with my application is it
proceeding is it still waiting for
resource manager to allocate some
resources now just couple of minutes
back I tested this application on yarn
and we can see that my first application
completed successfully and here we will
have to give some time so that yarn can
allocate the resources now if the
resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally Yan takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what Yan can allocate
to it sometimes you can also see a
slowness in what web UI shows up and
that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your notes
now for Apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as I said the memory which
shows up here 16 GB and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it couple of
seconds and then let's look into the
output here again I had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically I restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process should start so here I
have submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
an app master that is application Master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application ID and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking URL to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn UI if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
changed to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here I have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 GB for node manager on every node
and I have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving and we
can see the progress bar here which
basically will show what is happening
and if we go back to the terminal it
will show that first it went in deciding
map and reduce it goes for map once the
mapping phase completes then the
reducing phase will come into existence
and here my job has completed so now it
has basically used we can always look at
how many map and reduce SAS were run it
shows me that there was one map and one
reduced task now with the number of map
tasks depends on the number of splits
and we had just one file which is less
than 128 MB so that was one split to be
processed and reduced task is internally
decided by the reducer or depending on
what kind of property has been set in
Hadoop config files now it also tells me
how many input records were read which
basically means these were the number of
lines in the file it tells me output
records which gives me the number of
total words in the file now there might
be duplicates and that which is
processed by internal combiner further
processing or forwarding that
information to reducer and basically
reducer works on 335 records gives us a
list of words and their count now if I
do a refresh here this would obviously
show my application is completed it says
succeeded you can always click on the
application to look for more information
it tells me where it ran now we do not
have a history server running as of now
otherwise we can always access more
information so this leads to history
server where all your applications are
stored but I can click on this attempt
tasks and this will basically show me
the history URL or you can always look
into the logs so this is how you can
submit a sample application which is
inbuilt which is available in the jar on
your Hadoop cluster and that will
utilize your cluster to run now you
could always as I said when you are
running a particular job remember to
change the output directory and if you
would not want it to be processing a
single individual file you could also
point it to a directory that basically
means it will have multiple files and
depending on the file sizes there would
be multiple splits and according to that
multiple map tasks will be selected so
if I click on this this would submit my
second application to the cluster which
should first connect to resource manager
then resource manager has to start an
application Master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced tasks would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
UI to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however to not
create it Hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a map reduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now we will compare Hadoop version one
that is with mapreduce version one we
will understand and learn about the
limitations of Hadoop version one what
is the need of yarn what is yarn what
kind of workloads can be running on yarn
what are yarn components what is yarn
architecture and finally we will see a
demo on yarn so Hadoop person one or
mapreduce version one well that's
outdated now and nobody is using Hadoop
version one but it would be good to
understand what was in Hadoop version 1
and what were the limitations of Hadoop
version 1 which brought in the thought
for the future processing layer that is
yarn now when we talk about Hadoop we
already know that Hadoop is a framework
and Hadoop has two layers one is your
storage layer that that is your hdfs
Hadoop distributed file system which
allows for distributed storage and
processing which allows fault tolerance
by inbuilt replication and which
basically allows you to store huge
amount of data across multiple commodity
machines when we talk about processing
we know that map reduce is the oldest
and the most mature processing
programming model which basically takes
care of your data processing on your
distributed file system so in Hadoop
version 1 mapreduce performed both data
processing and resource management and
that's how it was problematic in
mapreduce we had basically when we talk
about the processing layer we had the
master which was called job tracker and
then you had the slaves which were the
task records so your job tracker was
taking care of allocating resources it
was performing scheduling and even
monitoring the jobs it basically was
taking care of assigning map and reduce
tasks to the jobs running on task
records and task trackers which were
co-located with data nodes were
responsible for processing the jobs so
task trackers were the slaves for the
processing layer which reported their
progress to the job tracker so this is
what was happening in Hadoop version one
now when we talk about Hadoop version 1
we would have say client machines or an
API or an application which basically
submits the job to the master that is
job tracker now obviously we cannot
forget that there would already be an
involvement from name node which
basically tells which are the machines
or which are the data nodes where the
data is already stored now once the job
submission happens to the job tracker
job tracker being the master demon for
taking care of your processing requests
and also resource management job
scheduling would then be interacting
with your multiple task trackers which
would be running on multiple machines so
each machine would have a task tracker
running and that task tracker which is a
processing slave would be co-located
with the data nodes now we know that in
case of Hadoop you have the concept of
moving the processing to wherever the
data is stored rather than moving the
data to the processing layer so we would
have task trackers which would be
running on multiple machines and these
Stars trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the CPU cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave domains
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was eventually overburdened
right because it was managing jobs it
was tracking the resources from multiple
task trackers and basically it was
taking care of job scheduling so job
tracker would be overburdened and in a
case if job tracker would fail then it
would affect the overall processing so
if the master is skilled if the master
demo and dies then the processing cannot
proceed now this was one of the
limitations of Hadoop person one so when
you talk about scalability that is the
capability to scale due to a single job
tracker scalability would be hitting a
bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40 000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing Master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as I mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a process using
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduced slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non mapreduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of Hadoop version 1 and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
mapreduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in Hadoop person one so when it
comes to doing a real-time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in Hadoop
person 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as I mentioned
before yarn in Hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limit processing which could be done now
this was one thing which brought in a
thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as I
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real-time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run mapreduce jobs only and
having issues in scalability resource
utilization job tracking Etc that led to
the need of something what we call as
yarn now from Hadoop version 2 onwards
we have the two main layers have changed
a little bit you have the storage layer
which is intact that is your sdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called ya yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce So mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing Frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which Hadoop version 1 was posing
something like Resource Management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for Hadoop version 1 which
were primarily mapreduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about multi
tenancy so basically now the cluster can
handle different kind of workloads so
you can use open source and propriety
data access engines you can perform
real-time analysis you can be doing
graph processing you can be doing ad hoc
querying and this can be supported for
multiple workloads which can run in
parallel so this is what yarn offers so
what is Yan as I mentioned yarn stands
for yet another resource negotiator so
it is the cluster Resource Management
layer for your Apache Hadoop ecosystem
which takes care of scheduling jobs and
assigning resources now just imagine
when you would want to run a particular
application you would basically be
telling the cus cluster that I would
want resources to run my applications
that application might be a mapreduce
application that might be a hive query
which is triggering a mapreduce that
might be a pick script which is
triggering a mapreduce that could be
Hive with days as in execution Engine
That Could Be a spark application that
could be a graph processing application
in any of these cases you would still
you as in in sense client or basically
an API or the application would be
requesting for resources yarn would take
care of that so yarn would provide the
desired resources now when we talk about
resources we are mainly talking about
the network related resources we are
talking about the CPU cores or as in
terms of yarn we say virtual CPU course
we would talk about Ram that is in GB or
MB or in terabytes which would be
offered from multiple machines and Yan
would take care of this so with yarn you
could basically handle different
workloads now these are some of the
workloads which are showing up here you
have the traditional mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as days you would have H base which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or Kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different Frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does yarn do that now
when we talk about yarn this is how a
overall yarn architecture looks so at
one end you have the client now client
could be basically your Edge node where
you have some applications which are
running it could be an API which would
want to interact with your cluster it
could be a user triggered application
which wants to run some jobs which are
doing some processing so this client
would submit a job request now what is
resource manager doing this Source
manager is the master of your processing
layer in Hadoop version 1 we basically
had job tracker and then we had task
trackers which were running on
individual nodes so your task trackers
were sending your heartbeats to the job
tracker your task trackers were sending
it their resource information and job
tracker was the one which was tracking
the resources and it was doing the job
scheduling and that's how as I mentioned
earlier job tracker was overburdened so
job tracker is now replaced by your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer your task trackers
are replaced by node managers which
would be then running on every node and
we have a temporary demon which you see
here in blue and that's your app master
so this is what we mentioned when we say
yet another resource negotiator so App
Master would be existing in a Hadoop
version and two now when we talk about
your resource manager resource manager
is the master for processing layer so it
would already be receiving heartbeats
and you can say resource information
from multiple node managers which would
be running on one or multiple machines
and these node managers are not only
updating their status but they are also
giving an information of the amount of
resources they have now when we talk
about resources we should understand
that if I'm talking about this node
manager then this has been allocated
some amount of RAM for processing and
some amount of CPU cores and that is
just a portion of what the complete node
has so if my node has say imagine my
node has around 100 GB RAM and I have
saved 60 cores all of that cannot be
allocated to node manager so node
manager is just one of the com
components of Hadoop ecosystem it is the
slave of the processing layer so we
could say keeping in all the aspects
such as different Services which are
running might be Cloud era or hot and
works related Services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 GB Ram per
node and say 40 CPU cores so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing Master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as I mentioned your resource
manager has these services or components
which basically helps it to do the
things it is basically a an architecture
where multiple components are working
together to achieve what yarn allows so
resource manager has mainly two
components that is your scheduler an
applications manager and these are at
high level four main components here so
we talk about Source manager which is
the processing Master you have node
managers which are the processing slaves
which are running on every nodes you
have the concept of container and you
have the concept of application Master
how do all these things work now let's
look at yarn components so resource
manager basically has two main
components you can say which assist
resource manager in doing what it is
capable of so you have scheduler and
applications manager now there is when
you talk about resources there is always
a requirement for the applications which
need to run on cluster of resources so
your application which has to run which
was submitted by client needs resources
and these resources are coming in from
multiple machines wherever the relevant
data is stored and in node manager is
running so we always know that node
manager is co-located with data nodes
now what is the schedule will do so we
have different kind of schedulers here
we have basically a capacity scheduler
we have a fair scheduler or we could
have a fee for scheduler so there are
different schedulers which take care of
resource allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-terrent cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queuing so that different departments
or different users can get dedicated
resources or can share resources on the
cluster so scheduler is responsible for
allocating resources to various running
applications now it does not perform
monitoring or tracking of the status of
applications that's not the part of
scheduler it does not offer any
guarantee about restarting the failed
tasks due to Hardware or network or any
other failures scheduler is mainly
responsible for allocating resources now
as I mentioned you could have different
kind of schedulers you could have a fifo
scheduler which was mainly in older
version of Hadoop which stands for first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler which basically means multiple
applications could be running in the
cluster and they would have a fair share
of the resources you could have a
capacity scheduler which would basically
have dedicated or fixed amount of
resources across the cluster now
whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as I said at higher
level we could always say resource
managers stay doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who
real it is these com so you have
applications manager which is
responsible for accepting job
submissions it negotiates the first
container for executing the application
specific application Master it provides
the service for restarting the
application Master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as I said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting or which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as I mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its Ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks been stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources and
resource manager has mainly these two
components which are helping it to do
its work now for a particular
application which might be needing data
from multiple machines now we know that
we would have multiple machines where we
would have node manager running we would
have a data node running and data nodes
are responsible for storing the data on
disk so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when I say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can I
have one GB of RAM and one CPU core from
you because there is some data residing
on your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
I again have 1GB and one CPU core from
you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has your resource
manager is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources which are called containers so
this request of holding resource can be
considered as a container so basically a
container can be of different sizes we
will talk about that so resource manager
negotiates the resources with node
manager now node manager which is
already giving an update of the
resources it has what amount of
resources it holds how much busy it is
can basically approve or deny this
request so node manager would basically
approve in saying yes I could hold these
resources I could give you this
container of this particular size now
once the container has been been
approved or allocated or you can say
granted by your node manager resource
manager now knows that resources to
process the application are available
and guaranteed by the node manager so
resource manager starts a temporary
demon called App Master so this is a
piece of code which would also be
running in one of the containers it
would be running in one of the
containers which would then take care of
execution of tasks in other containers
so your application Master is per
application so if I would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
Masters one app Master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app Master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app Master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other container
minutes which node manager is guaranteed
that it will give when the request
application request comes to it and
using these containers the App Master
will run the processing tasks Within
These designated resources so it is
mainly the responsibility of application
Master to get the execution done and
then communicate it to the master so
resource manager is tracking the
resources it is negotiating the
resources and once the resources have
been negotiated it basically gives the
control to application Master
application Master is then running
within one of the containers on one of
the nodes and using the other containers
to take care of execution this is how it
looks so basically container as I said
is a collection of resources like CPU
memory your disk which would be used or
which already has the data and network
so your node manager is basically
looking into the request from
application and master and it basically
is granting this request or basically is
allocating these containers now again we
could have different sizing of the
containers let's take an example here so
as I mentioned from the total resources
which are available for a particular
node some portion of resources are
allocated to the node manager so let's
imagine this is my node where node
manager as a processing slave is running
so from the total resources which the
node has some portion of RAM and CPU
cores is basically allocated to the node
manager so I could say out of total 100
GB Ram we can say around 60 cores which
the particular node has so this is my
Ram which the node has and these are the
CPU cores which the node has some
portion of it right so we can say might
be 70 or 60 percent of the total
resources so we could say around 60 GB
RAM and then we could say around 40 V
cores have been allocated to node
manager so there are these settings
which are given in the yarn hyphen site
file now apart from this allocation that
is 60 GB RAM and 40v cores we also have
some properties which say what will be
the container sizes so for example we
could have a small container setting
which could say my every container could
have 2GB RAM and say one virtual CPU
core so this is my smallest container So
based on the total resources you could
calculate how many such small containers
could be running so if I say 2GB Ram
then I could have around 30 containers
but then I'm talking talking about one
virtual CPU core so totally I could have
around 30 small containers which could
be running in parallel on a particular
node and as of that calculation you
would say 10 CPU cores are not being
utilized you could have a bigger
container size which could say I would
go for two CPU cores and 3 GB Ram so 3gb
RAM and two CPU cores so that would give
me around 20 containers of bigger size
so this is the container sizing which is
again defined in the yarn hyphen side
file so what we know is on a particular
node which has this kind of allocation
either we could have 30 small containers
running or we could have 20 big
containers running and same would apply
to multiple nodes so node manager based
on the request from application Master
can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you don't have an application
Master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application Master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on yarn then it
would be 10 application Masters one
responsible for each application your
application Master is the one which also
interacts with the scheduler to
basically know how much amount of
resources could be allocated for one
application and your application Master
is the one which uses these resources
but it can never negotiate for more
resources to node Manager application
Masters cannot do that application
master has to always go back to resource
manager if it needs more resources so it
is always the resource manager and
internally resource manager is component
that is application manager measure
which negotiates the resources at any
point of time due to some node failures
or due to any other requirements if
application Master needs more resources
on one or multiple nodes it will always
be contacting the resource manager
internally the applications manager for
more containers now this is how it looks
so your client submits the job request
to resource manager now we know that
resource manager internally has
scheduler an applications manager node
managers which are running on multiple
machines are the ones which are tracking
their resources giving this information
to the source manager so that resource
manager or I would say its component
applications manager could request
resources from multiple node managers
when I say request resources it is these
containers so your resource manager
basically will request for the resources
on one or multiple nodes node manager is
the one which approves these containers
and once the container has been approved
your resource manager triggers a piece
of code that is application Master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or I would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
locates a container application Master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run an application
Master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execute happens now that could be
a map task that could be a reduced task
that could be a spark executor taking
care of smart tasks and many other
processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works I would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from Cloudera so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which I explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has it talks about the yarn
configuration file where you give all
these properties it basically shows you
node manager which reports the amount of
resources it has to resource manager now
remember if worker node shows 18 to 8
CPU cores and 128 GB RAM and if your
node manager says 64-week course and RAM
128 GB then that's not the total
capacity of your node it is some portion
of your node which is allocated to node
manager now once your node manager
reports that your resource manager is
requesting for containers based on the
application what is the container it is
basically a logical name given to a
combination of vcore and RAM it is
within this container where you would
have basically the process running so
once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application Master within the
container and what does that application
Master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about mapreduce if
you have already followed the map reduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduced us could be running within the
container in one or multiple as I said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
Cloudera or hortonworks related Services
running and other processes which might
be running and based on that some
portion of RAM and CPU cores would be
allocated to node manager so that's how
it would be done in the yarn hyphen site
file and this basically show shows you
what is the total amount of memory and
CPU cores which is allocated to node
manager then within every machine where
you have a node manager running on every
machine in the yarn hyphen site file you
would have such properties which would
say what is the minimum container size
what is the maximum container size in
terms of ram what is the minimum for CPU
cores what is the maximum for CPU cores
and what is the incremental size in
where RAM and CPU cores can increment so
these are some of the properties which
Define how containers are allocated for
your application request so have a look
at this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
Fair scheduler or you basically having
different cues in which allocations can
be done you also have different ways in
which cues can be managed and different
schedulers can be used so you can always
look at this series of blog you can also
be checking for yarn schedulers and then
search for uh Hadoop definitive guide
and that could give you some information
on how it looks when you look for Hadoop
definitive guide so if you look into
this book which talks about the
different resources as I mentioned so
you could have a fee for scheduler that
is first in first out which basically
means if a long running application is
submitted to the cluster all other small
running applications will have to wait
there is no other way but that would not
be a preferred option if you look in V4
scheduler if you look for capacity
scheduler which basically means that you
could have different queues created and
those queues would have resources
allocated so then you could have a
production queue where production jobs
are running in a particular queue which
has fixed amount of resources allocated
you could have a development queue where
development jobs are running and both of
them are running in parallel you could
then also look into Fair scheduler which
basically means again multiple
applications could be running on the
cluster however they would have a fair
share so when I say fair share in brief
what it means is if I had given 50
percent of resources to a queue for
production and 50 of resources for a
queue of development and if both of them
are running in parallel then they would
have access to 50 percent of cluster
resources however if one of the queue is
unutilized then second queue can utilize
all cluster resources so look into the
fair scheduling part it also shows you
about how allocations can be given and
you can learn more about schedulers and
how queues can be used for managing
multiple applications now we will spend
some time in looking into few ways or
few quick ways in interacting with yarn
in the form of a demo to understand and
learn on how yarn works we can look into
a particular cluster now here we have a
designated cluster which can be used you
could be using the similar kind of
commands on your Apache based cluster or
a Cloudera quick start VM if you already
have or if you have a Cloudera or a
hortonworks cluster running there are
different ways in which we can interact
with yarn and we can look at the
information one is basically looking
into the admin console so if I would
look into Cloudera manager which is
basically an admin console for a
cloudera's distribution of Hadoop
similarly you could have a hortonworks
cluster then access to the admin console
so if you have even read access for your
cluster and if you have the admin
console then you can search for yarn as
a service which is running you can click
on yarn as a service and that gives you
different tabs so you have the instances
which tells basically what are the
different roles for your yarn service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them show in stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as I was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about allocations
so here if we see we can be looking for
yarn App mapreduce application Master
resource CPU course what is the CPU
course allocated for map reduce map task
reduce task you can be looking at yarn
node manager resource CPU cores which
basically says every node manager on
every node would be allocated with six
CPU cores and the container sizing is
with minimum allocation of one CPU core
and the maximum could be two CPU cores
similarly you could also be searching
for memory allocation and here you could
then scroll down to see what kind of
memory allocation has been done for the
node manager so if we look further it
should give me information of node
manager which basically says here that
the container minimum allocation is 2GB
the maximum is 3gb and we can look at
node manager which has been given 25 GB
per node so it's a combination of this
memory and CPU cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web UI and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web UI and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 GB memory allocated so
that could be say 25 GB per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
I could get more information so this
tells me that I have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 GB memory allocated per node and 6
cores out of which some portion is being
utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root q and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically users queue based on different
users we can always scroll here and that
can give us information if it is a fair
share so here we see that my root dot
default has 50 of resources and the
other queue also has 50 of resources
which also gives me an idea that a fair
scheduler is being used we can always
confirm that if we are using a fair
scheduler or a capacity scheduler which
takes care of allocation so search for
scheduler and that should give you some
understanding of what kind of scheduler
is being used and what are the
allocations given for that particular
scheduler so here we have Fair scheduler
it shows me you have under root you have
the root queue which has been given 100
capacity and then you have within that
default which also takes hundred percent
so this is how you can understand about
yarn by Looking In into the yarn web UI
you can be looking into the
configurations you can look at
applications you can always look at
different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your yarn UI what I can
also do is I can be going into Hue which
is the web interface and your web
interface also basically allows you to
look into the jobs so you can click on
Hue web UI and if you have access to
that it should show up or you should
have a way to get to your Hue which is a
graphical user interface mainly comes
with your Cloud era you can also
configure that with Apache hortonworks
has a different way of giving you the
web UI access you can click and get into
Hue and that is also one way where you
can look at yarn you can look at the
jobs we which are running if there are
some issues with it and these these are
your web interfaces so either you look
from yarn web UI or here in Hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here I can just remove this one
which should basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here I have list of all the
applications and it says this was a map
reduce this was a spark something was
killed something was successful and this
was basically a probably a hive query
which triggered a mapreduce job you can
click on the application and that tells
you how many tasks were run for it so
there was a map task which ran for it
you can get into the metadata
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the yarn UI to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a map reduce how many map and reduced
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web UI to look
into the jobs you can be finding in a
lot of useful information here you can
also be looking at how many resources
were used and what happened to the job
was it successful did it fail and what
was the job status now apart from web UI
which always you might not have access
to so in a particular cluster in a
production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have access given to all the users
to graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloud error manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your Edge node or clang
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's login here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in mapred
which gives you different options where
you can look at the mapreduce related
jobs you can look at different queues if
there are queues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if I just say
mapred and queue here this basically
gives me an option says what would you
want to do would you want to list all
the queues do you want information on a
particular queue so let's try a list and
that should give you different queues
which were being used now here we know
that per user a queue dynamically gets
created which is under root dot users
and that gives me what is the status of
the queue what is the capacity has there
been any kind of maximum capacity or
capping done so we get to see a huge
list of queues which dynamically get
configured in this environment and then
you also look at your root dot default I
could have also picked up one particular
queue and I could have said show me the
jobs so I could do that now here we can
also give a yarn command so let me just
clear the screen and I will say yarn and
that shows me different options so apart
from your web interface something like
web UI apart from your Yarns web UI you
could also be looking for information
using yarn commands here so these are
some list of commands which we can check
now you can just type in yarn and
version if you would want to see the
version which basically gives you
information of what is the Hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloud
errors distribution 5.14 which is
internally using Hadoop 2.6 now
similarly you can be doing a yarn
application list so if you give this
that could be an exhaustive list of all
the applications which are running or
applications which have completed so
here we don't see any applications
because right now probably there are no
applications which are running it also
shows you you could be pulling out
different status such as submitted
accepted or running now you could also
say I would want to see the services
that I've finished running so I could
say yarn application list and app States
as finished so here we could be using
our Command so I could say yarn
application list and then I would want
to see the app states which gives me the
applications which have finished and we
would want to list all the applications
which finished now there that might be
applications which succeeded right and
there is a huge list of application
which is coming in from the history
server which is basically showing you
the huge list of applications which have
completed so this is one way and then
you could also be searching for one
particular application if you would want
to search a particular application if
you have the application ID you could
always be doing a grip that's a simple
way I could say basically let's pick up
this one and if I would want to search
for this if I would want more details on
this I could obviously do that by
calling in my previous command and you
could do a grip if that's what you want
to do and if you would want to search is
there any application which is in the
list of my applications that shows my
application I could pull out more
information about my application so I
could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application ID so I could say yarn logs
now that's an option and every time any
time you have a doubt just hit enter it
will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so I can say yarn logs application ID
now we copied an application ID and we
could just give it here we could give
other options like app owner or if you
would want to get into the Container
details or if you would want to check on
a particular node now here I'm giving
yarn logs and then I am pointing it to
an application ID and it says the log
aggregation has not completed might be
this was might be this was an
application which was triggered based on
a particular interactive cell or based
on a particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so soap here you can be saying yarn yarn
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit and enter
it shows you the different options so we
just tried app States you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status I could be giving
my application ID so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application ID what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much GB memory and how
many core seconds it used so this is is
basically looking out at the application
details now I could kill an application
if the application was already running I
could always do a yarn application minus
skill and then I could be giving my
application now I could try killing this
however it would say the application is
already finished if I had an application
running and if my application was
already given an application ID by The
Source manager I Could Just Kill it I
can also say yarn node list which would
give me a list of the node managers now
this is what we were looking from the
yarn web UI and we were pulling out the
information so we can get this and kind
of information from your command line
always remember and always try to be
well accustomed with the command line so
you can do various things from the
command line and then obviously you have
the web uis which can help you with a
graphical interface easily able to
access things now you could be also
starting the resource manager which we
would not be doing here because we are
already running in a cluster so you
could give a yarn resource manager you
could get the logs of resource manager
if you would want by giving yarn demin
so we can try that so you can say yarn
and then demon so it says it does not
find the demon so you can give something
like this get level and here I will have
to give the node and the IP address
where you want to check the logs of
resource manager so you could be giving
this for which we will have to then get
into Cloudera manager to look into the
nodes and the IP address you could be
giving a command something like this
which basically gives you the level of
the log which you have and I got this
resource manager address from the web UI
now I can be giving in this command to
look into the demon log and it basically
says you would want to look at the
resource manager related log and you
have have the log 4J which is being used
for logging the kind of level which has
been set as info which can again be
changed in the way you're logging the
information now you can try any other
commands also from yarn for example
looking at the yarn RM admin so you can
always do a yarn RM admin and this
basically gives you lot of other
informations like refreshing the queues
or refreshing the nodes or basically
looking at the admin ACLS or getting
groups so you could always get group
names for a particular user now we could
search for a particular user such as
yarn or hdfs itself so I could just say
here I would want get groups and then I
could be searching for say username hdfs
so that tells me sdfs belongs to a
Hadoop group similarly you could search
for say mapred or you could search for
yarn so these are service related users
which automatically get created and you
can pull out information related to
these you can always do a refresh nodes
kind of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when you
are doing commissioning decommissioning
but then in case of Cloudera or
hortonworks kind of cluster you would
not be manually giving this command
because if you are doing a commissioning
decommissioning from an admin console
and if you are an administrator then you
could just restart the services which
are affected and that will take care of
this but if you were working in an
Apache cluster and if you are doing
commissioning decommissioning then you
would be using in two commands refresh
notes and basically that's for
refreshing the nodes which should not be
used for processing and similarly you
could have a command refresh notes which
comes with stfs so these are different
options which you can use with your yarn
on the command line you could also be
using curl commands to get more
information about your cluster by giving
curl minus X and then basically pointing
out to your resource manager web UI
address now here I would like to print
out the cluster related metrics and I
could just simply do this which
basically gives me a high level
information of how many applications
were submitted how many are pending what
is the reserved resources what is the
available amount of memory or CPU cores
and all the information similarly you
can be using the same curl commands to
get more information like scheduler
information so you would just replace
the metrics with scheduler and you could
get the information of the different
queues now that's a huge list we can
cancel this and that would give me the
list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
IDs and status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say I would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
notes so you can always be looking at
node specific information which gives
you how many nodes you have but this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command and would want to get
information about your cluster from an
HTTP interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample mapreduce job which
could then be triggered on yarn and it
would use the resources now I can look
at my application here and I can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have a lot of
files and directories which we have here
now I could pick up one of these and I
could be using a simple example to do
some processing let's take up this file
so there is a file and I could run a
simple word count or I could be running
a hive query which triggers a mapreduce
job I could even run a spark application
which would then show that the
application is running on the cluster so
for example if I would say spark to
Shell now I know that this is an
interactive way of working with spark
but this internally triggers a spark
submit and this runs an application so
here when you do a spark 2 Shell by
default it will contact yarn so it gets
an application ID it is running on yarn
with the master being yarn and now I
have access to the interactive way of
working with spark now if I go and look
into applications I should be able to
see my application which has been
started here and it shows up here so
this is my application
3827 which has been started on yarn and
as of now we can also look into the yarn
UI and that shows me the application
which has been started which basically
has one running container which has one
CPU core allocated 2GB RAM and it's in
progress although we are not doing
anything there so we can always look at
our applications from the yarn UI or as
I mentioned from your applications tab
within yarn Services which gives us the
information and you can even click on
this application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which I triggered using
spark shell similarly I can basically be
running a map reduce now to run a map
reduce I can say Hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt Cloud
era Parcels CDH lib Hadoop map reduce
Hadoop map reduce examples and then we
can look at this particular jar file and
if I hit on enter it shows me the
different classes which are part of this
jar and here I would like to use word
count so I could just give this I could
say word count now remember I could run
the job in a particular queue by giving
in an argument here so I could say minus
D mapred dot job dot Q dot name and then
I can point my job to a particular queue
I can even give different arguments in
saying I would want my mapreduce output
to be compressed or I want it to be
stored in a particular directory and so
on so here I have the word count and
then basically what I can be doing is I
can be pointing it to a particular input
path and then I can have my output which
can be getting stored here again a
direct tree which we need to choose and
I will say output new and I can submit
my job now once I have submitted my job
it connects to resource manager it
basically Gets a Job ID it gets an
application ID it shows you from where
you can track your application you can
always go to the yarn UI and you can be
looking at your application and the
resources it is using so my application
was not a big one and it has already
completed it triggered one map task it
launched one reduce task it was working
on around 12 466 records where you have
then the output of map which is these
many number of output records which was
then taken by a combiner and finally by
a reducer which basically gives you the
output so this is my yarn application
which has completed now I could be
looking into the yarn UI and if my job
has completed you might not see your
application here so as of now it shows
up here the word count which I ran it
also shows me my previous spark shell
job it shows me my application is
completed and if you would want further
information on this you can click and go
to the history server if you have been
given access to it or directly go to the
history server web UI where your
application shows up it shows how many
map and reduce tasks it was running you
can click on this particular application
which basically gives you information of
your map and reduce tasks you can look
at different counters for your
application right you can always look at
map specific tasks you can always look
into one particular task what it did on
which node it was running or you can be
looking at the complete application log
so you can always click on the logs and
here you have click here for full log
which gives you the information and you
can always look for your application
which can give you information of App
Master being launched or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released so
you can always look into the log for
more information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web UI or you can also be looking into
your Hue for more information welcome to
scoop tutorial one of the many features
of the Hadoop ecosystem for the Hadoop
file system what's in it for you today
we're going to cover the need for scoop
what is scoop scoop features scoop
architecture scoop import scoop export
scoop processing and then finally we'll
have a little Hands-On demo on scoop so
you can see what it looks like so where
does the need for scoop come in in our
big data Hadoop file system processing
huge volumes of data requires loading
data from diverse sources into Hadoop
cluster you can see here we have our
data processing and this process of
loading data from the heterogeneous
sources comes with a set of challenges
so what are the challenges maintaining
data consists resistancy ensuring
efficient utilization of resources
especially when you're talking about big
data we can certainly use up the
resources when importing terabytes and
petabytes of data over the course of
time loading bulk data to Hadoop was not
possible it's one of the big challenges
that came up when they first had the
Hadoop file system going and loading
data using script was very slow in other
words you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to Hadoop very easily so
think your Enterprise server you want to
take the from MySQL or your SQL and you
want to bring that data into your Hadoop
Warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoob comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between Hadoop and
external data storage such as relational
databases and MySQL server or the
Microsoft SQL server or MySQL server so
scoop equals SQL plus Hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the Hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from Hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features scoop
features has parallel Import and Export
it has import results of SQL query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
Kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel Import and Export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to Import and Export data this
provides fault Tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result return from an SQL carry into
the Hadoop file system or the hdfs and
you can see here where the import
results of SQL query come in SKU
provides connectors for multiple
relational data database management
system rdbms's databases such as MySQL
and Microsoft SQL server and it has
connectors for all major rdbms databases
scoop supports Kerberos computer network
Authentication Protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the Hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have our Enterprise data warehouse
document based systems you have connect
connector for your data warehouse a
connector for document-based systems
which reaches out to those two entities
and we have our connector for the rdbms
so connectors help in working with a
range of popular databases multiple
mappers perform map tasks to load the
data onto hdfs the Hadoop file system
and you can see here we have the map
task if you remember from Hadoop Hadoop
is based on mapreduce because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over it only accesses the mappers and it
opens up multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase hive is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our rdbms datastore and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your
company's database maybe it's an archive
at Google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think with
scoop you think SQL you think MySQL
server or Microsoft SQL Server that kind
of setup so it gathers the metadata and
you see the scoop import so introspect
database to gather metadata primary key
information and then it submits so you
can see submits map only job remember we
talked about mapreduce it only needs the
map side of it because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over scoop device the input data set
into splits and uses individual map
tests to push the splits into hdfs so
right into the Hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a Hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your Hadoop
file system storage which is your Hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers that has data on it so the
first step is you've got to gather the
metadata so step one you gather the
metadata step two submits map only job
introspect database to gather metadata
primary key information scoop divides
the input data set into splits and uses
individual map tests to push the splits
to rdbms scoop will export Hadoop files
back to rdms tables and you can think of
this in a number of different manners
one of them would be if you're restoring
a backup from the Hadoop file system
into your Enterprise machines there's
certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our URL so
specify the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify The
Connection Manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use Hadoop map reduce home directory
override Hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print uses instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
The Connection Manager class to use
manually SFI jdbc driver class to use
you do have to let it know to override
the Hadoop map reduce home and that's
true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setups so
you can see the format for a scoop is
pretty straightforward both Import and
Export so let's uh continue on our path
and look at scoop processing and what
the computer goes through for that and
we talk about scoop processing first
scoop runs in the Hadoop cluster it
Imports data from the rdbms the nosql
database to the Hadoop file system so
remember it might not be importing the
data from a rdbms it might actually be
coming from an osql and there's many out
there it uses mappers to slice the
incoming data into multiple formats and
load the data into hdfs it exports data
back into an rdbms while making sure
that the schema of the data in the
database is maintained so now that we've
looked at the basic commands in our
scoop in the scoop processing or at
least the basics thus far some theory is
concerned let's just jump in and take a
look at a demo on scoop
[Music]
for this demo I'm going to use our
Cloudera quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your your Horton sandbox
which is also a single node testing
machine Cloudera is one of um there's a
Docker version instead of virtual box
and you can also set up your own Hadoop
cluster plan a little extra time if
you're not an admin it's actually a
pretty significant Endeavor for an admin
if you've been admitting Linux machines
for a very long time and you know a lot
of the commands I find it for most
admins it takes them about two to four
hours the first time they go in and
create a virtual machine and set up
their own Hadoop in this case though I
mean you're just learning and getting
set up best to start with Cloudera
Cloudera also includes an installed
version of MySQL that way you don't have
to worry install the the SQL version for
importing data from and two once you're
in the Cloudera quick start you'll see
it a nice Centos Linux interface and it
has a desktop setup on there this is
really nice for learnings here not just
looking at command lines and from in
here it should open up by default to Hue
if not you can click on Hue here's a
kind of a fun little web-based interface
under Hue I can go under query I can
pick an editor and we'll go right down
to scoop so now I'm just going to load
the scoop editor in our Hue now I'm
going to switch over and do this all in
command line I just want to show that
you can actually do this in a hue
through the web-based interface the
reason I like to do the command line is
specifically on my computer it runs much
quicker or if I do the command line here
and I run it it tends to have an extra
lag or an added layer in it so for this
we're going to go ahead and open our
command line the second reason I do this
is we're going to need to go ahead and
edit our MySQL so we have something to
scoop in other words I don't have
anything going in there and of course we
zoom in zoom in this and increase the
size of our screen so for this demo are
Hands-On I'm going to use Oracle
virtualbox manager and the Cloudera
quick start if you're not familiar with
this we do have another tutorial we put
out and you can send a note in the
YouTube video below and let our team
know and they'll send you a link or come
visit
www.simpylearn.com now this creates a
Linux box on my Windows computer so
we're going to be in Linux and it'll be
the Cloudera version with scoop it will
also be using MySQL MySQL server once
inside the Cloudera virtual box we'll go
into the Hue editor now we're going to
do everything in terminal window but I
just want you to be aware that under the
Hue editor you can go under query editor
and you'll see as we come down here
here's our scoop on this so you can run
your Scoop from in here now before we do
this we have to do a little exploration
in my SQL and MySQL server that way we
know what data is coming in so let me go
ahead and open up a terminal window in
Cloudera you have a terminal window at
the top here that you can just click on
and open it up and let me just go ahead
and zoom in on here go View and zoom in
now to get into my SQL Server you
typically type in MySQL and this part
will depend on your setup now the
Cloudera quick start comes up that the
username is root and the password is
Cloudera kind of a strange Quirk is that
you can put a space between the minus U
and the root but not between the minus p
and the Cloudera usually you'd put in a
minus capital P and then it prompts you
for your password on here for this demo
I don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into MySQL server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
MySQL and we're going to do just a
couple of quick commands in here there's
show databases and you follow by the
semicolon that's standard in most of
these shell commands so it knows it's
the end of your shell command and you'll
see in here in the quick start Cloudera
quick start the MySQL comes with the
standard set of databases these are just
some of these have to do like with the
uzi which is the uzi part of Hadoop
where others of these like customers and
employees and stuff like that those are
just for demo purposes they come as a
standard setup in there so that people
going in for the first time have a
database to play with which is really
good for us so we don't have to recreate
those databases and you will see on the
list here we have a retail underscore DB
and then we can simply do uh use retail
underscore DB this will set that as a
default in MySQL and then we want to go
ahead and show the tables and if we show
the tables you can see under the
database the retail DB database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard SQL
command and if you did our Hive language
you'll note remember it's the same for
hql also on this we're just going to
select star everything from departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
Departments table and you'll see we have
has six lines in here and it has a
department ID and a department name two
for Fitness three for Footwear so on and
so forth now at this point I can just go
ahead and exit but it's kind of nice to
have this data up here so we can look at
it and flap back and forth between the
screens so I'm going to open up another
terminal window and we'll go ahead and
zoom in on this also and it isn't too
important for this particular setup but
it's always kind of fun to know what
your setup you're working with what is
your host name and so we'll go ahead and
just type that in this is a Linux
command and it's uh hostname minus F and
you see we're on quick start Cloudera no
surprise there now this next command is
going to be a little bit longer because
we're going to be doing our first scoop
command and I want to do two of them
we're going to list databases and tables
this is going to take just a moment to
get through this because there's a bunch
of stuff going on here so we have scoop
we have list databases we have connect
and under the connect command we need to
let it know how we're connecting we're
going to use the jdbc this is a very
standard one jdbc MySQL so you'll see
that if you're doing an SQL database
that's how you start it off with and
then the next part this is where you
have to go look it up it's however it
was created so if your admin created a
MySQL server with a certain setup that's
what you have to go by and you'll see
that usually they list this as localhost
so you'll see something like localhost
sometimes there's a lot of different
formats but the most common is either
localhost or the actual connection so in
this case we want to go ahead and do
quick start
3306 and so quick start is the name of
the localhost database and how it's
hosted on here and when you set up the
quick start for for Hadoop under
Cloudera it's Port 3306 as that's coming
in so that's where all that's coming
from and so there's our path for that
and then we have to put in our password
we typically type password if you look
it up password on the cloud era quick
start is Cloudera and we have to also
let it know the username and again if
you're doing this you'd probably put in
a minus Capital you can actually just do
it for a prompt Cloud for the password
so if you leave that out it'll prompt
you but for this doesn't really matter I
don't care if you see my password it's
the default one for Cloudera quick start
and then the username on here is simply
root and then we're going to put our
semicolon at the end and so we have here
our full setup then we go ahead and list
the databases and you'll see you may get
some warnings on here I haven't run the
updates on the quick start I suggest you
not running the updates either if you're
doing this for the first time because
it'll do some reformatting on there and
it quickly pops up and you can see
here's all of our the tables we went in
there and if we go back to on the
previous window we should see that these
tables match so here we come in and here
we have our databases and you can see
back up here where we had the CM
customers employees and so on so the
databases match and then we want to go
ahead and list the tables for a specific
database so let's go ahead and do that
I'm a very lazy typist so I'll put the
up arrow in and you can see here scoop
list databases we're just going to go
back and change this from databases to
list tables so we want to list the
tables in here same connection so most
the connection is the same except we
need to know which tables we're listing
an interesting fact is you can create a
table without being under a database so
if you left this blank it will show the
open tables that aren't connected
directly to a database or under a
database but what we want to do is right
past this last slash on the 3306 we want
to put that retail underscore DB because
that's the database we're going to be
working with and this will go in there
and show the tables listed under that
database and here we go we got
categories customers departments order
items and products and if we flip back
here real quick there it is the same
thing we had we had categories customers
departments order items and so on and so
let's go ahead and run our first import
command and again I'm that lazy typer so
we're going to do scoop and instead of
list tables we want to go ahead and
import so there's our import command and
so once we have our import command in
there then we need to tell it exactly
what we're going to import so everything
else is the same we're importing from
the retail DB so we keep that and then
at the very end we're going to tag on
dash dash table that tells it so we can
tell it what table we're importing from
and we're going to import departments
there we go so this is pretty
straightforward because what's nice
about this is you can see the commands
are the same I got the same connection
um I change it for the whatever database
I'm in then I come in here our password
and the username are going to be the
same that's all under the MySQL server
setup and then we let it know what table
we're entering in we run this and this
is going to actually go through the
mapper process in Hadoop so this is a
mapping process it takes the data and it
Maps it up to different parts in the
setup in Hadoop on there and then saves
that data into the Hadoop file system
and it does take it a moment to zip
through which I kind of skipped over for
you since it is running a you know it's
designed to run across the cluster not
on a single node so when you're running
on a single node it's going to run slow
even if you dedicate a couple cores to
it I think I put dedicated four cores to
this one and so you can see right down
here we get to the end it's now mapped
in that information and then we can go
in here we can go under we can flip back
to our Hue and under Hue on the top I
have there's databases the second icon
over is your Hadoop file system and we
can go in here and look at the Hadoop
file system and you'll see it show up
underneath our documents there it is
departments Cloudera departments and you
can see there's always a delay when I'm
working in Hue which I don't like and
that's the quick start issue that's not
necessarily running out on a server when
I'm running it on a server you pretty
much have to run through some kind of
server interface I still prefer the
terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker but we'll flip back on over here
to the command line and we can do the
Hadoop type in the Hadoop fs and then
list minus LS and if we run this you'll
see underneath our Hadoop file system
there is our departments which has been
added in and we can also do Hadoop fs
and this is kind of interesting for
those who've gone through the Hadoop
file system everything you'll you'll
recognize this on here but I'm going to
list it the contents of departments and
you'll see underneath the Departments we
have part part m0001
002003 and so this is interesting
because this is how Hadoop saves these
files and this is in the file system
this is not in Hive so we didn't
directly import this into Hive we put
this in the Hadoop file system depending
on what you're doing you would then
write the schema for Hive to look at the
Hadoop file system certainly visit our
Hive tutorial for more information on
hive specific uh so you can see in here
are different files that it forms that
are part of departments and we can do
something like this we can look at the
contents of one of these files FS minus
LS or a number of the files and we'll
simply do the full path which is user
Cloudera and then we already know the
next one is departments and then after
departments we're going to put slash
part star so this is going to see
anything that has part in it so we have
part Dash m000 and so on we can go ahead
and cat use that cat command or that
list command to bring those up and then
we can use the cat command to actually
display the contents and that's a a
Linux command Hadoop Linux command
catenate not to be confused with
catatonic catastrophic there's a lot of
cat got your tongue and we see here
Fitness Footwear apparel that should
look really familiar because that's what
we had in our MySQL server when we went
in here we did a select all on here
there it is Fitness Footwear apparel
golf outdoors and fan shop and then of
course it's really important slip back
on over here to be able to tell it where
to put the data so we go back to our
import command so here's our scoop
import we have our connect we have the
DB underneath our connection our MySQL
server we have our password our username
the table going where it's going to I
mean the table where it's coming from
and then we can add a Target on here we
can put in Target Dash directory and you
do have to put the full path that's a
Hadoop thing it's a good practice to be
in and we're going to add it to
Department we'll just do Department one
and so here we now add a Target
directory in here in user Cloudera
and this will take just a moment before
so I'll go ahead and skip over the
process since it's going to run very
slowly it's only running on like I said
a couple cores and it's also on a single
node and now we can do the uh Hadoop
let's just do the up Arrow file system
list we want just straight list and when
we do the Hadoop file system uh minus LS
or list you'll see that we now have
Department one and we can of course do
list Department one and you can see we
have the files inside Department one and
they mirrored what we saw before with
the same files in there and the part mm0
and so on if we were to look at them
it'd be the same thing we did before
with the cat so except instead of
departments we'd be Department one there
we go one thing that's going to come up
with the same data we had before now one
of the important things when you're
importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think Hadoop Big Data
put it all in there I know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn a couple hundred terabytes into
a petabyte very rapidly and suddenly
you're having to really add on to that
data store and you're storing duplicate
data sometimes so you really need to be
able to filter your data out and so
let's go ahead and use our up Arrow to
go to our last import since it's still a
lot the same stuff so we have all of our
commands under import we have the target
we're going to change this to Department
two so we're going to create a new
directory for this one and then after
departments there's another command that
we didn't really slide in here and
that's our mapping and I'll show you
what this looks like in a minute but
we're going to put M3 in there that
doesn't have nothing to do with the
filtering I'll show you that in a second
though what that's for and we just want
to put in where so where and what is the
where in this case we want to know where
Department ID and if you want to know
where that came from we can flip back on
over here we have Department underscore
IDs this is where that is coming from
that's just the name of the column on
here so we come in here to Department ID
is greater than four simple logic there
you can see where you'd use that for
maybe creating buckets for ages uh you
know age from 10 to 15 20 to 30. you
might be looking for I mean there's all
kinds of reasons why you could use the
where command on here in filter
information out maybe you're doing word
counting and you want to know words that
are used less than a hundred times if
you want to get rid of the and is and
and all the stuff that's used over and
over again so we'll go ahead and put the
where and then Department ID is greater
than four we'll go ahead and hit enter
on here and this will create our
department to set up on this and I'll go
ahead and skip over some of the runtime
again it runs really slow on a single
node a real quick page through our
commands
here we go our list and we should see
underneath the list the department two
on here now and there it is Department
two and then I can go ahead and do list
Department two you'll see the contents
in here and you'll see that there is
only three maps and it could be that the
data created three Maps but remember I
set it up to only use three mappers so
there's zero one and two and we can go
ahead and do a cat on there remember
this is Department two so we want to
look at all the contents of these three
different files and there it is it's
greater than four so we have golf is
five outdoor six uh fan shop is seven so
we've effectively filtered out our data
and just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data remember a lot of times you
have MySQL server and we're continually
dumping that data into our long-term
storage and access a Hadoop file system
but what happens when you need to pull
that data out and restore a database or
uh maybe you have you just merged with a
new company a favorite topic merging
companies emerging databases that's
listed under Nightmare and how many
different names for company can you have
so you can see where being able to
export is also equally important and
let's go ahead and do that and I'm going
to flip back over to my SQL Server here
and we'll need to go ahead and create
our database we're going to export into
now I'm not going to go too much in
detail on this command we're simply
creating a table and the table is going
to have it's pretty much the same table
we already have in here from departments
but in this case we're going to create a
table called Dept so it's the same setup
but it's it's just gonna we're just
giving a different name a different
schema and so we've done that and we'll
go ahead and do a select star from Dept
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there so now we
need to go ahead and Export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our Linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our commands here's scoop Import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export and the connection is going
to remain the same so same connect same
database we're also we're still doing
the retail DB we have the same password
so none of that changes the big change
here is going to be the table instead of
departments remember we changed it and
gave it a new name and so we want to
change it here also d-e-p-t so
Department we're not going to worry
about the mapper count and the where was
part of our import there we go and then
finally it needs to know where to export
from so instead of Target directory we
have an export directory that's where
it's coming from still user Cloudera and
we'll keep it as Department two just so
you can see how that data is coming back
with the that we've filtered in and
let's go ahead and run this it'll take
it just a moment to go through in steps
and again because it's low I'm just
going to go ahead and skip this so you
don't have to sit through it and once
we've wrapped up our export we'll flip
back on over here to mySQL use the up
arrow and this time we're going to
select star from department and we can
see that there it is it exported the
golf outdoors and fan shop and you can
imagine also that you might have to use
the where command in your export also so
there's a lot of mixing the command line
for scoop is pretty straightforward
you're changing the different variables
in there whether you're creating a table
listing a table listing databases very
powerful tool for bringing your data
into the Hadoop file system and
exporting it so now that we've wrapped
up our demo on scoop and gone through a
lot of basic commands let's dive in with
a brief history of Hive so the history
of Hive begins with Facebook Facebook
begin using Hadoop as a solution to
handle the growing big data and we're
not talking about a data that fits on
one or two or even five computers uh
we're talking due to the fifth sign if
you've looked at any of our other Hadoop
tutorials you'll know we're talking
about very big data and data pools and
Facebook certainly has a lot of data it
tracks as we know the Hadoop uses
mapreduce for processing data mapreduce
required users to write long codes and
so you'd have these really extensive
Java codes very complicated for the
average person to use not all users
reversed in Java and other coding
languages this proved to be a
disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in SQL
SQL has been around for a long time the
standard SQL query language Hive was
developed with the vision to incorporate
the concepts of tables columns just like
SQL so why Hive well the problem was for
processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well versed with the coding
languages if you're processing and
you're analyzing and so the solution was
required a language similar to SQL which
was well known to all the users and The
Hive or hql language evolved what is
Hive Hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large data sets stored in the hdfs or
the Hadoop file system Hive uses a query
language that we call Hive ql or hql
which is similar to SQL so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a mapreduce tasks and then accesses the
Hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of Hive
architecture of Hive we have the hive
client so that could be the programmer
or maybe it's a manager who knows enough
SQL to do a basic query to look up the
data they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
Thrift application in the hive Thrift
client Thrift is a software framework
Hive server is based on Thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support through
and then we have our jdbc application
and the hive jdbc driver jdbc Java
database connectivity jdbc application
is connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python C plus plus spart Java
you can find just about any connection
in any of the main scripting languages
and so we have our Hive Services as we
look at deeper into the architecture
Hive supports various services so you
have your Hive server basically your
Thrift application or your hive Thrift
client or your jdbc or your hive jdbc
driver your odbc application or your
hive odbc driver they all Connect into
The Hive server and you have your hive
web interface you also have your CLI now
the hive web interface is a GUI is
provided to execute Hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
CLI and then the CLI is a direct
terminal window and I'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver Hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver The Hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler Hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimized logical plan in the form
of a graph of mapreduce and hdfs tasks
is obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed when we look at the
architecture we also have to note the
metastore metastore is a repository for
five metadata stores metadata for Hive
tables and you can think of this as your
schema and where is it located and it's
stored on the Apache Derby DB processing
and resource management is all handled
by the map reduce V1 you'll see
mapreduce V2 the yarn and the tests
these are all different ways of managing
these resources depending on what
version of Hadoop you're in Hive uses
mapreduce framework to process queries
and then we have our distributed storage
which is the hdfs and if you looked at
our Hadoop tutorials you'll know that
these are on commodity machines and are
linearly scalable that means they're
very affordable a lot of time when
you're talking about Big Data you're
talking about a tenth of the price of
storing it on Enterprise computers and
then we look at the data flow And Hive
so in our data flow And Hive we have our
Hive in the Hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the UI we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our metastore that all goes into the
map reduce and the Hadoop file system so
when we acute a query and see it coming
in here it goes into the driver step one
step two we get a plan what are we going
to do refers to the query execution then
we go to the metadata it's like well
what kind of metadata are we actually
looking at where is this data located
what is the schema on it uh then this
that comes back with the metadata into
the compiler then the compiler takes all
that information and the send plan
returns it to the driver the driver then
sends the execute plan to the execution
engine once it's in the execution engine
the execution engine acts as a bridge
between Hive and Hadoop to process the
query and that's going into your map
reduce and your Hadoop file system or
your hdfs and then we come back with the
metadata operations it goes back into
the metastore to update or let it know
what's going on which also goes to the
between it's a communication between the
execution engine and the metastore
execution engine Communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional send results
communication back into the driver and
then we have the fetch results which
goes back to the client so let's take a
little bit look at the hive data
modeling Hive data modeling so you have
your high data modeling you have your
tables you have your partitions and you
have buckets the tables in however
created the same way it is done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional SQL server or MySQL server
where you might have Enterprise
equipment and a lot of people pulling
and moving stuff off of there the tables
are going to look very similar and this
makes it very easy to take that
information and let's say you need to
keep current information but you need to
store all of your years of transactions
back into the Hadoop Hive so you match
those so it's all kind of look the same
the tables are the same your databases
look very similar and you can easily
import them but you can easily store
them into the hive system partitions
here tables are organized into
partitions for grouping same type of
data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets data present in partitions can
be further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency at this level a lot of times
you're taught you're working with the
programmer and the admin of your Hadoop
file system to maximize the efficiency
of that file system so it's usually a
two-person job and we're talking about
Hive data modeling you want to make sure
that they work together and you're
maximizing your resources Hive data
types so we're talking about Hive data
types we have our primitive data types
and our complex data types A lot of this
would look familiar because it mirrors a
lot of stuff in SQL in our primitive
data types we have the numerical data
types string data type date time data
type and miscellaneous data type and
these should be very they're kind of
self-explanatory but just in case
numerical data is your floats your
integers your short integers all of that
numerical data comes in as a number a
string of course is character vectors
and numbers and then you have your date
time step and then we have kind of a
general way of pulling your own created
data types in there that's your
miscellaneous data type and we have
complex data types so you can store
arrays you can store maps you can store
structures and even units in there as we
dig into Hive data types and we have the
primitive data types and the complex
data types so we look at primitive data
types and we're looking at numeric data
types data types like an integer a float
a decimal those are all stored as
numbers in the hive data system a string
data type data types like characters and
strings you store the name of the person
you're working with you know John Doe
the city
State Tennessee maybe it's Boulder
Colorado USA or maybe it's hyperbad
India that's all going to be string it's
stored as a string character and of
course we have our date time data type
data types like time stamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that so you just
think if you can type a stamp of time on
it or maybe you're dealing with the race
and you want to know the interval how
long did the person take to complete
whatever task it was all that is date
time data type and then we talk
miscellaneous data type these are like
Boolean in binary and when you get into
Boolean and binary you can actually
almost create anything in there but your
yes nose zero one now let's take a look
at complex data types a little closer we
have arrays so your syntax is of data
type and it's an array and you can just
think of an array as a collection of
same entities one two three four if
they're all numbers and you have Maps
this is a collection of key value pairs
so understanding is so Central to Hadoop
so we store Maps you have a key which is
a set you can only have one key per
mapped value and so you in Hadoop of
course you collect the same keys and you
can add them all up or do something with
all the contents of the same key but
this is our map as a primitive type data
type in our collection of key value
Pairs and then collection of complex
data with comment so we can have a
structure we have the column name data
type comment column comment so you can
get very complicated structures in here
with your collection of data and your
commented setup and then we have units
and this is a collection of
heterogeneous data types so the syntax
for this is Union type data type data
type and so on so it's all going to be
the same a little bit different than the
arrays where you can actually mix and
match different modes of Hive Hive
operates in two modes depending on the
number and size of data nodes we have
our local mode and our map reduce mode
when we talk about the local mode it is
used when Hadoop is having one data node
and the data is small processing will be
very fast in a smaller data sets which
are present in local machine and this
might be that you have a local file
stuff you're uploading into the hive and
you need to do some processes in there
you can go ahead and run those High
processes and queries on it usually you
don't see much in the way of a single
node Hadoop system if you're going to do
that you might as well just use like an
SQL database or even a Java sqlite or
something python is sqlite so you don't
really see a lot of single node Hadoop
databases but you do see the local mode
in Hive where you're working with a
small amount of data that's going to be
integrated into the larger database and
then we have the map reduce mode this is
used when Hadoop is having multiple data
nodes and the data is spread across
various data nodes processing large data
sets can be more efficient using this
mode and this you can think of instead
of it being one two three or even five
computers we're usually talking with the
Hadoop file system we're looking at 10
computer
fifteen a hundred where this data is
spread across all those different Hadoop
nodes difference between Hive and rdbms
remember rdbms stands for the relational
database management system let's take a
look at the difference between Hive and
the rdbms with Hive Hive enforces schema
on read and it's very important that
whatever is coming in that's when hive's
looking at it and making sure that it
fits the model the rdbms enforces a
schema when it actually writes the data
into the database so it's read the data
and then once it starts to write it
that's where it's going to give you the
error or tell you something's incorrect
about your scheme Hive data size is in
petabytes that is hard to imagine you
know when we're looking at your personal
computer on your desk maybe you have 10
terabytes if it's a high-end computer
we're talking petabytes so that's
hundreds of computers grouped together
when a rdbms data size is in terabytes
very rarely do you see an rdbms system
that's spread over more than five
computers and there's a lot of reasons
for that with the rdbms it actually has
a high-end amount of rights to the hard
drive there's a lot more going on there
your writing and polling stuff so you
really don't want to get too big with an
rdbm Master you're going to run into a
lot of problems with Hive you can take
it as big as you want Hive is based on
the notion of right ones and read many
times this is so important they call it
worm which is right W10 read R many
times M they refer to it as warm and
that's true of any of you a lot of your
Hadoop setup it's it's altered a little
bit but in general we're looking at
archiving data that you want to do data
analysis on we're looking at pulling all
that stuff off your rdbms from years and
years and years of business or whatever
your company does or scientific research
and putting that into a huge data pool
so that you can now do queries on it and
get that information out of it with the
rdbms it's based on the notion of read
and write many times so you're
continually updating this database
you're continually bringing up new stuff
new sales the account changes because
they have a different licensing now
whatever software you're selling all
that kind of stuff or the data is
continually fluctuating and then Hive
resembles a traditional database by
supporting SQL but it is not a database
it is a data warehouse this is very
important it goes with all the other
stuff we've talked about that we're not
looking at a database but a data
warehouse to store the data and still
have fast and easy access to it for
doing queries you can think of Twitter
and Facebook they have so many posts
that are archived back historically
those posts aren't going to change they
made the post they're posted they're
there and they're in their database but
they have to store it in a warehouse in
case they want to pull it back up with
the rdbms it's a type of database
management system which is based on the
relational model of data and then with
Hive easily scalable at a low cost again
we're talking maybe a thousand dollars
per terabyte the rdbms
scalable at a low cost you first start
on the lower end you're talking about
ten thousand per terabyte of data
including all the backup on the models
and and all the added Necessities to
support it as you scale it up you have
to scale those computers and Hardware up
so you might start off with a basic
server and then you upgrade to a sun
computer to run it and you spend you
know tens of thousands of dollars for
that Hardware upgrade with Hive you just
put another computer into your Hadoop
file system so let's look at some of the
features of Hive when we're looking at
the features of Hive we're talking about
the use of SQL like language called Hive
ql a lot of times you'll see that as hql
which is easier than long codes this is
nice if you're working with your
shareholders you come to them and you
say Hey you can do a basic SQL query on
here and pull up the information you
need this way you don't have to take all
have your programmers jump in every time
they want to look up something in the
database they actually now can easily do
that if they're not skilled in
programming and script writing tables
are used which are similar to the rdbms
hence easier to understand
and one of the things I like about this
is when I'm bringing tables in from a
MySQL server or SQL Server there's
almost a direct reflection between the
two so when you're looking at one which
is a data which is continually changing
and then you're going into the archive
database it's not this huge jump where
you have to learn a whole new language
you mirror that same schema into the
hdfs into the hive making it very easy
to go between the two and then using
Hive ql multiple users can
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of cues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers in the query can go very
quickly depending on how many computers
and how much resources each machine has
to pull the information and Hive
supports a variety of data types so with
Hive it's designed to be on the Hadoop
system which you can put almost anything
into the Hadoop file system so with all
all that let's take a look at a demo on
hive ql or hql before I dive into the
Hands-On demo let's take a look at the
website
hive.apache.org that's the main website
since Apache it's an Apache open source
software this is the main software or
the main site for the build and if you
go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating Hive into beehive and
so if you see beehive versus Hive note
The Beehive is a new release is coming
out that's all it is it reflects a lot
of the same functionality of Hive it's
the same thing and then we like to pull
up some kind of documentation on
commands and for this I'm actually going
to go to hortonworks Hive cheat sheet
and that's because hortonworks when
Cloudera 2 the most common used builds
for Hadoop and four which include Hive
and all the different Tools in there and
so hortonworks has a pretty good PDF you
can download cheat sheet on there I
believe Cloudera does too but we'll go
ahead and just look at the Horton one
because it's the one that comes up
really good and you can see when we look
at the query language it Compares my SQL
Server to Hive ql or hql and you can see
the basic select we select from columns
from table where conditions exist you
know most basic command on there and
they have different things you can do
with it just like you do with your SQL
and if you scroll down you'll see data
types so here's your integer your flow
your binary double string timestamp and
all the different data types you can use
some different semantics different Keys
features functions for running a hive
query command line setup and of course
the hive shell set up in here so you can
see right here if we Loop through it it
has a lot of your basic stuff and it's
we're basically looking at SQL across a
Horton database we're going to go ahead
and run our Hadoop cluster Hive demo and
I'm going to go ahead and use the
Cloudera quick start this is in the
virtual box so again we have an oracle
virtual box which is open source and
then we have our Cloudera quick start
which is the Hadoop set up on a single
node now obviously Hadoop And Hive are
designed to run across a cluster of
computers so we talk about a single node
is for Education testing that kind of
thing and if you have a chance you can
always go back and look at our demo we
had on setting up a Hadoop system in a
single cluster to set a note Down Below
in the YouTube video and our team will
get in contact with you and send you
that link if you don't already have it
or you can contact us at the
www.simplylearn.com now in here it's
always important to note that you do
need on your computer if you're running
on Windows because I'm on a Windows
machine you're going to need probably
about 12 gigabytes to actually run this
it used to be you could buy with a lot
less but as things have evolved they
take up more and more resources and you
need the professional version if you
have the home version I was able to get
that to run but boy did it take a lot of
extra work to get the home version to
let me use a virtual setup on there and
we'll simply click on the Cloudera quick
start and I'm going to start that up and
this is starting up our Linux so we have
our Windows 10 which is a computer I'm
on and then I have the virtual box which
is going to have a Linux operating
system in it and we'll skip ahead so you
don't have to watch the whole install
something interesting to know about the
Cloudera is that it's running on Linux
Centos and for whatever reason I've
always had to click on it and hit the
escape button for it to spin up and then
you'll see the Dos come in here now that
our Cloudera has spun up on our virtual
machine with the Linux on we can see
here we have our it uses the Thunderbird
browser on here by default and
automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because I mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on Amazon web service to play
with this so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into Cloudera and I'm going to
access this in two ways the first one is
we're going to use Hue and I'm going to
open up Hue and it'll take it a moment
to load from the setup on here and Hue
is nice if I go in and use Hue as an
editor into Hive or into the Hadoop
setup usually I'm doing it as a from an
admin side because it has a lot more
information a lot of visuals less to do
with you know actually diving in there
and just executing code and you can also
write this code into files and scripts
and there's other things you can other
ways you can upload it into Hive but
today we're going to look at the command
lines and we'll upload it into Hue and
then we'll go into and actually do our
work in a terminal window Under The Hive
shell now in the Hue browser window if
you go under query and click on the pull
down menu and then you go under editor
and you'll see Hive there we go there's
our Hive setup I go and click on hive
and this will open up our query down
here and now it has a nice little B that
shows our Hive going and we can go
something very simple down here like
show databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
Hive as you always add our punctuation
at the end there and I'll go ahead and
run this and the query will show up
underneath and you'll see down here
since this is a new quick start I just
put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name I haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like a
system function tables your databases up
here there's all kinds of things you can
research you can look at through Hue as
far as a bigger picture the downside of
this is it always seems to lag for me
whenever I'm doing this I always seem to
run slow so if you're in Cloudera you
can open up a terminal window they
actually have an icon at the top you can
also go under applications and under
applications system tools and term
either one will work it's just a regular
terminal window and this terminal window
is now running underneath our Linux so
this is a Linux terminal window or on
our virtual machine which is resting on
our regular Windows 10 machine and we'll
go ahead and zoom this in so you can see
the text better on your own video and I
simply just clicked on view and zoom in
and then all we have to do is type in
Hive and this will open up the shell on
here and it takes it just a moment to
load when starting up Hive I also want
to note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on in your action
you might have to do pseudohive and put
in your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the Linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go ahead and create
a database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if I do
show we'll just do the up
up arrow is a hotkey that works in both
Linux and in Hive so I can go back and
paste through all the commands I've
typed in and we can see now that I have
my there's of course a default database
and then there's the office database so
now we've created a database it was
pretty quick and easy and we can go
ahead and drop the database we can do
drop Database Office now this will work
on this database because it's empty if
your database was not empty you would
have to do Cascade and that drops all
the tables in the database and the
database itself now if we do show
database and we'll go ahead and recreate
our database because we're going to use
the office database for the rest of this
Hands-On demo a really handy command to
Now set with the SQL or hql is to use
office and what that does is that sets
office as the default database so
instead of having to reference the
database every time we work with a table
it now automatically assumes that's the
database being used whatever tables
we're working on the difference is you
put the database name period table and
I'll show you in just a minute what that
looks like and how that's different if
we're going to have a table and a
database we should probably load some
data into it so let me go ahead and
switch gears here and open up a terminal
window you can just open another
terminal window and it'll open up right
on top of the one that you have Hive
shell running in and when we're in this
terminal window first we're going to go
ahead and just do a list which is of
course a Linux command you can see all
the files I have in here this is the
default load we can change directory to
documents we can list in documents and
we're actually going to be looking at
employee.csv a Linux command is the cat
you can use this actually to combine
documents there's all kinds of things
that cat does but if we want to just
display the contents of our
employee.csv file we can simply do cat
employee CSV and when we're looking at
this we want to know a couple things one
there's a line at the top okay so the
very first thing we notice is that we
have a header line the next thing we
notice is that the data is comma
separated and in this particular case
you'll see a space here generally with
these you've got to be real careful with
spaces there's all kinds of things you
got to watch out for because it can
cause issues these spaces won't because
these are all strings that the space is
connected to if this was a space next to
the integer you would get a null value
that comes into the database without
doing something extra in there now with
most of Hadoop that's important to know
that you're writing the data once
reading it many times and that's true of
almost all your Hadoop things coming in
so you really want to process the data
before it gets into the database and for
those who of you have studied data
transformation that's the adult where
you extract transfer form and then load
the data so you really want to extract
and transform before putting it into the
hive then you load it into the hive with
the transform data and of course we also
want to note the schema we have an
integer string string integer integer so
we kept it pretty simple in here as far
as the way the day setup the last thing
that you're going to want to look up is
the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash Cloudera documents and these
are just text documents we're working
with right now we're not doing anything
fancy so we can do a simple git edit
employee.csv and you'll see it comes up
here it's just a text document so I can
easily remove these added spaces there
we go and then we go and just save it
and so now it has a new setup in there
we've edited it the G edit is usually
one of the default that loads into Linux
so any text editor will do back to the
hive shell so let's go ahead and create
a table employee and what I want you to
note here is I did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where I have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so I
can do all of my commands at once now
just so I don't have any typo errors I
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we had the different
values in here which was ID name
Department year of joining and salary
and the ID is an integer name is a
string department string you're joining
energy salary an integer and they're in
Brackets we put close brackets around
them and you could do this all as one
line and then we have row format
delimited Fields terminated by comma and
this is important because the default is
tabs so if I do it now it won't find any
terminated Fields so you'll get a bunch
of null values loaded into your table
and then finally our table properties we
want to skip the header line count
equals one now this is a lot of work for
uploading a single file it's kind of
goofy when you're uploading a single
file that you have to put all this in
here but keep in mind Hive and Hadoop is
designed for writing many files into the
database you write them all in there and
then you can they're saved it's an
archive it's a data warehouse and then
you're able to do all your queries on
them so a lot of times we're not looking
at just the one file coming up we're
loading hundreds of files you have your
reports coming off of your main database
all those reports are being loaded and
you have your log files you have I mean
all this different data is being dumped
into Hadoop and in this case Hive on top
of Hadoop and so we need to let it know
hey how do I handle these files coming
in and then we have the semicolon at the
end which lets us know to go ahead and
run this line and so we'll go ahead and
run that and now if we do a show tables
you can see there's our employee on
there we can also describe if we do
describe employee you can see that we
have our ID integer name string
department string year of joining
integer and salary integer and then
finally let's just do a select star from
employee very basic
sqlnhql command selecting data and it's
going to come up and we haven't put
anything in it so as we expect there's
no data in it so if we flip back to our
Linux terminal window you can see where
we did the cat
employee.csv and you can see all the
data we expect to come into it and we
also did our PWD and right here you see
the path you need that full path when
you are loading data you know you can do
a browse and if I did it right now with
just the employee.csv is the name it
will work but that is a really bad habit
in general when you're loading data
because it's you don't know what else is
going on on the computer you want to do
the full path almost in all your data
loads so let's go ahead and flip back
over here to our Hive shell we're
working in and the command for this is
load data so that says hey we're loading
data that's a hive command hql and we
want local data so you got to put down
local in path so now it needs to know
where the path is now to make this more
legible I'm just going to go ahead and
hit enter then we'll just paste the full
path in there which I have stored over
on the side like a good prepare shared
demo and you'll see here we have home
Cloudera documents employee.csv so it's
a whole path for this text document in
here and we go ahead and hit enter in
there and then we have to let it know
where the data is going so now we have a
source and we need a destination and
it's going to go into the table and
we'll just call it employee we'll just
match the table in there and because I
wanted to execute we put the semicolon
on the end it goes ahead and executes
all three lines now if we go back if you
remember we did the select star from
employee just using the up Arrow to page
through my different commands I've
already typed in you can see right here
we have as we expect we have Rose Sam
Mike and Nick and we have all their
information showing in our four rows and
then let's go ahead and do uh select and
count we'll just look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic select because it doesn't need
to go through the full map reduce phase
but when you start doing a count it does
go through the full map reduce setup in
the hive and Hadoop and because I'm
doing this demo on a single node
Cloudera virtual box on top of a Windows
10. all the benefits of running it on a
cluster are gone and instead is now
going through all those added layers so
it takes longer to run you know like I
said when you do a single node as I said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running it on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from our cheat sheet
which we brought up here from Horton's
it's a pretty good one there's all these
different commands we can do we'll look
at one more command where we do the what
they call sub queries right down here
because that's really common to do a lot
of sub queries and so we'll do select
star or all different columns from
employee e now if we weren't using the
office database it would look like this
from Office dot employee and either one
will work on this particular one because
we have office set as a default on there
so from office employee and then the
command where creates a subset and in
this case we want to know where the
salary is greater than 25
000. there we go and of course we end
with our semicolon if we run this query
you can see it pops up and there's our
salaries the people top earners we have
Rose and it and Mike and HR kudos to
them of course they're fictional I don't
actually we don't actually have a rows
and a mic in those positions or maybe we
do so finally we want to go ahead and do
is we're done with this table now
remember you're dealing with the data
warehouse so you usually don't do a lot
of dropping of tables and databases but
we're going to go ahead and drop this
table here before we drop it one more
quick note is we can change it so what
we're going to do is we're going to
alter table office
employee and we want to go ahead and
rename it there's some other commands
you can do in here but rename is pretty
common and we're going to rename it to
and it's going to stay in office and
turns out one of our shareholders really
doesn't like the word employee he wants
employees plural it's a big deal to him
so let's go ahead and change that name
for the table it's that easy because
it's just changing the meta data on
there and now if we do show tables
you'll see we now have employees not
employee and then at this point maybe
we're doing some house cleaning because
this is all practice so we're going to
go ahead and drop the table and we'll
drop table employees because we changed
the name in there so if we did employee
just give us an error and now if we do
show tables you'll see how the tables
are gone now the next thing we want to
go and take a look at and we're going to
walk back through the loading of data
just real quick because we're going to
load two tables in here and let me just
float back to our terminal window so we
can see what those tables are that we're
loading and so up here we have customer
we have a customer file and we have an
order file we want to go ahead and put
the customers and the orders into here
so those are the two we're doing and of
course it's always nice to see what
you're working with so let's do our cat
customer dot CSV we could always do G
edit but we don't really need to edit
these we just want to take a look at the
data in customer and important in here
is again we have a header so we have to
skip a line comma separated nothing odd
with the data we have our schema which
is integer string integer string integer
so you know you'd want to take that note
that down or flip back and forth when
you're doing it and then let's go ahead
and do cat
order.csv and we can see we have oid
which I'm guessing is the order ID we
have a date up something new we've done
integers and strings but we haven't done
date when you're importing new and you
never worked with the date dates always
one of the more trickier fields to port
in and that's true of just about any
scripting language I've worked with all
of them have their own idea of how
date's supposed to be formatted what the
default is this particular format or its
year and it has all four digits Dash
month two digits Dash day is the
standard import for the hive so you'll
have to look up and see what the
different formats are if you're going to
do a different format in there coming in
or you're not able to pre-process the
data but this would be a pre-processing
of the data thing coming in if you
remember correctly from our edel which
is uh e just in case you weren't able to
hear me last time
ETL which stands for extract transform
then load so you want to make sure
you're transforming this data before it
gets into here and so we're going to go
ahead and bring both this data in here
and really we're doing this so we can
show you the basic join there is if you
remember from our setup merge join all
kinds of different things you can do but
joining different data sets is so common
so it's really important to know how to
do this we need to go ahead and bring in
these two data sets and you can see
where I just created a table customer
here's our schema the integer your name
age address salary here's our delimited
by commas and our table properties where
we skip a line well let's go ahead and
load the data first and then we'll do
that with our order and let's go ahead
and put that in here and I've got it
split into three lines so you can see it
easily we've got load data local in path
so we know we're loading data we know
it's local and we have the path here's
the complete path for oops this is
supposed to be order CSV grab the wrong
one of course it's going to give me
errors because you can't recreate the
same table on there and here we go
create table here's our integer date
customer the basic setup that we had
coming in here for our schema row format
commas table properties skip header line
and then finally let's load the data
into our order table load data local in
path home Cloud error documents
order.csv into table order now if we did
everything right we should be able to do
select star from customer and you can
see we have all seven customers and then
we can do so select star from order and
we have four orders so this is just like
a quick frame we have you know a lot of
times when you have your customer
databases in business you have thousands
of customers from years and years and
some of them you know they move they
close their business they change names
all kinds of things happen so we want to
do is we want to go ahead and find just
the information connected to these
orders and who's connected to them and
so let's go ahead and do it's a select
because we're going to display
information so select and this is kind
of interesting we're going to do c dot
ID and I'm going to Define c as customer
as a customer table in just a minute
then we're going to do c dot name and
again we're going to define the c c dot
age so this means from the customer we
want to know their ID their name their
age and then you know I'd also like to
know the order amount so let's do o for
DOT amount and then this is where we
need to go ahead and Define what we're
doing and I'll go and capitalize from
customer so we're going to take the
customer table in here and we're going
to name it C that's where the C comes
from so that's the customer table C and
we want to join order as o that's where
our o comes from so the O DOT amount is
what we're joining in there and then we
want to do this on we got to tell it how
to connect the two tables C dot ID
equals o Dot customer underscore ID so
now we know how they're joined and now
remember we have seven customers in here
we have four orders and as a processes
we should get a return of four different
names joined together and they're joined
based on of course the orders on there
and once we're done we now have the
order number the person who made the
order their age and the amount of the
order which came from the order table uh
so you have your different information
and you can see how the join works here
very common use of tables and hql and
SQL and let's do one more thing with our
database and then I'll show you a couple
other archive commands and let's go
ahead and do a drop and we're going to
drop Database Office and if you're
looking at this and you remember from
earlier this will give me an error and
let's see what that looks like it says
failed to execute exception one or more
tables exist so if you remember from
before you can't just drop a database
unless you tell it to Cascade that lets
it know I don't care how many tables are
in it let's get rid of it and in Hadoop
since it's an art it's a warehouse a
data warehouse you usually don't do a
lot of dropping maybe at the beginning
when you're developing the schemas and
you realize you messed up you might drop
some stuff but down the road you're
really just adding commodity machines to
take up so you can store more stuff on
it so you usually don't do a lot of
database dropping and some other fun
commands to know is you can do select
round 2.3 as round value you can do a
round off in Hive we can do as floor
value which is going to give us a 2 so
it turns it into an integer versus a
float you it goes down you know
basically truncates it but it goes down
and we can also do ceiling which is
going to round it up so we're looking
for the next integer above there's a few
commands we didn't show in here because
we're on a single node as as an admin to
help speciate the process you usually
add in partitions for the data and
buckets you can't do that on a single
node because the when you add a
partition it partitions it across
separate nodes but beyond that you can
see that it's very straightforward we
have SQL coming in and all your basic
queries that are in SQL are very similar
to hql let's get started with pig why
Pig what is pig map reduce versus Hive
versus pig hopefully you've had a chance
to do our Hive tutorial and our map
reduce tutorial if you haven't send a
note over to Simply learn and we'll
follow up with a link to you we'll look
at Pig architecture working a pig pig
latin data model Pig execution modes a
use case Twitter and features is a pig
and then we'll tag on a short demo so
you can see Pig In Action so why pick as
we all know Hadoop uses mapreduce to
analyze and process big data processing
Big Data consumed more time so before we
had the Hadoop system they'd have to
spend a lot of money on a huge set of
computers and Enterprise machines so he
introduced the Hadoop map reduce and so
afterwards processing Big Data was
faster using mapreduce then what is the
problem with map reduce prior to 2006
all mapreduce programs were written in
Java non-programmers found it difficult
to write lengthy Java codes they faced
issues in incorporating map sort reduce
to fundamentals of mapreduce while
creating a program you can see here map
phase Shuffle and sort reduce phase
eventually it became a difficult task to
maintain and optimize a code due to
which the processing time increased you
can imagine a manager trying to go in
there and eat it in a simple query to
find out data and he has to go talk to
the programmers anytime he wants
anything so that was a big problem not
everybody wants to have a on-call
programmer for every manager on their
team Yahoo faced problems to process and
analyze large data sets using Java as
the codes were complex and lengthy there
was a necessity to develop an easier way
to analyze large data sets without using
time-consuming complex Java modes and
codes and scripts and all that fun stuff
Apache Pig was developed by Yahoo it was
developed with a vision to analyze and
process large data sets without using
complex Java codes Pig was developed
especially for non-programmers pig used
simple steps to analyze data sets which
was time efficient so what exactly is
pick pig is a scripting platform that
runs on Hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses SQL like
queries they're definitely not SQL but
some of them resemble SQL queries and
then we use that to analyze our data Pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at mapreduce versus Hive versus pig
so we start with a compiled language
your map reduce and we have Hive which
is your SQL like query and then we have
pig which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to SQL but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember SQL like
query which is what Hive is based off
looks for structured data and so we get
into scripting languages like Pig now
we're dealing more with semi-structured
and even unstructured data with a Hadoop
map reduce we have a need to write long
complex codes with Hive no need to write
complex codes you could just put it in a
simple SQL query or hql Hive ql and in
pig no need to write complex codes is we
have pig lat now remember in the map
reduce it can produce structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
and as I mentioned before Hive can
process only structured data think rows
and columns where Pig can process
structured semi-structured and
structured data you can think of
structured data as rows and columns
semi-structured as your HTML XML
documents if you have on your web pages
and unstructured could be anything from
groups of documents and written format
Twitter tweets any of those things come
in as very unstructured data and with
our Hadoop mapreduce we have a lower
level of abstraction with both Hive and
pig we have a higher level abstraction
so it's much more easy for someone to
use without having to dive in deep and
write a very lengthy map reduce code and
those map and reduce codes can take 70
80 lines of code when you can do the
same thing in one or two lines with
however Pig this is the advantage Pig
has over Hive it can process only
structured data in Hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to note that separates the
different query languages is we look at
map and reduce map reduce supports
partitioning features as does Hive Pig
no concept partitioning in pigs it
doesn't support your partitioning
feature your partitioning features allow
you to partition the data in such a way
that it can be queried quicker you're
not able to do that in pig mapreduce
uses Java and python while Hive uses an
SQL like query language known as hiveql
or hql Pig Latin is used which is a
procedural data flow language mapreduce
is used by programmers pretty much as
straightforward on Java Hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use Pig for a quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under Hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce and pick
under Pig Code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than Hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where Pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig Latin Pig Latin
is a procedural data flow language used
in pig to analyze data it is easy to
program using Piglet and it is similar
to SQL and then we have the runtime
engine runtime engine represents the
execution environment created to run Pig
Latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your Hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in pig latin
to analyze data using Pig then you have
the grunt shell and it actually says
grunt when we start it up and we'll show
you that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acelic
graph and then we have an Optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to The Logical
Optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into mapreduce jobs and then that is
executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that um the kind of
end you always want to execute
everything once you've created it and so
dump is kind of our execution statement
and you can see right here as we were
talking about earlier once we get to the
execution engine and it's coded into
mapreduce then the map reduce processes
it onto the hdfs working a pig pig latin
script is written by the users so you
have load data and right Pig script and
pig operations so we look at the working
of pig pig latin script is written by
the users there's step one we load data
and write Pig script and step two in
this step all the pig operations are
performed by parser Optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and then we get to step three
execution of the plan in this stage the
results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
Hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data the
data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have Adam Rob or 50. Adam represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string two bolts so we
go from our atom which are most basic
thing so if you look at just Rob or just
50 that's an atom that's our most basic
object we have in pig latin then you
have a tuple Tuple represents sequence
of fields that can be of any data type
it is the same as a row in rdbms for
example a set of data from a single row
and you can see here we have Rob comma
five and you can imagine with many of
our other examples we've used you might
have the ID number the name where they
live their age their date of starting
the job that would all be one row and
store it as a tuple and then we create a
bag a bag is a collection of tuples it
is the same as a table in rdbms and is
represented by brackets and you can see
here we have our table with Rob 5 mic 10
and we also have a map a map is a set of
key value pairs key is of character
array type and a value can be of any
type it is represented by the brackets
and so we have name and age where the
key value is Mike and 10. pig latin has
a fully nestable data model that means
one data type can be nested within
another here's a diagram representation
of pig latin data model and in this
particular example we have basically an
ID number a name an age and a place and
we break this apart we look at this
model from Pig Latin perspective we
start with our field and if you remember
a field contains basically an atom it is
one particular data type and the atom is
stored as a string which it then
converts it into either an integer or
number or character string next we have
our Tuple and in this case you can see
that it represents a row so our Tuple
would be three comma Joe comma 29 comma
California and finally we have our bag
which contains three rows in it in this
particular example let's take a quick
look at Pig X
ution modes
it works in two execution modes
depending on where the data is reciting
and where the pig script is going to run
we have local mode here the pig engine
takes input from the Linux file system
and the output is stored in the same
file system local mode local mode is
useful in analyzing small data sets
using Pig and we have the mapreduce mode
here the pig engine directly interacts
and executes in hdfs and mapreduce in
the mapreduce mode queries written in
pig latin are translated into mapreduce
jobs in a run on a Hadoop cluster by
default Pig runs in this mode there are
three modes in pig depending on how a
pig latin code can be written we have
our interactive mode batch mode and
embedded mode the interactive mode means
coding and executing the script line by
line when we do our example we'll be in
the interactive mode in batch mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension dot Pig and the file is
directly executed and then there's
embedded mode Pig lets its users Define
their own functions udfs in a
programming language such as Java so
let's take a look and see how this works
in a use case in this case use case
Twitter users on Twitter generate about
500 million tweets on a daily basis the
Hadoop mapreduce was used to process and
analyze this data analyzing the number
of tweets created by a user in the Tweet
table was done using mapreduce in Java
programming language and you can see the
problem it was difficult to perform
mapreduce operations as users were not
well versed with written complex Java
codes so Twitter used Apache pig to
overcome these problems and let's see
how let's start with the problem
statement analyze the user table and
tweet table and find out how many tweets
are created by a person and here you can
see we have a user table we have Alice
Tim and John with their ID numbers one
two three and we have a tweet table in
the Tweet table you have your the ID of
the user and then what they tweeted
Google was a good whatever it was
tennis. spacecraft Olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were perform for
analyzing given data first the Twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into Pig storage and this
data is probably on an Enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitters going on and then it goes into
Hadoop file system remember the Hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown Below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from user names and tweet to
the ID link directly to the name so
Alice was user one Tim was 2 and John 3.
and so now they're listed with their
actual tweet the next operation is the
aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count so it's very straightforward we
just want to count how many tweets each
user is doing and finally the result
after the count operation is joined with
the user table to find out the username
and you can see here where Alice had
three Tim two and John 1. Pig reduces
the complexity of the operations which
would have been lengthy using mapreduce
and joining group operation the tweet
and user tables are joined and grouped
using co-group command the next
operation is the aggregation the tweets
are counted according to the names the
command used as count the result after
the count operation is joined with the
user table to find out the username and
you can see we're talking about three
lines of script versus a mapreduce code
of about 80 lines finally we could find
out the number of tweets created by a
user in a simple way so let's go quickly
over some of the features of pig that we
already went through most of these first
ease of programming as Pig Latin is
similar to SQL lesser lines of code need
to be written short development time as
the code is simpler so we can get our
queries out rather quickly instead of
having to have a programmer spend hours
handles all kind of data like structured
semi-structured and unstructured pig
lets us create user defined functions
Pig offers a large set of operators such
as join filter and so on it allows for
multiple queries to process unparallel
and optimization and compilation is easy
as it is done automatically and
internally
[Music]
so enough Theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do and pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go ahead and use Cloudera quick
start and we'll be doing this in Virtual
box we do have a tutorial in setting
that up you can send a note to our
simply learned team and then get that
linked to you once your Cloudera quick
start is uh spun up and remember this is
virtualbox we've created a virtual
machine and this virtual machine is
Centos Linux once it's spun up you'll be
in a full Linux system here it is see we
have Thunderbird browser which opens up
to the Hadoop basic system browser and
we can go underneath the Hue where it
comes up by default if you click on the
pull down menu and go under editor you
can see there's our Impala our Hive uh
Pig along with a bunch of other query
languages you can use and we're going
under Pig and then once you're in pig we
can go ahead and use our command line
here and just click that little blue
button to start it up and running we
will actually be working in terminal
window so if you're in the Cloudera
quick start you can open up the terminal
window up top or if you're in your own
setup and you're logged in you can
easily use all of your commands here in
terminal window and we'll zoom in that
way you get a nice view of what's going
on there we go now for our first command
we're going to do a Hadoop command and
import some data into the Hadoop system
in this case a pig input let's take a
look at this we have Hadoop let's know
it's going to be Hadoop command DFS
there's actually four variations of DFS
so if you have hdfs or whatever that's
fine all four of them Point used to be
different setups underneath different
things and now they all do the same
thing and we want to put this file which
in this case is under home Cloudera
documents and Sample and we just want to
take that and put it into the pig input
and let's take a look at that file if I
go under my document browsers and open
this up you'll see it's got a simple ID
name profession and age we have one Jack
engineer 25. and that was in one of our
earlier things we had in there and so
let's go ahead and hit enter and execute
this and now we've uploaded that data
and it's gone into our Pig input and
then a lot of the Hadoop commands mimic
the Linux commands and so you'll see we
have cat as one of our commands or it
has a hyphen before it so we execute
that with Hadoop DFS hyphen cat slash
Pig input because that's what we called
it that's where we put our sample CSV at
and we execute this you can see from our
Hadoop system it's going to go ahead and
pull that up and sure enough it pulls
out the data file we just put in there
and then we can simply enter the pig
Latin or Pig editor mode by typing in
pick and we can see here by our grunt I
told you that's how it was going to tell
you we're in pig latin there's our grunt
command line so we are now in the pig
shell and then we'll go ahead and put
our load command in here and the way
this works is I'm going to have office
equals load and here's my load when this
case is going to be Pig input we have
that in single brackets remember that's
where the data is in the Hadoop file
system where we dumped it into there
we're going to using Pig storage our
data was separated as with a comma so
there's our comma separator and then we
have as in this case we have an ID
character array name character array
profession character array and age
character array and we're just going to
do them all as character arrays just to
keep this simple for this one and then
when I hit put this all in here you can
see that's our full command line going
in and we have of our semicolon at the
end so when I hit enter it's now set
office up but it hasn't actually done
anything yet it doesn't do anything
until we do dump office so there's our
Command to execute whatever we've loaded
or whatever setup we have in here and we
run that you can see it go through the
different languages and this is going
through the map reduce remember we're
not doing this locally we're doing this
on the Hadoop setup and once we've
finished our dump you can see we have ID
name profession age and all the
information that we just dumped into our
pick oh we can now do let's say oh let's
say we have a request just for we'll
keep it simple in here but just for the
name and age and so we can go office
we'll call it each as our variable
underscore each and we'll say for each
office generate name comma H and for
each means that we're going to do this
for each row and if you're thinking map
reduce you know that this is a map
function because this map each row and
generating name and age on here and of
course we want to go ahead and close it
with the semicolon and then once we've
created our query or the command line in
here let's go ahead and dump office
underscore each and with our semicolon
and this will go through our map reduce
setup on here and if we were on a large
cluster the same processing time would
happen in fact it's really slow because
I have multiple things on this computer
and this particular virtual box is only
using a quarter of my processor it's
only dedicated to this and you can see
here there it is name and age and it
also included the top row since we did
delete that out of there or tell it not
to and that's fine for this example you
need to be aware of those things when
you're processing a significantly large
amount of data or any data and we can
also do office and we'll call this DSC
for descending so maybe the boss comes
to you and says hey can we order office
by ID descending and of course your boss
you've taught them how to your
shareholder it sounds a little
regulatory I say boss you've talked to
the shareholder and you said and you've
taught him a little bit of Pig Latin and
they know that they can now create
office description and we can order
office by ID description and of course
once we do that we have to dump office
underscore description so that it'll
actually execute and there goes into our
map reduce it'll take just a moment for
it to come up because again I'm running
on all the quarter of my processor and
you can see we now have our IDs in
descending order returned let's also
look at and this is so important with
anytime you're dealing with big data
let's create office with a limit and you
can of course do any of this instead of
with office we could do this with office
descending so you get just the top two
IDs on there we're going to limit this
to two and of course to execute that we
have to dump office underscore limit and
you can just think of dumping your
garbage into the pigpen for the pig to
eat there we go dump office limit two
and that's going to just limit our
office to the top two 2 and for our
output we get our first row which had
our ID name profession and age and our
second row which is Jack who's an
engineer let's do a filter we'll call it
office underscore filter you guessed it
equals filter office by profession
equals and keep note this is similar to
how python does it with the double equal
signs for equal for doing a true false
statement so if your logic statement
remember to use two equal signs in Pig
and we're going to say it equals doctor
so we want to find out how many doctors
do we have on our list and we'll go
ahead and do our dump we're dumping all
our garbage into the pig pen and we're
letting Pig take over and see what it
can find out and see who's a doctor on
our list and we find uh employee ID
number two Bob is a doctor 30 years old
for this next section we're going to
cover something we see a lot nowadays in
data analysis and that's word counting
tokenization that is one of the next big
steps as we move forward in our data
analysis where we go from say stock
market analysis of highs and lows and
all the numbers to what are people
saying about companies on Twitter what
are they saying on the web pages and on
Facebook something you need to start
counting words and finding out how many
words are totaled I mean in the first
part of the document and so on we're
going to cover a very basic word count
example and in this case I've created a
document called wordrows.txt and you can
see here we have simply learned as a
company supporting online learning
simply learn helps people attain their
certifications simply learn as an online
community I love simply learn I love
programming I love data analysis and I
went and saved this into my documents
folder so we could use it and let me go
ahead and open up a new terminal window
for our word count let me go ahead and
close the old one so we're going to go
in here and instead of doing this as Pig
we're going to do pig minus X local and
what I'm doing is I'm telling the pig to
start the pig shell but we're going to
be looking get files local to our
virtual box or the Centos machine and
let me go ahead and hit enter on there
just maximize this up there we go and it
will load Pig up and it's going to look
just the same as the pig we're doing
which was defaulted to high to our
Hadoop system to our hdfs this is now
defaulted to the local system now we're
going to create lines we're going to
load it straight from the file remember
last time we took the hdfs and loaded it
into there and then loaded it into Pig
since we've gone to local we're just
going to run a local script we have
lines equals load home the actual full
path home Cloudera documents and I
called it wordrose.txt and as line is a
character array so each line and I've
actually you can change this to read
each document I certainly have done a
lot of document analysis and then you go
through and do word counts and different
kind of counts in there so once we go
ahead and create our line instead of
doing the dump we're going to go ahead
and start entering all of our different
setups for each of our steps we want to
through and let's just take a look at
this next one because the load is
straightforward we're loading from this
particular file since we're locals
loading it directly from here instead of
going into the Hadoop file system and it
says as and then each line is read as a
character array now we're going to do
words equal for each of the lines
generate Flat tokenize Line space as
word now there's a lot of ways to do
this this is if you're a programmer
you're just splitting the line up by
spaces there's actual ways to tokenize
it you gotta look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flattened takes the line and just
creates a it flattens each of the words
out so this is we're just going to
generate a bunch of words for each line
and then each each of those words is as
a word a little confusing in there but
if you really think about it we're just
going down each line separating it out
and we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it will automatically tokenize it
by space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
group equals group words by word so
we're going to group all the same words
together and if we're going to group
them then we want to go ahead and count
them and so for count we'll go ahead and
create a word count variable and here's
our four each so for each grouped
grouped is our line where we group all
the words in the line that are similar
we're going to generate a group and then
we're going to count the words for each
grouped so for each line we group the
words together we're going to generate a
group and that's going to count the
words we want to know the word count in
each of those and that comes back in our
word count and finally we want to take
this and we want to go ahead and dump
word count and this is a little bit more
what you see when you start looking at
grunt scripts you'll see right here
these these lines right here we have
each of the steps you take to get there
so we load our file for each of our
lines we're going to generate and
tokenize it into words then we're going
to take the words and we're going to
group them by same words for each
grouped we're going to generate a group
and we're just going to count the words
so we're going to summarize all the
words in here and let's go ahead and do
our dump word count which executes all
this and it goes through our mapreduce
it's actually a local Runner you'll see
down here you start seeing where they
still have mapreduce but as a special
Runner we're mapping it that's a part of
each row being counted and grouped and
then when we do the word count that's
the reducer the reducer creates these
keys and you can see I is used three
times a came up once and came up once is
to continue on down here to attain
online people company analysis simply
learn they took the top rating with four
certification so all these things are
then counted in the how many words are
used and in data analysis this is
probably the very the beginnings of data
analysis where you might look at it and
say oh they mentioned love three times
so whatever's going on in this post it's
about love and uh what do they love and
then you might attach that to the
different objects in here so you can see
that pig latin is fairly easy to use
there's nothing really you know it may
it takes a little bit to learn the
script depending on how good your memory
is as I get older my memory leaks a
little bit more so I don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduce localized run comes out and
like I said it's very easy to use that's
why people like Pig Latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things I like
about Pig Latin is when I'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so I can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe I'll just dump
lines and then it's going to run it's
going to show me all the lines that I'm
working on in the small amount of data
and that way I can test that if I got an
error on there that said oh this isn't
working maybe I'll be like oh my gosh
I'm in mapreduce or I'm in the basic
grunt shell instead of the local path
grunt so maybe it'll generate an error
on there and you can see here it just
shows each of the lines going down Hive
versus pig on one side we'll have our
sharp Stinger on our black and yellow
friend and on the other side our thick
hide on our Pig let's start with an
introduction to hbase back in the days
data used to be less and was mostly
structured you see we have structured
data here we usually had it like in a
database where you had every field was
exactly the correct length so if you had
a name field at exactly 32 characters I
remember the old access database in
Microsoft the files are small if we had
you know hundreds of people in one
database that was considered Big Data
this data could be easily stored
relational database or rdbms and we talk
about relational database you might
think of Oracle you might think of SQL
Microsoft SQL MySQL all of these have
evolved even from back then to do a lot
more today than they did but they still
fall short in a lot of ways and they're
all examples of an rdms or relationship
database then internet evolved and huge
volumes of structured and
semi-structured data got generated and
you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam filter you know
we're talking about all the HTML Pages
XML which is a lot of time is displayed
on our HTML and help desk Pages Json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
Apache hbase Apache hbase was solution
for this let's take a look at the
history the hbase history and we look at
the hbase history we're going to start
back in 2006 November Google released a
paper on big table and then in 2017 just
a few months later hbase prototype was
created as a Hadoop contribution later
on in the Year 2007 in October first
usable hbase along with the Hadoop .15
was released and then in January 2008
hbase became the sub-project of Hadoop
and later on that year in October all
the way into September the next year
hbase was released the 0.81 version the
0.19 version and 0.20 and finally in May
of 2010 hbase became Apache top level
project and so you can see in the course
of about four years hbase started off as
just an idea on paper and has evolved
all the way till 2010 as a solid project
under the Apache and since 2010 it's
continued to evolve and grow as a major
source for storing data in
semi-structured data so what is hbase
hbase is a column oriented database
management system derived from Google's
nosql database bigtable that runs on top
of the Hadoop file system or the hdfs
it's an open source project that is
horizontally scalable and that's very
important to understand that you don't
have to buy a bunch of huge expensive
computers you're expanding it by
continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no SQL
database written in Java which permits
faster querying so Java is the back end
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
Boggle it down like it would in other
database companies using hbase so let's
take a look and see who is using this
nosql database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like Cloudera
hortonworks they are behind Hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course Apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
Capital One as Banks you also see Bank
of America where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it so
their information might be very sparse
they might have one Bank way back when
they collected information as far as the
person's family and what their income
for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as he
started saying where you have data that
is very difficult to store where it's
missing a bunch of data hubspot's using
it Facebook certainly all of your
Facebook Twitter most of your social
medias are using it and then of course
there's JPMorgan Chase and Company
another bank that uses the hbase as
their data warehouse for NOS SQL let's
take a look at an hbase use case so we
can dig a little bit more into it to see
how it functions telecommunication
company that provides mobile voice and
multimedia Services across China the
China mobile and China mobile they
generate billions of call detailed
records or CDR and so these cdrs and all
these records of these calls and how
long they are and different aspects of
the call maybe the tower they're
broadcasted from all of that is being
recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing in real-time analysis of
billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution Apache
hbase hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records HP performs fast
processing of Records using SQL queries
so you can mix your SQL and nosql
queries and usually just say no SQL
queries because of the way the query
Works applications of hbase one of them
would be in the medical industry hbase
is used for storing genome sequences
storing disease history of people of an
area and you can imagine how sparsat is
as far as both of those a genome
sequence might be only have pieces to it
that each person is unique or is unique
to different people and the same thing
with disease you really don't need a
column for every possible disease a
person could get you just want to know
what those diseases those people have
had to deal with in that area e-commerce
hbase is used for storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and Target advertisement for
Better Business insights sports hbase
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so when we look at age base
we all want to know what's the
difference between hbase versus rdbms
that is a relational database management
system hbase versus rdbms so the hbase
does not have a fixed schema a
schema-less defines only column families
and we'll show you what that means later
on an rdbms has a fixed schema which
describes the structure of the tables
and you can think of this as you have a
row and you have columns and each column
is a very specific structure how much
data can go in there and what it does
with the hbase it works well with
structured and semi-structured data with
the rdbms it works only well with
structured data with the age space it
can have denormalized data it can
contain missing or null values with the
rdbms it can store only normalized data
now you can still store a null value in
the rdbms but it still takes up the same
space as if you're storing a regular
value in many cases and it also for the
hbase is built for y tables it can be
scaled horizontally for instance if you
were doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words that you're pulling up
and combinations of words so with an
rdbms it's built for thin tables that
are hard to scale you don't want to
store 1.4 million columns in your SQL
it's going to crash and it's going to be
very hard to do searches with the age
base it only stores that data which is
part of whatever row you're working on
let's look at some of the features of
the hbase it's scalable data can be
scaled across various nodes as it is
stored in the hdfs and I always think
about this it's a linear add-on for each
terabyte of data I'm adding on roughly a
thousand dollars in commodity Computing
with an Enterprise machine we're looking
at about 10 000 at the lower end for
each terabyte of data and that includes
all your backup and redundancy so it's a
big difference it's like a tenth of the
cost to store it across the hbase it has
automatic failure support right ahead
log across clusters which provides
automatic support against failure
consistent read and write hbase provides
consistent read and write of the data
it's a Java API for client access
provides easy to use Java API for
clients block cache and Bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
Bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage hbase column
oriented storage and I told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key this is really one of the
important references is each row has to
have its own key or your row ID and then
you have your column family and in here
you can see we have column family one
column family two column family three
and you have your column qualifiers so
you can have in column family one you
can have three columns in there and
there might not be any data in that so
when you go into column family one and
do a query for every column that
contains a certain thing that row might
not have anything in there and not be
queried where in column family two maybe
you have column one filled out and
column three filled out and so on and so
forth and then each cell is connected to
the row where the data is actually
stored let's take a look at this at what
it looks like when you fill the data in
so in here we have a row key with a row
ID and we have our employee ID one two
three that's pretty straightforward you
probably would even have that on an SQL
server and then you have your column
family this is where it starts really
separating out your column family might
have personal data and under personal
data you would have name City
age you might have a lot more than just
that you might have number of children
you might have degree all those kinds of
different things that go under personal
data and some of them might be missing
you might only have the name and the age
of an employee you might only have the
name the city and how many children and
not the age and so you can see with the
personal data you can now collect a
large variety of data and stored in the
age space very easily and then maybe you
have a family of professional data your
designation your salary all the stuff
that the employee is doing for you in
that company let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase architecture and so you
can see here what looks to be a
complicated chart it's not as
complicated as you think from the Apache
a space we have the Zookeeper which is
used for monitoring what's going on and
you have your age Master this is the
hbase master of science regions and load
balancing and then underneath the region
or the hbase master then under the H
master or H base Master you have your
reader server serves data for read and
write and the read region server which
is all your different computers you have
in your Hadoop cluster you'll have a
region an H log you'll have a store
memory store and then you have your
different files for H file that are
stored on there and those are separated
across the different computers and
that's all part of the hdfs storage
system so we look at the Architectural
Components or regions and we're looking
at we're drilling down a little bit
hbase tables are divided horizontally by
a row so you have a key range into
regions so each of those IDs you might
have IDs one to twenty twenty one to 50
or whatever they are regions are
assigned to the nodes in the cluster
called region servers a region contains
all rows in the table between the region
start key and the End Key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and the git sends it out and it
finds out where that start if it's
between which start keys and in keys and
then it pulls the data from that
different region server and so the
region sign data definition language
operation create delete are handled by
the H master so the H Master is telling
it what are we doing with this data
what's going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for Recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your IDs if you have 500 IDs across
three servers you're not going to put
400 IDs on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves Region 3 and Region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the H master
and you can see here it monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where H
Master alone is not sufficient to manage
everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with h master so you
have an active age Master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the Zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region server so
the region servers send their status to
keeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active h Master
fails it will come to the rescue active
Ace master and region servers connect
with a session to zookeeper so you see
your active h Master selection your
region server session they're all
looking at the Zookeeper keeping that
pulse an active age master and region
server connects with a session to the
Zookeeper and you can see here where we
have ephemeral nodes for active sessions
via heartbeats to indicate that the
region servers are up and running so
let's take a look at hbase read or write
going on there's a special hbase catalog
table called The Meta table which holds
a location of the regions in the cluster
here's what happens the first time a
client reads or writes data to hbase the
client gets the region server the host
the meta table from zookeeper and you
can see right here the client has a
request for your region server and goes
hey zookeeper can you handle this the
Zookeeper takes a look at it and goes ah
metal location is stored in Zookeeper so
it looks at its metadata on there and
then the metadata table location is sent
back to the client the client will query
The Meta server to get the region server
corresponding to the row key if it wants
to access the client caches this
information along with the meta table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're querying so we
get the region server for row key from
The Meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets a row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or get
Row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbase meta table special
hbase catalog table that maintains a
list of all the region servers in the
hbase storage system so you see here we
have the meta table we have a row key
and a value table key region region
server so the meta table is used to find
the region for the given table key and
you can see down here you know our meta
table comes in is going to fire out
where it's going with the region server
and we look closer at the right
mechanism in hbase we have write a head
law or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is right ahead
log is a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for Recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store mem store
is a right cache that stores a new data
that has not yet been written to disk
there is one mem store per column family
per region and once we've done that we
have three ack once the data is placed
in mem store the client then receives
the acknowledgment when the minister
reaches the threshold it dumps or
commits the data into H file and so you
can see right here we've taken our or
has gone into the wall the wall then
Source it into the different memory
stores and then the memory stores it
says Hey we've reached we're ready to
dump that into our H files and then it
moves it into the age files H5 I'll
store the Roses data as stored key value
on disk so here we've done a lot of
theory let's dive in and just take a
look and see what some of these commands
look like and what happens in our age
base when we're manipulating a no SQL
setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by Apache
and you can go to
hbase.apache.org and you'll see that
there's a lot of information you can
actually download the hbase separate
from the Hadoop although most people
just install the Hadoop because it's
bundled with it and if you go in here
you'll find a reference guide and so you
can go through the Apache reference
guide and there's a number of things to
look at but we're going to be going
through Apache H based shell that's what
we're going to be working with and
there's a lot of other interfaces on the
setup and you can look up a lot of the
different commands on here so we go into
the Apache hbase reference guide we can
go down to read hbase shell commands
from a command file you can see here
where it gives you different options of
formats for putting the data in and
listing the data certainly you can also
create files and scripts to do this too
but we're going to look at the basics
we're going to go through this on a
basic hbase shell and one last thing to
look at is of course if you continue
down the setup you can see here where
they have more detail as far as how to
create and how to get to your data on
your hbase now I will be working in a
virtual box and this is by Oracle you
can download the Oracle virtual box you
can put a note in below for the YouTube
as we did have a previous session on
setting up virtual setup to run your
Hadoop system in there I'm using the
Cloudera quick start installed in here
there's Hortons you can also use the
Amazon web service there's a number of
options for trying this out in this case
we have Cloudera on the Oracle virtual
box the virtual box has Linux Centos
installed on it and then the Hadoop it
has all the different Hadoop flavors
including hbase and I bring this up
because my computer is a Windows 10 the
operating system of the virtual box is
Linux and we're looking at the hbase
data warehouse and so we have three very
different entities all running on my
computer and that can be confusing if
it's a first time in and working with
this kind of setup now you'll notice in
our Cloudera setup they actually have
some hbase monitoring so I can go
underneath here and click on each base
and master and it'll tell me what's
going on with my region servers it'll
tell me what's going on with our backup
tables right now I don't have any user
tables because we haven't created any
and this is only a single node and a
single hbase tour so you're not going to
expect anything too extensive in here
since this is for practice and education
and perhaps testing out package you're
working on it's not for really you can
deploy Cloudera of course but when you
talk about a quick start or a single
node setup that's what it's really for
so we can go through all the different
hbase and you'll see all kinds of
different information with zookeeper if
you saw it flash buy down here what
version we're working in some zookeepers
part of the hbase setup where we want to
go is we want to open up a terminal
window and in Cloudera it happens to be
up at the top and when you click on here
you'll see your Cloudera terminal window
open and let me just expand this so we
have a nice full screen and then I'm
also going to zoom in and we have a nice
big picture and you can see what I'm
typing what's going on and to open up
your age base shell simply type hbase
shell to get in and hit enter and you'll
see it takes just a moment to load and
we'll be in our H based shell for doing
hbase commands once we've gotten into
our hbase shell you'll see you'll have
the hbase prompt information ahead of it
we can do something simple like list
this is going to list whatever tables we
have it so happens that there's a base
table that comes with hbase now we can
go ahead and create and I'm going to
type in just create what's nice about
this is it's going to throw me kind of a
it's going to say hey there's no just
straight create but does come up and
tell me all these different formats we
can use for create so we can create our
table and one of our families you can
add splits names versions all kinds of
things you can do with this let's just
start with a very basic one on here and
let's go ahead and create and we'll call
it new table now this is to call it new
TBL for table new table and then we also
want to do let's do knowledge so let's
take a look at this I'm creating a new
table and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter and
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
I go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
TBL and when we describe it it's going
to come up it's going to say hey name I
have knowledge data block encoding none
Bloom filter row or replications Go
version all the different information
you need new minimum version 0 forever
deleted cells false block size in memory
and you can look this stuff up on
apache.org to really track it down one
of the things that's important to note
is versions so you have your different
versions of the data that's stored and
that's always important to understand
that we might talk about that a little
bit later on and then we have to
describe it we can also do a status the
status says I have one active Master
going on that's our H base as a whole we
can do status summary I should do the
same thing as status so we got the same
thing coming up and now that we've
created let's go ahead and put something
in it so we're going to put new TBL and
then we want Row one you know what
before I even do this let's just type in
put and you can see when I type in put
it gives us like a lot of different
options of how it works and different
ways of formatting our data as it goes
in and all of them usually begin with
the new table new TBL then we have in
this case we'll call it Row one and then
we'll have knowledge if you remember we
created knowledge already and we'll do
knowledge Sports and then in knowledge
and sports we're going to set that equal
to Cricut so we're going to put
underneath this our knowledge setup that
we have a thing called Sports in there
and we'll see what this looks like in
just a second let's go ahead and put in
we'll do a couple of these let's see
let's do another Row 1 and this time
instead of sports Let's Do Science you
know this person not only you know we
have Row one which is both knowledgeable
and cricket and also in chemistry so
it's a chemist who plays Cricket in row
one and let's see if we have let's do
another row one just to keep it going
and we'll do science in this case let's
do physics not only in chemistry but
also physicist I have quite a joy in
physics myself so here we go we have Row
one there we go and then let's do row
two let's see what that looks like when
we start putting in row two and in row
two this person is has knowledge in
economics this is a master of business
and how or maybe it's Global economics
maybe it's just for the business and how
it fits in with the country's economics
and we'll call it macroeconomics so I
guess it is for the whole country there
so we have knowledge economics
macroeconomics and then let's just do
one more we'll keep it as row two and
this time our Economist is also a museum
position so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows Row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan uh scan and then let's just do scan
by itself so you can see how that looks
you can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new TBL and
in our scan new TBL we have Row one row
one row two row two and you'll see Row
one has a column called knowledge
science time step value crickets value
physics so it has information as when it
was created when the timestamp is Row
one also has knowledge Sports and a
value of Cricut so we have sports and
Science and this is interesting because
if you remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here I don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new table
when I hit enter in here you're going to
see it comes out true and then we'll go
ahead and disable it let's go ahead and
disable new table make sure I have our
quotes around it and now that we've
disabled it what happens when we do the
scan we do the scan new table and hit
enter you're going to see that we get an
error coming up so once it's disabled
you can't do anything with it until we
re-enable it now before we enable the
table Let's do an alteration on it and
here's our new table and this should
look a little familiar because it's very
similar to create we'll call this test
info we'll hit enter in there it'll take
just a moment for updating and then we
want to go ahead and enable it so let's
go ahead and enable our new table so
it's back up and running and then we
want to describe describe new table and
we come in here you'll now see we have
name knowledge and under there we have
our data encoding and all the
information under knowledge and then we
also have down below test info so now we
have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops I already
did that I guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
where it brings up the information like
this what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do R1 and when we do
hbase R1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a timestamp value
physics and we have knowledge Sports and
it has a time stamp on it and value
Cricut and then let's see what happens
when we put into our new table and in
here we want Row one and if you can
guess from earlier because we did
something similar we're going to do
knowledge economics and then it's going
to be as sort of I think it was what
macroeconomics is now market economics
and we'll go back and do our git command
and now see what it looks like and we
can see here where we have knowledge
economics it has a timestamp value
market economics physics and cricket and
this is because we have economics
science and sports those are the three
different columns that we have and then
each one has different information in it
and so if you've managed to go through
all these commands and look at Basics on
here you'll now have the ability to
create a very basic hbase setup no SQL
setup based on your columns and your
rows and just for fun we'll go back to
the Cloudera where they have the website
up for the hbase master status and I'll
go ahead and refresh it and then we can
go down here and you'll see user tables
table set one and we can click on
details and here's what we just did it
goes through so if you're the admin
looking at this you can go oh someone
just created new TBL and this is is what
they have underneath of it in their new
table in there here we will learn on
Apache spark history of spark what is
spark Hadoop which is a framework again
West spark components of Apache spark
that is spark core spark SQL spark
streaming spark ml lib and Graphics then
we will learn on spark architecture
applications of spark spark use cases so
let's begin with understanding about
history of Apache spark it all started
in 2009 as a project at UC Berkeley amp
Labs by matissah area in 2010 it was
open source under a BST license in 2013
spark became an Apache top level project
and in 2014 used by data bricks to sort
large-scale data sets and it set in New
World Record so that's how Apache spark
started and today it is one of the most
in demand processing framework or I
would say in memory Computing framework
which is used across the Big Data
industry so what is Apache spark let's
learn about this Apache spark is a open
source in memory Computing framework or
you could say data processing engine
which is used to process data in batch
and also in real time across various
cluster computers and it has a very
simple programming language behind the
scenes that is Scala which is used
although if users would want to work on
spark they can work with python they can
work with Scala they can work with Java
and so on even R for that matter so it
supports all these programming languages
and that's one of the reasons that it is
called polyglot wherein you have good
set of libraries and support from all
the programming languages and developers
and data scientists incorporate spark
into their applications or build Spark
based applications to process analyze
query and transform data at a very large
scale so these are key features of
Apache spark now if you compare Hadoop
West spark we know that Hadoop is a
framework and it basically has mapreduce
which comes with Hadoop for processing
data however processing data using
mapreduce in Hadoop is quite slow
because it is a batch oriented operation
and it is time consuming if you if you
talk about spark spark can process the
same data 100 times faster than
mapreduce as it is a in-memory Computing
framework well there can always be
conflicting ideas saying what if my
spark application is not really
efficiently coded and my mapreduce
application has been very efficiently
coded well then it's a different case
however normally if you talk about code
which is efficiently written format
reduce or for spark based processing
spark will win the battle by doing
almost 100 times faster than mapreduce
so as I mentioned Hadoop performs batch
processing and that is one of the
paradigms of mapreduce programming model
which involves mapping and reducing and
that's quite rigid so it performs batch
processing the intermittent data is
written to sdfs and written right back
from sdfs and that makes hadoops
mapreduce processing slower in case of
spark it can perform both batch and
real-time processing however a lot of
use cases are based on real-time
processing take an example of Macy's
take an example of retail giant such as
Walmart and there are many use cases who
would prefer to do real time processing
or I would say near real-time processing
so when we say real time or near real
time it is about processing the data as
it comes in or you are talking about
streaming kind of data now Hadoop or
hadoop's map reduce obviously was
started to be written in Java now you
could also write it in Scala or in
Python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in Java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
Driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in Scala and Scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and object
oriented language and in case of Scala
whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now Hadoop supports
Kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms Kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of capitals so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data sets
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we learn more about rdds later
so spark contains rdds which saves huge
time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
Hadoop when we say in memory Computing
here I would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in-memory Computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit it
further queries however when we say in
memory Computing we are talking about
lazy evaluation we are talking about
data being loaded into memory only and
only when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in Ram so here
we can say Ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that Ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as I already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in Java Scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded and the data
will be loaded into rdds only when
execution is happening so these can be
fault tolerant as these rdds are
distributed across multiple nodes so
failure of one worker node in the
cluster will really not affect the rdds
because that portion can be recomputed
so it ensures loss of data it ensures
that there is no data loss and it is
absolutely fault tolerant it is for
better analytics so sparked has Rich set
of SQL queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various spark components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which I'm talking
about Spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
SQL so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structurized would want to prefer
using spark SQL and Spark SQL internally
has components or features like data
frames and data sets which can be used
to process your structured data in a
much much faster way you have spark
streaming now that's again an important
component of spark which allows you to
create your spark streaming applications
which not only works on data which is
being streamed in or data which is
constantly getting generated but you
would also or you could also transform
the data you could analyze or process
the data as it comes in in smaller
chunks you have Sparks mlib now this is
basically a set of libraries which
allows developers so data scientists to
build their machine learning algorithms
so that they can do Predictive Analytics
or prescriptive descriptive preemptive
analytics or they could build their
recommendation systems or bigger smarter
machine learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have Graphics so
think about organizations like LinkedIn
or say Twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when I talk
about graphs I'm not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but I'm talking
about Network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about Facebook think about LinkedIn
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called Graphics which I allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
Apache spark spark core spark SQL spark
streaming spark ml lib and Graphics so
to learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with is spark core which has rdds
as the building blocks of your spark so
it is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling Distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage systems so here I would like to
make a key point that Spar by itself
does not have its own storage it relies
on storage now that storage could be
your sdfs that is hadoops distributed
file system it could be a database like
nosql database such as hbase or it could
be any other database say rdbms from
where you could connect your spark and
then fetch the data extract the data
process it analyze it so let's learn a
little bit about your rdds resilient
distributed data sets now spark core
which is the base engine or the core
engine is embedded with the building
blocks of spark which is nothing but
your resilient distributed data set so
as the name says it is resilient so it
is existing for a shorter period of time
distributed so it is distributed across
nodes and it is a data set where the
data will be loaded or where the data
will be existing for processing so it is
immutable fault tolerant distributed
collection of objects so that's what
your rdd is and there are mainly two
operations which can be performed on and
rdd now to take an example of this say I
want to process a particular file now
here I could write a simple code in
Scala and that would basically mean
something like this so if I say well
which is to declare the variable I would
say well X and then I could use what we
call as spark context which is basically
the most important entry point of your
application so then I could use a method
of spark context for example that is
text file and then I could point it to a
particular file so this is just a method
of your spark context and Spark context
is the entry point of your application
now here I could just give a path in
this method so what does this step do it
does not do any evaluation so when I say
Val X I'm creating a immutable variable
and to that variable I'm assigning a
file now what this step does is is it
actually creates a rdd resilient
distributed data set so we can imagine
this as a simple execution logic a EMT
data set which is created in memory of
your node so if I would say I have
multiple nodes in which my data is split
and stored I'm imagining that your yarn
your spark is working with Hadoop so I
have Hadoop which is using say two nodes
and this is my distributed file system
sdfs which basically means my file is
written to hdfs and it also means that
the file related blocks are stored in
the underlying disk of these machines so
when I say Val x equals SC dot text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
whole text files parallelize and so on
this step will create an rdd so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and I can say first
step in what we call as a dag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later I could do further processing on
this I could say well Y and then I could
do something on X so I could say x dot
map and I would want to apply a function
to every record or every element in this
file and I could give a logic here x dot
map now this second step is again
creating an rdd a resilient distributed
data set you can say second step in my
dag okay and here you have a external
rdd one more rdd created which depends
on the first RTD so my first RTD becomes
the base rdd or parent ID D and the
resultant RTD becomes the child rdd then
we can go further and if we could say
well Z and I would say okay now I would
want to do some filter on y so this
filter which I am doing here and then I
could give a logic might be I'm
searching for a word I am searching for
some pattern so I could say well Z
equals y dot filter which again creates
one more rdd a resilient distributed
data set in memory and a you can say
this is nothing but one more step in the
dag so this is my tag which is a series
of steps which will be executed now here
when does the execution happen when the
data get when will the data get loaded
into these rdds so all of this that is
using a method using a transformation
like map using a transformation like
filter or flat map or anything else
these are your Transformations so the
operations such as map filter join Union
and many others will only create rdds
which basically means it is only
creating execution Logic No data is
evaluated no operation is happening
right now only and only when you invoke
an action that is might be you want to
print some result might be you want to
take some elements and see that might be
you want to do a count so those are
actions which will actually trigger the
execution of this dag right from the
beginning so if I hear say Z dot count
where I would want to just count the
number of words which I am filtering
this is an action which is invoked and
this will trigger the execution of dag
right from the beginning so this is what
happens in a spark now if I do a z dot
count again it will start the whole
execution of dag again right from the
beginning so my Z dot count second time
in action is invoked again the data will
be loaded in the first RTD then you will
have map then you will have filter and
finally you will have result so this is
the core concept of your rdds and this
is how RTD works so mainly in spark
there are two kind of operations one is
your Transformations and one is your
actions Transformations or using a
method of spark context will always and
always create an rdd or you could say a
step in the tag actions are something
which will invoke the execution which
will invoke the execution from the first
rdd till the last rdd where you can get
your result so this is how your rdds
work now when we talk about components
of spark let's learn a little bit about
spark SQL so spark SQL is a component
type processing framework which is used
for structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
particular delimiters and has a pattern
and if one wants to process the
structured data if one wants to use
spark to do in memory processing and
work on this structured data they would
prefer to use spark SQL so you can work
on different data formats say CSV Json
you can even work on smarter formats
like Avro parquet even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark SQL it has a data
source API which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now Spark SQL has something called as
data frame API so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame API allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some Transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frame so when you want to use spark SQL
you would use
Sparks context which is SQL context or
Hive context or spark which allows you
to work with data frames so like in my
earlier example we were saying Val x
equals SC dot text file now in case of
data frames instead of SC you would be
using say spark dot something so spark
context is available for your data
frames API to be used in older versions
like spark 1.6 and so on we were using
Hive context or SQL context so if you
were working with spark 1.6 you would be
saying well x equals SQL context dot
here we would be using spark dot so data
frame API basically allows you to create
data frames out of your structured data
which also lets spark know that data is
already in a particular structure it
follows a format and based on that your
Sparks back in DAC scheduler right so
when I say about dag I talk about your
sequence of steps so spark is already
aware of what are the different steps
involved in your application so your
data frame API basically allows you to
create data frames out of your data and
data frames when I say I am talking
about rows and columns with some
headings and then you have your data
frame DSL language or you can use spark
SQL or Hive query language any of these
options can be used to work with your
data frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like Macy's where they
would want to have machine learning
algorithms now what would these machine
learning algorithms do suppose you have
lot of customers walking in the store
and they are searching for particular
product or particular item so there
could be cameras placed in the store and
this is being already done there are
cameras placed in the store which will
keep monitoring in which corner of the
store there are more customers now once
camera captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will see which product or
which series of product customers might
be interested in and if this algorithm
in real time can process based on the
number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even a
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real-time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history based on customer
Behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be seeing the
essence of real-time processing only in
a fixed or in a particular duration of
time and this also means that you should
have something which can process the
data as it comes in so spark streaming
is a lightweight API that allows
developers to perform batch processing
and also real-time streaming and
processing of data so it provides secure
reliable fast processing of live data
streams so what happens here in spark
streaming in brief so you have a input
data stream now that data stream could
be a file which is constantly getting
appended it could be some kind of
metrics it could be some kind of events
based on the clicks which customers are
doing or based on the products which
they are choosing in a store this input
data stream is then pushed in through a
spark streaming application now spark
streaming application will broke break
this content into smaller streams what
we call as discreticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh options like when I say windows
I mean a window of past three events
window of past three events each event
being of 5 Seconds so your batches of
smaller data is processed by Spark
engine and this process data can then be
stored or can be used for further
processing so that's what spark
streaming does when you talk about mlib
it's a low level machine learning
library that is simple to use scalable
and compatible with various programming
languages now Hadoop also has some
libraries like you have Apache mahaut
which can be used for machine learning
algorithms however in terms of spark we
are talking about machine learning
algorithms which can be built using
mlibs libraries and then spark can be
used for processing so mlib eases the
deployment and development of scalable
machine learning algorithms I mean think
about your clustering techniques so
think about your classification where
you would want to classify the data
where you would want to do supervised or
unsupervised learning think about
collaborative filtering and many other
data science related techniques or
techniques which are required to build
your recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
Sparks ml lip Graphics is Spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
Facebook think about LinkedIn where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data has some kind of network
connections or you could say it is well
networked I could say x is connected to
y y is connected to z z is connected to
a so x y z a all of these are in terms
of graph terminologies we call as
vertices or vertex which are basically
being connected and the connection
between these are called edges so I
could say a is friend to B so A and B
are vertices and friend a relation
between them is The Edge now if I have
my data which can be represented in the
form of graphs if I would want to do a
processing in such way this could be not
only for social media it could be for
your network devices it could be a cloud
platform it could be about different
applications which are connected in a
particular environment so if you have
data which can be represented in the
form of graph then Graphics can be used
to do ETL that is is extraction
transformation load to do your data
analysis and also do interactive graph
computation so Graphics is quite
powerful now when you talk about spark
your spark can work with your different
clustering Technologies so it can work
with Apache mesos that's how Spar came
in where it was initially to prove The
credibility of Apache mesos spark can
work with yarn which is usually you will
see in different working environments
spark can also work as Standalone that
means without Hadoop spark can have its
own setup with master and workout
processes so usually or you can say
technically spark uses a Master Slave
architecture now that consists of a
driver program that can run on a master
node it can also run on a client node it
depends on how you have configured or
what your application is and then you
have multiple executors which can run on
worker nodes so your master node has a
driver program and this driver program
internally has the spark context so your
spark Every Spark application will have
a driver program and that's driver
program has a inbuilt or internally used
spark context which is basically your
entry point of application for any spark
functionality so your driver or your
driver program interacts with your
cluster manager now when I say interacts
with cluster manager so you have your
spark context which is the entry point
that takes your application request to
the cluster manager now as I said your
cluster manager could be say Apache
mesos it could be yarn it could be spark
Standalone Master itself so your cluster
manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager so your spark
application internally runs as series or
set of tasks and processes your driver
program wherever that is run will have a
spark context and Spark context will
take care of your application execution
how does that do it spark context will
talk to Cluster manager so your cluster
manager could be on and in terms of when
I say cluster manager for yarn would be
resource manager so at high level we can
say a job is split into multiple tasks
and those tasks will be distributed over
the slave nodes or worker nodes so
whenever you do some kind of
transformation or you use a method of
spark context and rdd is created and
this rdd is distributed across multiple
nodes as I explained earlier worker
nodes are the slaves that run different
tasks so this is how a spark
architecture looks like now we can learn
more about spark architecture and its
interaction with yarn so usually what
happens when your spark context
interacts with the cluster manager so in
terms of yarn I could say resource
manager now we already know about yarn
so you would have say node managers
running on multiple machines and each
machine has some RAM and CPU cores
allocated for your node manager on the
same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the Hadoop related data so whenever
the application wants to process the
data your application via spark contacts
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does resource
manager do resource manager makes a
request so resource manager makes
request to the node manager of the
machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can I have a container of 1GB
RAM and one CPU core can I have a
container of 1GB RAM and one CPU core
and your no manager based on the kind of
processing it is doing will approve or
deny it so node manager would say fine I
can give you the container and once this
container is allocated or approved by
node manager resource manager will
basically start an extra piece of code
called App Master so App Master is
responsible for execution of your
applications whether those are spark
applications or mapreduce so your
application Master which is a piece of
code will run in one of the containers
that is it will use the RAM and CPU core
and then it will use the other
containers which were allocated by node
manager to run the tasks so it is within
this container which can take care of
execution so what is a container a
combination of RAM and CPU core so it is
within this container we will have a
executed process which would run and
this executed process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about this
spark cluster managers as I said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without Hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark Standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application we'll try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark Standalone cluster which basically
means you could have multiple nodes on
one of the nodes you would have the
master process running and on the other
nodes you would have the spark worker
processes running so here we would not
have any distributed file system because
spark is Standalone and it will rely on
an external storage to get the data or
probably the file system of the nodes
where the data is stored and processing
will happen across the nodes where your
worker processes are running you could
have spark working with Apache missiles
now as I said Apache my source is a open
source project to manage your computer
class clusters and can also run Hadoop
applications Apache mesos was introduced
earlier and Spark came in and as
existence to prove The credibility of
Apache mesos you can have spark working
with hadoop's yarn this is something
which widely you will see in different
working environments so yarn which takes
care of your processing and can take
care of different processing Frameworks
also supports spark you could have
kubernetes now that is something which
is making a lot of news in today's world
it is a open source system for
automating deployment scaling and
management of containerized applications
so where you could have multiple Docker
based images which can be connecting to
each other so spark also works with
kubernetes now let's look at some
applications of spark so JPMorgan Chase
and company uses Spark to detect
fraudulent transactions analyze the
business spends of an individual to
suggest offers and identify patterns to
decide how much to invest and where to
invest so this this is one of the
examples of banking a lot of banking
environments are using spark due to its
real-time processing capabilities and
in-memory faster processing where they
could be working on fraud detection or
credit analysis or pattern
identification and many other use cases
Alibaba group that uses also spark to
analyze large data sets of data such as
real-time transaction details now that
might be based online or in the stores
looking at the browsing history in the
form of spark jobs and then provides
recommendations to its users so Alibaba
group is using spark in its e-commerce
domain you have IQ via now this is a
leading Healthcare company that uses
Spark to analyze patients data identify
possible health issues and diagnose that
based on their medical history so there
is a lot of work happening in healthcare
industry where real-time processing is
finding a lot of importance and real
time and faster processing is what is
required so healthcare industry and iqvi
is also using spark you have Netflix
which is known and you have Riot games
so entertainment and gaming companies
like Netflix and ride games use Apache
spark to Showcase relevant
advertisements to their users based on
the videos that they have watched shared
or liked so these are few domains which
find use cases of spark that is banking
e-commerce Healthcare entertainment and
then there are many more which are using
spark in their day-to-day activities for
real time in memory faster processing
now let's discuss about the Sparks use
case and let's talk about conviva which
is world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about YouTube
which has data you could always read
about it so YouTube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so that is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this videos are
streamed in or can be watched by users
so video streaming is a challenge and
especially with increasing demand for
high quality streaming experiences
conver collects data about video
streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now how
do they do it Apache spark again using
Apache spark convert delivers a better
quality of service to its customers by
removing the screen buffering and
learning in detail about Network
conditions in real time this information
is then stored in the video player to
manage live video traffic coming in from
4 billion video feeds every month to
ensure maximum retention Now using
Apache spark conver has created an auto
diagnostics alert it automatically
detects anomalies along the video
streaming Pipeline and diagnosis the
root cause of the issue now this really
makes it one of the leading video
streaming companies based on auto
diagnostic alerts it reduces waiting
time before the video starts it avoids
buffering and recovers the video from a
technical error and the whole goal is to
maximize the viewer engagement so this
is Spark's use case where conviva is
using spark in different ways to stay
ahead in video streaming related
deliveries if we have understood and
learned about your spark components your
spark architecture we can also see
running a spark application now a spark
application can run in a standalone mode
that is you could set up your IDE such
as Eclipse with a Scala plugin and then
you could have your coded application
which is written in Eclipse to be run in
local mode now here I have an example of
application which can be run in a local
mode or on a cluster so this application
is importing some packages that is spark
context spark conf I have created an
object which is first app it is the main
class of your project and other classes
can just be extending app rather than
having main here we declare a variable
called X which is pointing to a file in
my project directory it looks for a file
which is abc1 dot text and this file
basically has some content what are we
doing in the application so we create a
variable where we assign the file then
we Define our initializers for context
so remember whenever you work with IDE
you don't have spark context or spark
available implicitly that has to be
defined so here we create a
configuration object we set our
application name we set the master as
local if you want to run it in a local
mode if you want to run it say on your
Windows machine or if you would want to
run on a spark Standalone cluster if I
would be running it on yarn then I would
remove this property that is set master
now once you have defined your
configuration object you can be
basically using spark context you can
use method of it which will result in
RTD that is what is happening in line 13
Val Y and then finally I can create a
variable where I would want to do a flat
map transformation on Y which would
result in an internal rdd followed by a
map transformation which would again
result in an rdd and finally Reduce by
key which is doing an aggregation once
all these steps are done I can site to
display the result on the screen or I
can even use save as text file point it
to a particular location and then have
my application run now this is my
Eclipse refer to other sessions where I
have explained how you can set up Ide on
windows with different environment
variables and then you can run your
applications on a particular cluster if
I would want to run this application on
a cluster then I will have to give a
particular path so here in this case I
can say let's do this and I will say my
file is abc1.txt let's save it and I'll
also say my output will be getting
stored in a default location as I intend
to run it I intend to run this
application on a cluster now in that
case the cluster would usually be set up
on Linux machines would have a Hadoop
cluster where you can run this
application so if I would want to run
this application on a cluster but not
local on the machine I can just delete
this part I can keep my application now
if you see my application already
compiles and does not show any error
message and that is because in my
Project's build path I have added all
the spark related jars all the spark
related jars you can get from your spark
directory or you can be getting in
manually all the dependencies some
people would prefer to use Maven or say
SBT for packaging your application as
jar and that can also be done so here my
code compiles code is fine it is
pointing to a file and then it is also
creating an output which will have word
count now what I can do is since I have
my code already written I know that I
have SBT installed on this machine
because I would want to package this
code AS jar and run it on a cluster so
for that we can look in our Command
Prompt and here I can go into workspace
I I can go into my Scala project and if
you see here we have your build dot SBT
file you have your binaries and you have
your source so you might not have these
spark related directories now these
exist in my case because I have been
using spark and I've done some previous
runs now this is what we have within my
spark apps so to build my package I need
a build dot SBT file we can see what
does that contain so your build.sbt
contains your name version of your
package or Scala version spark version
and then repository with spark will
refer to when it wants to have the
dependencies for all of your components
such as bar core spark SQL ml lab and so
on so this is my build.sbt file which
exists in the project folder and if you
are intending to use SBT to package your
code AS jar and then run it on the
cluster in that case I can even skip
adding spark related charge to the build
path so that is only done to make sure
that your code compiles now once I have
my code written I have SBT installed I
have made the file path changes I can
just go to the command line within my
project folder and I can say SBT package
now this will basically resolve all the
dependencies based on whatever you have
given in the code it will create a jar
file and place it in a particular
location and then we can use the same
jar file to run on a particular cluster
so SVD package is busy in creating the
jar now meanwhile what I can do is I can
open up a lab content and what I can do
is I can just say for example simply
learn and here I already have a lab set
up so you could have your own spark
Standalone cluster where you could also
run the this jar file you could have
spark with Hadoop which is what I have
here and I will use that to submit an
application on the yarn cluster and
let's go to the web console let me copy
my link I'll close this I'll say launch
lab and then I can log in here I can
just do paste my password and I'm logged
in so I can just say spark to Shell now
that's how it has been configured here
to work with your spark version 2. so
this is an interactive way of bringing
you your spark shell and running your
application but what we are interested
in is running the application as HR file
so let's go and see here where we have
our code and let's see if SBT has done
the packaging yes it has done and it has
created a jar file in this location so
what I can do is I need to get this jar
file from this location onto my cluster
so what I can do is
I can come in here I can do a FTP so
this basically allows me to push
whatever jars I have on my web console
so I'll go in here I'll say connect now
I'll search if there is already existing
jar file which might create a conflict
so I have something here so I can for
now just delete it it's done I will say
upload file and I am interested in
getting the jar file so here we can
click on users win 10 I have my
workspace project I can get into Target
Scala 2.11 and take my jar file and say
open so this will upload my jar file on
the web console or The Terminal wherein
I can connect to my cluster now let's go
in here let's quit from spark shell as
we want to run an application on the
cluster how do I do it so I can search
if I I have my jar file existing it's
here so I'll say spark to submit and
then I will point to my jar file and
then I can simply say class and I know
my code has a package and a class name
so this is package and this is my object
or class name so I can say main dot
Scala DOT first app now it will be good
if we check if the file exists which are
code points to so I'll just for now
comment it out I will check in my stfs
LS in my default user directory this is
where it will search for a file and here
we can search if I have a file called
ABC so I don't see anything here so
let's do this what I can do is I can
again go to FTP and basically I can do a
upload file like what we did earlier and
this time I'll pick up this existing
abc1 file which I showed you and upload
it once this is done I can put it on my
cluster by just saying hdfs DFS put
let's take the abc1 file and let's put
it in my directory so this will be my
input so I'm putting in a file there and
now I can do a spark submit to submit
the application on the cluster so if you
see here it has basically started the
application it contacts the resource
manager it gets an application ID and
now it is doing the processing of my
file where I would want to get once this
is done it will be completed and the
temporary directory will be deleted so
this is how I run a spark application on
a cluster now once this is done I can
also go to Sparks history server by
saying this is the path for my spark
history server it shows an app
application which was run today which
was doing a word count you can click on
the application it says it ended with
save as text file you can click on this
and then it shows you the dag
visualization it says we started with
text file we did a flat map we did a map
and then there was some shuffling
because we wanted to do Reduce by key so
as I said every rdd by default has two
partitions and if you want to do some
aggregate or wider Transformations like
Reduce by key sort by key Group by key
count by key and so on in that case
similar key related data has to be
shuffled and brought into one partition
that's where we see shuffling happening
here and it also tells what are the
number of tasks which have run per
partition so here we ran a spark
application by packaging it as jar using
your SBT so SBT created the jar file and
then basically we we brought our jar
file onto the cluster and then submitted
it using spark submit so this is how a
spark application runs on the cluster so
as I said your application has a driver
program now your spark applications run
as independent processes and they can
run on a cluster across the nodes so we
just saw how we can run a spark
application on a cluster now we can
always look at spark applications
progress or after it has completed by
looking into the spark UI your spark
application as I mentioned has a driver
program and when you run your
application on the cluster you can
always specify where would you want your
driver program to run so in our case
when we ran our spark application here
we basically just did a simple spark
submit and we gave our jar and the class
name I could also say master and then I
could specify if I if I would want my
application to run in a local mode or I
could say yarn but that is default or if
it was a spark standard loan cluster
then I could be giving something like
this your host name and then your Port
so you could do all of these options by
specifying minus minus master I could
also specify how many executors I need
how much memory per executor how much
cores per executor I need and I could
also say deploy mode as client which
basically means my driver will run on
this machine however my execution of
application will happen on cluster nodes
I can also say deploy mode as cluster
which basically means my driver will run
on one of the nodes of the cluster you
could submit your application and then
based on whatever arguments you have
given your application will be submitted
on the cluster and it will run so you
can have your application running so as
I said you have an app application which
has a driver and it also has either
spark session or spark context which
takes your application request to the
resource manager now if your application
is completed you can always come back
and look into the spark history server
or spark UI if I choose this as my
application which I have run I can go to
executors and that shows me that there
was one for your driver now that was
running on this particular node which is
my client node then I have my executors
on my other nodes which are nodes of my
cluster which used one core which ran
two tasks for the partitions which they
were working on and there was some
shuffling involved as we were doing a
world count which uses Reduce by key so
when you run your application your yarn
or your cluster manager such as resource
manager negotiates the resources to the
slave processes your worker node
basically will have the resources
available for any kind of execution now
as I said your resource manager will
request for containers your worker nodes
will approve those containers and then
within those containers you will have
the executor which will run which will
take care of the task to process the
data so what is a task it is a unit of
work for the data set which has to be
worked upon so your rdds which get
created have partitions and for every
partition you have a task which is taken
care by the executor so the data is
loaded into the rdd when action is
invoked and then your task is worked
upon by the executor so what does it do
it basically gets the data into the
partition of rdd and then does the
execution as a task on that particular
partition results are then sent back to
the driver and you can also have your
output saved on the disk so this is how
your application education run whenever
you run a particular application you can
always go to your web console and scroll
or look into the logs for more
information so here our application was
run and we can see right from the
beginning here when we talk about spark
submit which is done here it says
running spark version 2.2 it basically
then we'll see that there will be a
driver which will be started you can
further see that it does some memory
calculations it then starts as spark UI
and here we can see that requesting a
new application from cluster with four
node managers verify our application has
not requested more than maximum memory
capability of the cluster so the
container sizing at the cluster level is
3gb per container and your application
should not be requesting for a container
bigger than that it starts a application
Master container with specific amount of
memory and then find really your
execution starts if we scroll down and
look into the logs we will see where my
driver runs it will also see show you
how much memory was utilized and it will
talk about tax scheduler which is taking
care of execution of your tag that is
series of your rdds and finally you will
see the result getting generated or
saved so this is how you run your spark
application this is how you can see your
spark applications in history server or
spark UI and this is how overall Apache
spark Works utilizing your cluster
manager help getting the resources from
the worker processes and then running
the executors within those here we will
learn on what is spark streaming spark
streaming data sources features of spark
streaming working of spark streaming
this criticized streams caching or
persistence as we call checkpointing in
Sparks streaming and we will then have a
demo on spark streaming so let's learn
on what is spark streaming and what it
is capable of so it's an extension of
core spark API that basically enables
scalable High throughput fault tolerant
stream processing of live data streams
now data can be ingested from different
sources like Kafka Flume kinosis or TCP
sockets and then it can be processed
using complex algorithms expressed with
different kind of functions such as map
reduce join in window and when we have
the data processed that data can be
pushed out to your file systems
databases and live dashboards so if we
look on this image we can clearly see
that we would be working on a input data
stream which goes into spark streaming
component of spark which gives us
batches of input data or you could say
say the streaming data is broken down
into smaller patches which would then be
worked upon by spark core engine and you
have finally batches of processed data
now when we talk about spark streaming
and the data sources you could have
streaming data sources coming in from
Kafka or Flume or say Twitter API or
also with different formats such as
parquet you could also have static data
sources coming in from mongodb hbase
MySQL and postgres so when we talk about
spark streaming it receives the input
data streams divides the data into
patches which can then be processed by
Spark engine to generate your final
stream of results again in batches so
your spark streaming actually provides a
high level abstraction called
discreticized stream and we will learn
about that or what we call as D stream
which represents a continuous stream of
data now when we look at your different
data sources from where the data I can
come in spark streaming would take in
this input and then you could have even
your ml lib component which could be
used that is Sparks component to build
machine learning algorithms wherein you
can train your models with live data and
you can even use your trained model you
could be also going for structured
processing or processing the data which
is structurized and that could be done
by using Sparks components that is spark
SQL which has data frames and data sets
so you could process your data with data
frames interactively query with SQL when
spark streaming is working on the data
which is constantly flowing in finally
the data which is processed can be
stored in your distributed file systems
such as stfs or any other nosql or SQL
based database now when we talk about
spark streaming it is good to know some
of the features of spark streaming and
here you have some of the features so it
enables fast recovery from failures
while it is working on streaming data
you have better load balancing and
resource usage and you can also combine
the streaming data with static data sets
and perform interactive queries now your
spark streaming also supports native
integration with Advanced processing
libraries and that is one of the
benefits users can have when they are
using spark streaming let's learn about
working of spark streaming so as I
mentioned earlier at one end you have
your data streams now those data streams
are then caught or perceived by your
receivers which we have to enable in our
application your data streams or
streaming data which is constantly
getting generated and flowing in is
broken down into smaller batches which
will then be processed by spark so you
would have your final processed results
now if we look at the bigger picture
here we will talk about live input data
streams that could be divided into
smaller batches and when we say batches
these are batches of input data as rdds
so spark streaming performs computation
expressed using these streams it
generates rdd Transformations so you
would have your spark add jobs to
execute rdd Transformations which would
give you your final processed result now
there are various examples and we'll
look at examples later so once your
spark streaming works on Breaking the
input into smaller streams it can then
process the data finally giving you
batches of your result and that is again
on the streaming data now what is these
D streams let's understand about
restreams or discretized streams so
that's the basic abstraction provided by
spark streaming now it represents a
continuous stream of data either the
input data stream received from The
Source or the process data stream
generated by transforming the input
stream now here if we look at the
dstream we would say you would have
series of rdds or series of
Transformations applied on the data
which is flowing in for a particular
time frame now here we say data from
time 0 to 1 and that would result in
some of the Transformations which you
would perform on the data when it has
come in between this time zone or time
frame you would have again data from
time one to two and so on so that's how
your spark streaming works so if we look
at your different Transformations now
there could be various Transformations
which could be applied on your data so
this is something like your streaming
data which comes in you would want to
say have a receiver which monitors a
particular socket or a particular port
and looks for data coming in we would
also Define the time interval and for
that time interval the data is taken so
that's a smaller batch or a d stream on
which you could have your processing
done now within your application you
would have series of steps which are
nothing but Transformations which would
be performed on this data within this
time frame giving you a result which
could be stored which could be seen on
your console or which could just be
pushed further for processing and this
keeps happening at regular type
intervals whatever you have specified
till the spark streaming application
continues now when we talk about spark
we already know that there are different
kind of Transformations which can be
applied so you have map transformation
wherein you have map and then you pass
in a function which basically says you
would want to perform a function on
every element so when we say map
function that would return a new D
stream by passing each element of the
source D stream through a function which
is passed similarly it is for flat map
where you would be passing in a function
you would want to perform a flat map
transformation on the data stream or t
stream which comes in so each input item
can be mapped to zero or more output
elements you could be doing a filter
wherein you return a d stream by
selecting only the records of the source
3 stream on which the function returns
true so filtering is used when you want
to run a transformation where you would
want to look at the input data for a
particular time interval as I mentioned
earlier and you would want to filter
that data as per whatever your function
is applied now you could be doing a
union where you could basically be
having a union of multiple D streams so
that this would return a new D stream
that contains Union of elements in the
source tree stream and a other dstream
you could be doing a transform function
that contains the union of elements you
could be doing a count you could be
doing a join so these are some of the
Transformations which can be performed
on your D streams now there is also a
concept of windowing and that is
basically to process the data for a
series of time intervals so when I
mention windowed stream processing I'm
saying spark streaming would allow you
to apply Transformations over a sliding
window of data now this operation is
called as windowed computation let's see
how it looks like so if you have your
original D stream which is being which
is basically your data coming in now
that would be looked upon for specific
time intervals such as time 1 time 2 and
then you could be doing a windowed
computation which could basically mean
that I could have a window which is a
series of these time intervals on which
you would want to perform series of your
rdd Transformations so you have a window
dstream at time one then at time two and
time three so that could be one window
wherein you would want to get an output
so here we see window at time three now
you could also have a another sliding
window which would take your time series
and we have time 3 Time 4 and time Phi
where you could be performing the series
of Transformations so this is usually
helpful where you would not only want to
process the data at particular type
interval but you would want a
Consolidated processing for series of
intervals and that's what we mean by
windowed computation now before we
understand about caching and persistence
we can talk a little bit more on
windowing so if one would want to
understand the window stream processing
or as we say spark streaming's feature
of windowed computations we need to
think it as applying Transformations
over a sliding window of data now as we
see here every time the window slides
over a source D stream the source rdds
that fall within the window are combined
and operated upon to produce the rdds of
windowed stream now in this specific
case we can say the operation is applied
over last three time units of data and
slide Heights by two time units this
shows that any window operation needs to
specify two parameters one is the window
length which is basically the duration
of window so for example we can say 3 as
we see in the figure here and then you
have a sliding interval which is
basically the interval at which window
operation is performed so these two
parameters must be multiples of the
batch interval of source D string so
that's what we do when we talk about
window now there are various other
Transformations which can be applied or
window based operations which can be
done on your D streams here to talk a
little bit more on these streams which
is as I said it's a basic abstraction
provided by spark streaming it
represents a just remember it has a
continuous stream of data now either the
input data stream received from Source
or the process data stream which is
generated by transforming the input
string so a d stream is represented by
you could say a continuous series of
rtds which is Sparks abstraction of a
immutable distributed data set so any
operation applied on a d string it is
basically translating to operations on
the underlying rdds now for example we
can say converting a stream of lines to
word the flat map operation is applied
on each rdd in the lines now D stream to
generate the rdds of your words dstream
so when we talk about your discretized
streams understand that you would have a
series of Transformations which would be
applied for this time interval whatever
has been specified now when you talk
about your streaming or smart streaming
architecture as I mentioned here that is
your receivers now that plays a very
important role here so your input D
streams or data streams are representing
the stream of input data that is
received from your streaming sources now
we could have different kind of data and
we could be doing different kind of
Transformations so your receiver is
basically an object which receives the
data from a source and stores it in
Spark's memory for processing and that's
the main role of your receiver now spark
streaming provides two categories of
building streaming sources so you have
basic sources that is sources directly
available in streaming context which is
a class we learn about it such as your
file systems or socket connections so
those could be your basic sources from
where the data is coming in you could
have advanced sources like your Kafka
Flume kindnesses Etc and they would be
available through extra utility classes
so your receiver is going to be looking
into the data which is constantly
getting generated and then basically
forwarding it for processing by your
spark streaming you know when we talk
about your spark streaming one more
important aspect is basically
understanding the caching and
persistence now as we know from the
spark core engine or as you should know
that rdds are say your logical steps or
rdds are created when you perform some
Transformations and these
Transformations or these computations or
these rdds can be cached so that it can
improve the performance of your
application so the computed rtts or the
rtds which are result of some performing
some Transformations they can be cached
so that they can be reutilized down your
application for your further processing
so when we talk about your caching in
persistence these streams also allows
developers to purchase the stream data
in memory so similar to your concept of
rdds these streams can allow you to
purchase the particular streams data in
memory now that is by doing or using
your persist method on a d stream which
will automatically persist every RTD of
that D string in memory it could be
every rdt or it could be specifically
chosen rdts now this is really useful if
the data in dstream has to be or would
be computed multiple times say in your
application so for example if we say
window based operations like Reduce by
window or Reduce by key and window
wherein you have group of operations
being done or you could have state based
operations like update state by key now
in any of these cases your D streams
generated by say window based operations
are automatically persisted in memory
without the developer calling for the
persist method now for input streams
that receive data over networks such as
Kafka Flume sockets Etc the default
persistence level is set to replicate
the data to two nodes for fault
tolerance now one thing which we should
remember is unlike your rdds the default
persistence level of D streams keeps the
Theta data serialized in memory and that
we can discuss again further about your
serializations or deserialization now
one important aspect which takes care of
your fault recovery is checkpointing
mechanism in spark streaming now when I
say checkpointing a streaming
application as in real scenario we would
want must operate 24 bar 7 and if the
streaming application is constantly
running then there has to be a mechanism
which can make your streaming
application resilient to failures which
can be unrelated to your application
logic so spark streaming needs to do the
checkpointing it needs to checkpoint
enough information to a fault tolerant
underlying storage system such that it
can recover from failures so your
checkpointing is the process to make
streaming applications more fault
tolerant or resilient to your failures
now this is usually used when you would
want to recover from failure of a node
running the driver of streaming
application now we know driver is
existing for every application and it is
basically one which knows the flow of
your application driver also has the
context in case of streaming application
we would have say the spark streaming
context which is the entry point of your
application now when we talk about your
checkpointing to ensure your streaming
application is more fault tolerant you
have two kinds of checkpointing here so
you could have a metadata checkpointing
and you could have data checkpointing
now when we talk about metadata what
does that include so metadata includes
configuration dstream operations or even
incomplete batches so when we talk about
metadata it has configuration so
configuration that was used to create
the streaming application you could have
t stream operations that is set of
dstream operations that Define the
streaming application that is your
series of rtds and then you have
incomplete batches or batches those jobs
are queued but not have completed so
this would have to be checkpointed so
metadata checkpointing is used for
recovering from a node failure running
the streaming application driver now
your metadata which has your
configuration incomplete batches and D
stream operations need to be saved in an
underlying storage system now when you
talk about data checkpointing it is
mainly about saving the generated rtds
to reliable storage that is whatever
rdds are computed so saving the
information which is saving the
computations to a storage like stfs now
that is used in stateful Transformations
combining data across various batches so
when we talk about Transformations
whatever rtds are generated that depend
on rdds of previous batches if we are
talking about stateful and that can
cause the length of dependency chain to
increase or keep increasing with time
now to avoid any kind of increase in the
recovery time intermediate rtds can be
periodically checkpointed and that could
be done to a reliable storage to
basically cut off the growing dependency
changes so if we would want to summarize
we would say metadata checkpointing is
primarily needed for recovery from
driver failures whereas data or RTD
checkpointing is necessary even for
basic functioning if stateful
Transformations are used and we should
remember we are talking about stateful
Transformations here so when we talk
about checkpointing now the question is
when would you enable checkpointing or
what would you do to enable
checkpointing so checkpointing must be
enabled for applications with different
kind of requirements so for example if
you are using stateful Transformations
where one series of rdds depend on the
result of your previous matches so
something like update state by key or
Reduce by key in window now if these
kind of operations are used in your app
application then checkpoint directory
must be provided to allow for periodic
rdd checkpointing when we say about
requirements then recovering from
failures of the driver which is taking
care of your application metadata
checkpoints should be used when we talk
about simple streaming applications
without the stateful Transformations
they could be run without enabling
checkpointing because your one batch of
rdds really does not depend on the
previous set of rdts which were done in
the previous time frame now recovery
from driver failures will also be
partial in that case when you talk about
your stateless so some might be received
and your unprocessed data might be lost
but then that's pretty much acceptable
when you talk over spark streaming
applications so here we look at your
checkpointing so we say start now you
have a checkpointing now whenever your
application is creating a streaming
context it would create it would set a
checkpoint path and then you would
Define your dstream which is nothing but
series of your rdd Transformations your
streaming context starts which is
basically your application entry point
into the cluster for processing and at
any point of time if there is any
failure you could always recover using
the checkpoint which was created in case
of spark streaming one more thing we
need to remember is that your
checkpointing can be enabled by setting
it directly in a fault tolerant reliable
file system such as sdfs wherein the
checkpointing information will be saved
so we will have to add some methods
within your application like streaming
context with a checkpoint and then
pointing into a checkpoint directory and
in that way we can have our stateful
Transformations or metadata information
stored in the underlying storage
whichever we have chosen now that we
have discussed about spark streaming
some basics of spark streaming let's
also understand about shared variables
or what we call as accumulator and
broadcast variables so normally when you
talk about your spark operations such as
your map or reduce these are executed on
one of the node of your cluster and what
happens is when you talk about your
operations they work on separate copies
of all variables used in the function
now in this case variables are copied to
each machine and no updates to the
variables on remote machines are
propagated back to the driver program
now when we talk about read write shared
variables across tasks that would be
inefficient so spark actually provides
two limited types of shared variables
for common usage patterns and those are
your broadcast variables and your
accumulators now when you talk about
your accumulators these are variables
that are only added through an
associative or commutative operation so
spark natively supports accumulators of
numeric types and program programmers
can add support for your new types so
when we talk about accumulators they can
be used to implement counters such as
your map reduce or sums so as a user you
can create named or unnamed accumulators
now as we see in the image here it named
accumulator in this instance counter
will display in web UI for the stage
that modifies that accumulator spark
displays the value for each accumulator
Modified by a task in the tasks table
now tracking accumulators in the UI can
be useful for understanding the progress
of your running stages but we should
remember that as of now this is not
supported in Python might be in future
the support for python will also be
added now when you talk about your
accumulators you can have say a numeric
accumulator created by calling a spark
context and its method such as long
accumulator or you could have double
accumulate Editor to accumulate values
of type long or double respectively so
tasks running on a cluster can then add
to it using the add method now we cannot
I mean in this case the value cannot be
read but driver program can read the
accumulators value using its Value
method we can look at some examples to
understand this later now when you talk
about your broadcast variables that is
one more type of variables which allows
the programmers to keep a read-only
variable cast on each machine rather
than shipping a copy of it with tasks
now what we know is sometimes you might
be doing very costly operations like
joins where you might be working on
multiple rtds they need to be joined and
these rtds could also be pair rdds which
could be key value pairs now whenever
you are performing a join there would be
kind of two level of shuffling one
within a particular rdd so if you are
joining two rdds the first RTD which
might have data in the form of key value
pairs that rdd would have to have some
shuffling where all the similar keys can
be brought into one partition and this
would happen on the second RTD also
which has again key value Pairs and then
if you are doing a join these rtds will
be shipped to the node or basically the
data would be loaded in the memory and
then basically your Transformations will
happen this can be a cost clear Affair
so what can be done is you could create
broadcast variables so for example if we
have two rtds and we want to perform a
join operation and if one rdd is known
to be smaller then we can create a
broadcast variable of the smaller RTD so
that this variable itself can be shipped
to each machine and then this variable
can be used for your join operations
with the other rdd which is existing in
the memory of those nodes so that saves
time and that improves your performance
so smart work basically attempts to
distribute the broadcast variable using
efficient broadcast algorithms to reduce
the communication cost now if for
example you have multiple nodes in a
cluster and if you would want to give
every node a copy of large input data
set in an efficient manner so spark
actions are executed through a set of
stages now we know that and stages are
separated by your Shuffle operations so
whenever we talk about narrow
dependencies such as map flat map filter
you would not have any shuffling
involved but if you go for group by key
Reduce by key and such operations to
bring the similar Keys together there
would be shuffling involved and also
this applies when you are doing some
join operations so in that case
broadcast variables could be a really
plus where one set of data or rdd which
is already computed that could be
broadcasted to other nodes so the data
broadcasted will be cached in serialized
form and deserialized before running
each task this means that explicitly
creating broadcast variables can be
useful when tasks across multiple stages
need the same data or when caching the
data in deserialized form is important
so we can create broadcast variables
using spark context and its method
called broadcast and your broadcast
variable can then be shipped to other
nodes which can be used for your other
operations now when you talk about smart
streaming it is used in various use
cases I mean you could talk about speech
recognition you could talk about
sentiment analysis you could talk about
streaming applications which would be
performing some kind of analytics on the
data which is coming in it is also used
widely in retail chain companies now if
we look at the example here so big
retail chain companies would want to
build real-time data Sports so that they
can keep a track of their inventory and
operations and for this they would need
one streaming data or data which is
constantly getting generated at source
which needs to be processed on and this
information can then be populating your
dashboards to give you a real-time
scenario or real-time information of
what is happening so in case of an
inventory dashboard you could use then
these interactive dashboards uh wherein
you could draw insights about the
business and that's what retail
companies are doing so how many products
are being purchased or products that
have been shipped or how many products
have been delivered to customers and
this kind of information would be good
to capture in real time so when the
streaming data is basically being
processed so at one end you have your
data which is getting generated that
might be based on the sales which are
happening that might be based on the
products which are being shipped or that
might be based on the acknowledgment
that the products have been received now
while this data is getting generated at
various sources it can be subjected to a
spark streaming application which will
look into the streaming data perform
series of Transformations which you
would want to process the data at
regular time intervals and then pushing
it to your dashboards or to your storage
layer wherein it could then be used to
answer such questions so when we talk
about spark streaming it's an ideal
choice to process this kind of data in
real time and there are various use
cases so at one end if you see you have
a input stream which shows the product
status that is how many products were
purchased or shipped or delivered now
this would be then handled by your spark
streaming and also your spark core
engine which would then process the data
to give you an output stream which gives
you a status such as what was the total
count of products which are purchased
products which are and products which
were delivered so this was a quick and
brief introduction to spark streaming
and how it works now we can also see how
spark streaming works or how we create
an application for that what we can do
is we can basically set up our Eclipse
to have your Scala based spark
applications and for that what you could
do is you could have your Eclipse which
can then be having a Scala plugin added
to it now if somebody would want to look
at the Scala plugin then you can always
go to Scala Dot
ide.org and this is the place where you
can scroll towards the bottom you can
click on stable and that basically also
shows you a video how Scala plugin can
be added to your Eclipse it also tells
from where you can get the Scala latest
release and this can be added to your
Eclipse so in my case it has already
been added to the eclipse I'm bringing
it up here and and then you can have
your applications built using your IDE
people would prefer to use IntelliJ and
that's also fine so you could also look
for videos on setting up IntelliJ with
your Scala plugin now there are two ways
one you can build your application run
it on your Windows machine when you
could have some kind of utility like
netcat which can be used to send in some
messages in a streaming fashion you
could have a receiver which looks at a
particular socket at a particular port
and you could build a streaming
application within your IDE run it on
your Windows machine in a local mode
which would then be looking at your
Source where the data is getting
generated that's one option the second
option is you could build your
application package it as jar and then
run it on a cluster now that could be a
spark Standalone cluster or spark with
yarn and then you could be packaging
your application using tools like SBT
and then use spark submit to submit your
application now I'll show you both the
ways in which you can work with
streaming applications so first is get
your eclipse and make sure that Scala
plugin is already added now in my case
on the right top corner I see Scala
symbol that says I can be using Scala
perspective now here I have some
projects so what you can do is you can
create a project by saying new Scala
project you can give it a name so for
example I could say my apps 3 and then
you can say finish so that creates a
project now within your project what you
can do is you can create a package so
for example I could say something like
main dot Scala and then say finish so
that creates your package now also one
thing to remember is it would be good to
change your compiler instead of 2.12 to
2.11 normally for different environments
you might have spark with different
versions and Scala with 2.10 or 2.11 so
it would be good to have the compiler
change to the bundle 2.11 so we can
select this project I can do a right
click I can go to the build path I can
say configure build path and then I can
click on Scala compiler where I will use
project settings and I will choose to
2.11 bundle so that would make sure that
your applications can compile just say
okay it might say the compiler settings
have changed a full rebuild is required
for changes to take effect just hit on
OK so that's the first thing you need to
do the second thing is for your code to
compile it would be good to have your
jars added to your build path now we
could do that or as I said you could be
writing your application which might not
compile within your IDE but you can
package it using SBT and then run it as
jar so what I'm doing here is on my
machine within my C drive I already have
spark distribution which I've downloaded
so basically I have downloaded spark and
then untied it so spark 2.4.3 I have
unzipped or untied it I have kept it in
my C and this basically has my spark now
within which I have my jars and this has
all my spark related jars so technically
speaking I can even use Windows command
line and I can start working on spark in
an interactive way or packaging my
application and running it in a local
mode so you could also do this so
basically you have your spark and then
if you see on my desktop I have a Hadoop
folder within which I have a bin folder
and within which I have a win utils.exe
and this will be basically required when
you want to try out your spark based
applications whether that is streaming
or data frames to be tested on your
Windows machine so you can always search
and download the win utils.exe place it
in a Hadoop folder within the bin folder
on your machine so once you get your win
utils.exe once you have your charts what
you can do is for your project you can
just say right click you can go to the
build path and you can say configure
build path and here you had add external
charge so we can select all of these
jars here which I would want to add to
my build path so that my code can
compile and I can test it on the Windows
machine itself I can say open and then
just basically to apply and okay so that
has created my project with a package my
compiler is changed to 2.11 I have added
the external charge the spark related
jars and that is good enough for my code
now what we need is a streaming
application which we need to build so
let me show you from my existing project
how it looks like so within your Source
the same way I have main package and
here I have a streaming application so
this streaming application is to test or
to work on capturing the data which is
generated at this particular stream on a
particular IP and a particular port and
I would want to do some series of
Transformations on that so this gives me
an example of doing a word count and
then I would want to print the results I
could also be saving the output in a
particular location so for this
application we need basically to import
certain packages that is say spark
streaming spark context and also you
have spark conf so these are the
packages which we need to import now
here I have created an object I've
called this fifth app and I'm saying
extends app and this is because within
my project I already have an application
which has been defined as main so if
your application has been defined as
main one application is already existing
then you can just have your new objects
with extending app so we don't need to
define the main method here now here I
am saying while conf new spark once so I
am creating a configuration object I am
setting my application name and to test
it on Windows we will have to set the
master as local and it is advisable to
give it more than one thread because you
would be creating a receiver within your
application that would utilize one
thread so here I am saying set master
local and then I am saying two threads I
am also creating my spark context which
we need to initialize based on the
configuration object we just created in
the previous step then we need to create
a spark streaming context and this
streaming context depends on spark
context and I've given a time interval
of 10 seconds so this is the time
interval which I am setting for which I
would want to work on the stream of data
which comes in every 10 seconds on a
particular socket now here we are
setting up a receiver so I say stream
rdt which is basically be spark
streaming context and then you use your
socket it text stream now there are
various methods of spark streaming
context for example if I just go here
and if I just do a dot it shows me what
are the different options you have file
stream you have q stream you have socket
stream receiver stream and so on so I am
using socket text stream and I would
want to point it to this machine so I'll
say
127.0.0.1 I will also specify Port 2222
okay and here once I have created my
configuration object my spark context my
spark streaming context with the time
interval and I have set my receiver to
use the socket text stream method on
this particular IP on this particular
Port now then I am specifying what I
would want to do on the data which gets
generated on this machine at this
particular Port so I'm saying well word
counts so I would want to work on the
stream rdd that is the D stream I would
want to do a flat map on it to split the
data based on space I would want to map
every word to word comma 1 and then I
would want to do a Reduce by key now
Reduce by key you can pass in
specifically the function you would want
to do I could do a count of this I could
print the result or I could even save it
with an output using the Java method to
create a random string attached to the
output once you are done with this here
I'm mentioning spark streaming context
start now this will basically trigger my
spark streaming context to start and it
will run till we terminate this
application now here to run this on
Windows machine you can always look into
your run configuration and what I have
done is in my environment I basically
want to use let's say okay now let's
look at the configuration what you need
to set so here I have my streaming
application and let's look at the Run
configuration which basically shows my
application and started and it's running
on the environment so if you see here I
have added Hadoop underscore home
pointing to this Hadoop directory which
has been and when utils X I have also
given spark local IP which is
127.0.0.1 so that is my run
configuration now if you see here my
streaming application has started my
streaming application has not yet
started probably it is running a
different application so we can come
back and check this so we can go to run
as Scala application and let's see what
it does so it tries to connect to
127.0.0.1 so receiver is trying to do
that but it does not find anything on
that particular machine on that
particular Port so my receiver is not
able to find it is not able to establish
a connection now what I can do is I can
go to my command line and here I will go
into downloads so I've already
downloaded the netcat utility for
Windows and here we can basically search
for for something which I have on my
machine within downloads and that is
your netcat utility so what I would do
is I will come back here and I would say
NC DOT exe lvp and then I could say my
port which I have specified in my
streaming application and I can just
start this netcat utility now here it
says listening on 222 it says connection
to
127.0.0.1 and then if I look in the
background my receiver will now be able
to establish a connection establish a
connection with this netcat utility now
whatever I type here will be taken for
processing every 10 seconds and we would
see a word count while my application is
running so let's test this so I'll say
this is a test test is being done and as
soon as I pass in this message we see
that there is a word count happening for
the stream of data which is coming in we
can and say Winters are coming Winters
will be cold and once I given these
messages we will see our streaming
application which will try to work on
the data which is coming in and process
it and show us the result so we can say
this is a test of winters and let's see
if it continues to do the processing and
shows us doubt right so my streaming
application is running fine it is
looking at The Words which we are
passing in and we can say if it is able
to process my data and every 10 seconds
the tech stock socket stream is looking
on this machine at this particular Port
doing a series of Transformations and
these series of Transformations and then
are seen within your console now in my
application if I had used word
counts.save as text file then I could
also have my output getting generated
related at every 10 second interval and
that would get saved here I could also
decide to have my output saved and
stored on a sdfs or any other storage so
this is a simple streaming application
what we saw which is using socket text
stream it is looking at this machine on
a particular Port where we are running a
netcat utility it does series of your
rdd Transformations that is flat map and
then you're reduced by key and finally
we are invoking an action such as print
which basically triggers these rdts
which work on my streaming data so this
is one example now what I could also be
doing is this is particularly my
application now I already have SBT for
windows installed so I can be going into
my project space so I could say
workspace I could go into my apps and
I'm in my project folder so I could say
SBD package gauge and this will
basically then based on my build file
which I already have within my project
folder so if you see here this is my
build file which says name the version
Scala version spark version and the
repository with the spark to manage the
dependencies for all its components like
spark core SQL MLM streaming And Hive so
you need to have this build dot SBT file
within your project folder which can be
used to package your application as jar
now we have done the packaging and it
shows me that it has created a jar of my
applications within this particular
folder now once I have this I can
basically then import this package into
my cluster where I can run it on a
cluster using spark submit now to run
the spark streaming application on a
cluster here I have a two node cluster
which will then have my spark standard
loan cluster you could look at the
previous videos which wherein I explain
how to set up a spark Standalone cluster
now here I can go into the spark
directory and then I could just say s
bin start all dot sh which will start by
spark master and worker node now I do
have Hadoop cluster also set up on this
but right now I am running a spark
Standalone cluster which shows me I have
a master and worker process on this
machine and I have a worker process on
this machine so my spark Standalone
cluster is running we can always bring
up the UI to see how it looks like so
here I can just be giving HTTP slash
slash um1 8080 so that's my spark
Standalone cluster with two worker nodes
right now there is no application
running we can come back here and we can
check if we have my jar file so I've
already placed my jar here now at any
point of time if you have your jar which
has been packaged you can always go and
do a jar minus x v f and you can choose
your jar to see what is within your jar
which I have already done on this
machine so if I look in the main folder
I have Scala and within Scala if you see
these are the different classes what we
have so my code was packaged as a jar it
has a fifth app class which we would
want to run here so what I can do is I
can just be saying spark submit because
now I would want my application to run
on the cluster so I can say class main
dot Scala and then my object name so I
will say fifth app now that's my class
my jar is this one and we will also say
master which is going to be spark which
is running on um1 and it listens on 7077
Port so that would basically start my
streaming application but what we would
also need is like our windows we we
would also need some utility like netcat
so basically what I can do is I can here
use a netcat utility to basically
connect or send in some messages for our
streaming application so let's say let
me search if I have already the netcat
which I might have used here so let's
see so we on your window machine you
will have to install your netcat utility
by saying a aptkit netcat so here I can
say NC minus L and then I can say Port
which is 2222 so we can see if this is
working so this is a test and let's see
if it works so let's start our
application streaming application which
then needs the receiver to establish a
connection with the particular machine
and let's see if that is done so here I
could also be canceling this and give it
a particular Port so I can say
192 168 0.18 now the only problem is
when we packaged our application when we
packaged our application we should be
specifically giving the IP and also
comment out the local so when I package
this to run on the cluster I commented
out this part and I obviously would not
be giving 127 but the IP where my netcat
is running so right now let's test it so
we will say this is a test new test for
our application and I'm sending in some
messages so it is already doing the word
count as we expected it to do and if
while we are doing it if you come back
here so you would see your application
is now running on the cluster so it is
my application it is using for Cores
what is the memory per executor and you
can basically click on your application
now here you can look at the application
detail UI to see what is is being done
so for our application we have a
streaming job running receiver which
says this is my application it says it
is running you can basically click at
this click on this and it says your dag
visualization which will say the
streaming job which is running you can
look at the stages if you would want to
see if there are multiple stages which
we don't have because we are not doing
any wider transformation we can look at
storage if we have used some persisting
or caching we can look at the executors
which are being used and one of the
important things when you talk about
your streaming is the streaming tab
which gets activated now that does not
show up when you run your batch
applications but in your streaming
applications you have the UI shows you
the streaming Tab and that basically
says running batches of 10 seconds for 2
minutes 9 seconds already now we see the
input rate we see the receivers we see
if there is any delay in scheduling what
is the processing time how many batches
it has come completed and it basically
shows me what is the processing time how
many tasks were run and so on so my
application is running fine and unless
and until we go ahead and cancel this my
application will continue to run it will
keep looking for messages which we keep
typing in so for example if I would want
to just copy this and start again where
I would keep passing in this is say test
one test one is this where we test
streaming application right and I can be
seeing that my messages are being
processed I am getting a word count so
we can say winter winter summer Old
Winter and you can always look at if
your streaming application is doing the
word count so this is a simple way where
you can run your streaming application
either on a Windows machine in a local
mode or you could be running on a spark
standalone cluster or you could also
deploy your application to run on a
yarn-based cluster now that we have seen
a streaming application which does a
word count it will be interesting to
also see the window based computation or
windowing operation which is supported
in spark streaming as I explained and
for that we can look at a different
application here which is streaming with
a window option let's look into this
what this application does so here I'm
importing some packages that is
streaming streaming context your spark
and Spark context spark configuration
I'm also using the spark API Java
function I am then using spark streaming
API and I'm also using Storage level
because I also intend to have the
persistence or caching done now here we
create an application say streaming app
extends app we create our configuration
object where we say app name and then we
set master with appropriate number of
threads we create the smart streaming
context as we initialize it and then we
have the spark streaming context which
depends on SC and we have given a time
interval of 10 seconds we then set up a
receiver so we say stream rdd which will
use socket extreme like we did earlier
with which will look for this particular
machine at this port wherein I am also
using Storage level so what I would want
is that the data stream which would get
generated here every 10 seconds should
be cached in memory now we could use
different storage levels that is we
could use memory only disk only memory
and disk you could have memory and disk
with replication Factor so you have
different storage levels now here we are
then doing some series of
Transformations like what we did earlier
but if you see in my previous example we
just had reduced by key and here I am
using a transformation which is reduced
by by key and window now this one
basically takes the function as I said
the windowing takes associative or
commutative functions so instead of
using the shortcut wave we will be
specifying our function so we say it
takes a and b and basically it uses this
function now here we have to give the
interval that is 30 seconds that's my
window time frame and then within that
what will be my each interval which we
would want to look at so these are the
two main aspects One is using your
window based transformation and then
also specifying your time interval for
your windowing which basically means we
would still do a word count but then
here we would basically not only be
doing a word count for every 10 seconds
for the data which is coming in here but
we would also want to have a
Consolidated set of computation done
every 30 seconds so that is looking at
the last three time intervals now if you
also notice I am all also doing a check
pointing here wherein I have not
specified a specific directory but what
I am saying here is I would want to
checkpoint or I would want to basically
save my computations for any kind of
fault recovery now this is a streaming
application with window based
computation we are using Storage level
for persistence we are also doing the
checkpointing which takes care of fault
recovery now to run this application we
have already set our environment
variables and so on so I can basically
start this application by just doing a
run as Scala application now this would
start my streaming application with
window based computations now we can
open up our command line where we would
want to start a netcat utility so I
could go to downloads let me just
minimize this window here and what I can
do is I can then be starting my netcat
utility so I could say NC DOT exe minus
lvp and on a port 222 as soon as I do
this in background my application
receiver will be able to establish
connection to this netcat utility
running on this particular Port now
that's done so we can see if the word
count happens for our 10 second interval
so let's do that so I'll say this is my
first test and if I do this it should
give me the word count for the data
which I have passed in now I can say
this is my second test this is my third
test and if you see here it basically is
doing this now if I say this is my first
test again so since we are doing window
based operation also we will see a
Consolidated set of Transformations
which happen for a window of three
intervals so if you see here now my this
is giving me account but it is not
showing me totally this as four or say
this because it is only looking at a
window of last two or three time
intervals so now it is back because it
is looking at the last one so if I say
this is my test test is done test is
done so if you do this it will show you
the word count which is for whatever you
have passed in like test is done is
twice test is Thrice but then since
windowing based operation is done you
will look at the time interval of the
messages which were passed within that
particular window now we can also since
my application is running and it is on
Windows we can bring up your spark UI so
I can go to http and slash slash I can
be looking at my machine and the port so
for example I could do this this shows
my streaming application which is
running in wherein I can see see the
window based application which is
running but what would be interesting is
to look at the stages if there is any
kind of shuffling which is happening
looking at the storage should show me
the persistence which we are doing now
if you see here it shows me that we have
been persisting in the memory what size
it occupies how many partitions were
cast and this is because of the
persistence or the Storage level what we
have used as memory only now if we
change that to disk we will see our rdds
will be cached on disk and then you can
look at your streaming tab which gives
you more information about your patches
so this is a very simple example
obviously you can change what kind of
RTD computations you would want to do
here whether you want to do a word count
or something else whether you want to
save your processed output now here we
are able to do that you can always do a
Refresh on your project and here what we
see is we see some entries of a folder
getting created right and we can decide
whether we would want our output to be
created we can also see within this what
would be containing and since we have
set checkpointing in the project folder
it would also be checkpointing
temporarily the information for any kind
of failure so this is a classic example
of streaming application using window
based computations persisting your
computations and also doing the
checkpointing simultaneously in this
tutorial here we have some list of
questions and an explanation of those so
that you can be well prepared for your
Hadoop interviews now let's look at some
general Hadoop questions so what are the
different vendor specific distributions
of Hadoop now all of you might be aware
that Hadoop or Apache Hadoop is the core
distribution of Hadoop and then you have
different vendors in the market which
have packaged the Apache Hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor specific distributions we have
Cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hortonworks and now
you might be aware that clouder and
hortonworks have merged so it has become
a bigger entity you have mapper you have
Microsoft Azure IBM's infosphere and
Amazon web services so these are some
popularly known vendor-specific
distributions if you would want to know
more about the Hadoop distributions you
should basically look into Google and
you should check for Hadoop different
distributions Wiki page so if I type
Hadoop different distributions and then
I check for the Wiki page that will take
me to the distributions and Commercial
support page and this basically says
that the sold products that can be
called a release of Apache Hadoop come
from apache.org so that's your open
source community and then you have
various vendor specific distributions
which basically are running in one or
the other way Apache Hadoop but they
have packaged it as a solution like a
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of Hadoop coming
back let's look at our next question so
what are the different Hadoop
configuration files now whether you are
talking about Apache Hadoop Cloudera
hortonworks map r or no matter which
other distribution these config files
are the most important and existing in
every distribution of Hadoop so you have
Hadoop environment.sh wherein you will
have environment variables such as your
Java path what would be your process ID
path where will your log get stored what
kind of metrics will be collected and so
on your core hyphen site file has the
hdfs path now this has many other
properties like enabling trash or
enabling High availability or discussing
or mentioning about your zookeeper but
this is one of the most important file
you have hdfs hyphen site file now this
file will have other information related
to your Hadoop cluster such as your
replication Factor where will name node
store its metadata on disk if a data
node is running where would data node
store its data if a secondary name node
is running where would that store a copy
of name nodes metadata and so on your
mapred hyphen site file is a file which
will have properties related to your map
reduce processing you also have Masters
and slaves now these might be deprecated
in a vendor-specific distribution and in
fact you would have a yarn hyphen site
file which is based on the yarn
processing framework which was
introduced in Hadoop version 2 and this
would have all your resource allocation
and resource manager and node manager
related properties again if you would
want to look at default properties for
any one of these for example let's say
hdfs hyphen site file I could just go to
Google and type in one of the properties
for example I would say DFS dot name
node.name dot directory and as I know
this property belongs to hdfs hyphen
site file and if you search for this it
will take you to the first link which
says stfs default XML you can click on
this and this will show you all the
properties which can be given in your
stfs hyphen site file it also shows you
which version you are looking at and you
can always change the version here so
for example if I would want to look at
2.6.5 I just need to change the version
and that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example I would say FS dot
default fs and that's a property which
is in core hyphen side file and
somewhere here you would see core minus
default dot XML and this will show you
all the properties so similarly you
could search for properties which are
related to yarn hyphen site file or
mapred hyphen site file so I could say
yarn dot resource manager and I could
look at one of these properties which
will directly take me to yarn default
XML and I can see all the properties
which can be given in yarn and similarly
you could say map reduce dot job dot
reduces and I know this property belongs
to mapreduce hyphen site file and this
takes you to the default XML so these
are important config files and no matter
which distribution of Hadoop you are
working on you should be knowing about
these config files whether you work as a
Hadoop admin or you work as a Hadoop
developer knowing these config
properties would be very important and
that would also showcase your internal
knowledge about the configs which drive
your Hadoop cluster let's look at the
next question so what are the three
modes in which Hadoop can run so you can
have Hadoop running in a standalone mode
now that's your default mode it would
basically use a local file system and a
single Java process so when you say
Standalone mode it is as you downloading
Hadoop related package on one single
machine but you would not have any
process running that would just be to
test Hadoop functionalities you could
have a pseudo distributed mode which
basically means it's a single node
Hadoop deployment now Hadoop as a
framework has many many services so it
has a lot of services and those Services
would be running irrespective of your
distribution each service would then
have multiple processes so your pseudo
distributed mode is a mode of cluster
where you would have all the important
processes belonging to one or multiple
Services running on a single node if you
would want to work on a pseudo
distributed mode and using a Cloudera
you can always go to Google and search
for cloudera's quick start VM you can
download it by just saying Cloud era
quick start VM and you can search for
this and that will allow you to download
a quick start VM follow the instructions
and you can have a single node Cloudera
cluster running on your virtual machines
for more information you can refer to
the YouTube tutorial where I have
explained about how to set up a quick
start VM coming back you could have
finally a production setup or a fully
distributed mode which basically means
that your Hadoop framework and its
components would be spread across
multiple machines so you would have
multiple services such as hdfs yarn
Flume scope Kafka hbase Hive Impala and
for these Services there would be one or
multiple processes distributed across
multiple nodes so this is normally what
is used in production environment so you
could say Standalone would be good for
testing pseudo distributed could be good
for testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs
So when you say regular file system you
could be talking about a Linux file
system or you could be talking about a
Windows based operating system so in
regular file system we would have data
maintained in a single system so the
single system is where you have all your
files and directories so it is having
low fault tolerance right so if the
machine crashes your data recovery would
be very difficult unless and until you
have a backup of that data that also
affects your processing so if the
machine crashes or if the machine fails
then your processing would be blocked
now the biggest challenge with regular
file system is the seek time the time
taken to read the data so you might have
one single machine with huge amount of
disks and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least fault tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for Hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in stfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple nodes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication Factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of Auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination for multiple machines
however if you are working with huge
data which is getting stored it will
still be beneficial in comparison to
reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through Auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up now
let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs Fault
tolerant now as I just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is Fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 MB that's
the minimum since Hadoop version 2. so
any file which is up to 128 MB would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 MB then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talk
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is Fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as I mentioned
earlier you would in a Hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs so for
your sdfs service you would have a name
node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across or
getting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about sdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs that data is split
into blocks depending on its size and
the blocks are randomly distributed
across nodes with auto replication
feature these blocks are also Auto
replicated across multiple machines with
the first condition that no two
identical blocks will sit on the same
machine now as soon as the cluster comes
up your data nodes which are part of the
cluster and based on config files would
start sending their heartbeat to the
name node and this would be every three
seconds what does name node do with that
name node will store this information in
its Ram so name node starts building a
metadata in its RAM and that metadata
has information of what are the data
nodes which are available in the
beginning now when a data writing
activity starts and the blocks are
distributed across the nodes data nodes
every 10 seconds will also send a block
report to name node so name node is
again adding up this information in its
Ram or the metadata in Ram which earlier
had only data noded information now name
node will also have information about
what are the files the files are split
in which blocks the blocks are stored on
which machines and what are the file
permissions now while name node is
maintaining this metadata in Ram name
node is also maintaining metadata in
disk that is what we see in the red box
which basically has information of
whatever information was written to HD
F so to summarize your name node has
metadata in Ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is a auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is in sequential activity
now this is what I mentioned about when
you talk about name node which is the
master process hosting metadata in disk
and RAM so when we talk about disk it
basically has a edit log which is your
transaction log and your FS image which
is your file system image right from the
time the cluster was started this
metadata in disk was existing and this
gets appended every time read write or
any other operations happen on stfs
metadata m is dynamically built every
time the cluster comes up which
basically means that if your cluster is
coming up name node in the initial few
seconds or few minutes would be in a
safe mode which basically means it is
busy registering the information from
data nodes so name node is one of the
most critical processes if name node is
down and if all other processes are
running you will not be able to access
the Clusters name nodes metadata in disk
is very important for name node to come
up and maintain the cluster name nodes
metadata in Ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as I
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name nodes Ram is constantly
getting updated and metadata in disk is
also constantly getting updated based on
any kind of write activity happening on
the cluster now data node which is
storing the block will also help in any
kind of read activity whenever a client
requests so whenever a client on an
application or an API would want to read
the data it would first talk to name
node name node would look into its
metadata on
and confirm to the client which machines
could be reached to get
to get that's where your client would
try to read the data from sdfs which is
actually getting the data from data
nodes and that's how your read write
requests are satisfied now what are the
two types of metadata in name node
server holds as I mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log NFS image metadata in
Ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so I will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hot and works however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back let's look at the next
question what is the difference between
Federation and high availability now
these are the features which were
introduced in Hadoop version 2. both of
these features are about horizontal
scalability of name node prior to
version 2 the only possibility was that
you could have one single Master which
basically me means that your cluster
could become unavailable if name node
would crash so Hadoop version 2
introduced two new features Federation
and high availability however High
availability is a popular one so when
you talk about Federation it basically
means any number of name nodes so there
is no limitation to the number of name
nodes your name nodes are in a Federated
cluster which basically means name nodes
still belong to the same cluster but
they are not coordinating with each
other so whenever a write request comes
in one of the name node picks up that
request and it guides that request for
the blocks to be written on data nodes
but for this your name node does not
have to coordinate with other name node
to find out if the block ID which was
being assigned was the same one as
assigned by other name node so all of
them belong to a Federated cluster they
are linked via a cluster ID so whenever
an application or an API is trying to
talk to Cluster it is always going via
an cluster ID and one of the name node
would pick up the read activity or write
activity or processing activity so all
the name nodes are sharing a pool of
metadata in which each name node will
have its own dedicated pool and we can
remember that by a term called namespace
or name service so this also provides
High fault tolerance suppose your one
name node goes down it will not affect
or make your cluster unavailable you
will still have your cluster reachable
because there are other name nodes
running and they are available now when
it comes to heartbeats all your data
nodes are sending their heartbeats to
all the name nodes and all the name
nodes are aware of all the data nodes
when you talk about high availability
this is where you would only have two
name nodes so you would have an active
and you would have a standby now
normally in any environment you would
see a high availability setup with
Suzuki is a centralized coordination
service so when you talk about your
active and stand by name notes election
of a name node to be to be made as
active and taking care of a automatic
failover is done by your Zuki button
High availability can be set up without
zookeeper but that would mean that a
admins intervention would be required to
make a name known as active from standby
or also to take care of failover now at
any point of time in high availability a
active name node would be taking care of
storing the edits about whatever updates
are happening on sdfs and it is also
writing these edits to a shared location
standby name node is the one which is
constantly looking for these latest
updates and applying to its metadata
which is actually a copy of whatever
your active name node has so in this way
your standby name node is always in sync
with the active name node and if for any
reason active name node fails your
standby name node will take over and
become the active remember zookeeper
plays a very important role here it's a
centralized coordination service one
more thing to remember here is that in
your high availability secondary name
node will not be allowed so you would
have a active name node and then you
will have a standby name node which will
be configured on a separate machine and
both of these will be having access to a
shared location now that shared location
could be NFS or it could be a quorum of
General nodes so for more information
refer to the tutorial where I have
explained about sdfs high availability
and Federation now let's look at some
logical question here so if you have a
input file of 350 MB which
is 28 MB how many input splits would be
created by sdfs
what would be the size of each input
split so for this you need to remember
that by default the minimum block size
is 128 MB now that's customizable if
your environment has more number of
larger files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block
if your environment has a lot of files
being written but these files are of
smaller size you could be okay with 128
MB remember in Hadoop every entity that
is your directory on sdfs file on sdfs
and a file having multiple blocks each
of these are considered as objects and
for each object
Loops name nodes Ram 150 bytes is
utilized so if your block size is very
small then you would have more number of
blocks which would directly affect the
name nodes of M if you keep a block size
very high that will reduce the number of
blocks but remember that might affect in
processing because processing also
depends on split
split more number of splits more the
parallel processing so setting of block
size has to be done with consideration
about your parallelism requirement and
your name nodes Ram which is available
now coming to the question if you have a
file of 350 MB that would be split into
three blocks and here two blocks would
have 128 MB data and the third block
although the block size would still be
128 it would have only 94 MB of data so
this would be the split of this
particular file now let's understand
about rack awareness how does rack
awareness work or why do we even have
racks so organizations always would want
to place their nodes or machines in a
systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that Hadoop
follows Auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack aware cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different nodes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different rack on a different node now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can I have my block and its
replicas spread across three racks and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
one copy on a different track now let's
proceed how can you restart name node
and all demons in Hadoop so if you were
working on an Apache Hadoop cluster then
you could be doing a start and stop
using Hadoop demon scripts so there are
these Hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your Hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
Apache Hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which I would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and
so let's look at the start and stop and
and here I have a file let's look at
this one and this gives you highlights
so if you talk about Apache Hadoop this
is how the setup would be done so you
would have it download the Hadoop tar
file you would have to untie it edit the
config files you would have to do
formatting and then start your cluster
and here I have said using scripts so
this is in case of Apache Hadoop you
could be using a start all script that
internally triggers start DFS and start
yarn and these scripts start DFS
internally would run Hadoop them in
multiple times based on your configs to
start your different processes then your
start yarn would run yarn demand script
to start your processing related
processes so this is how it happens in
Apache Hadoop now in case of cloud era
or hortonworks which is basically a
vendor specific distribution you would
have say multiple Services which would
have one or multiple demons running
across the machines let's take an
example here that you would have machine
1 Machine 2 and machine 3 with your
processes spread across however in case
of cloud era and hot remarks these are
cluster Management Solutions so you
would never be involved in running a
script individually to start and stop
your processes in fact in case of
Cloudera you would have a Cloudera SCM
server running on one of the machines
and then Cloudera SCM agents running on
every machine if you talk about
hortonworks you would have ambari server
and ambari agent running so your agents
which are running on every machine are
responsible to monitor the processes
send also their heartbeat to the master
that is your server and your server is
the one or a service which basically
will give instructions to the agents so
in case of vendor specific distribution
your start and stop of processes is
automatically taken care by these
underlying services and these Services
internally are still running these
commands however only in Apache Hadoop
you have to manually follow these to
start and stop coming back we can look
into some command related questions so
which command will help you find the
status of blocks and file system health
so you can always go for a file system
check command now that can show you the
files for a particular sdfs path it can
show you the blocks and it can also give
you information on status such as under
replicated blocks over replicated blocks
misreplicated blocks default replication
and so on so your fsck file system check
utility does not repair if there is any
problem with the blocks but it can give
you information of blocks related to the
files on which machines they have stored
if they are replicated as per the
replication factor or if there is any
problem with any particular replica now
what will happen if you store too many
small files in a cluster and this
relates to the block information which I
gave some time back so remember Hadoop
is coded in Java so here every directory
every file and file Creator block is
considered as an object and for every
object within your Hadoop cluster name
nodes Ram gets utilized so more number
of blocks you have more would be usage
of name nodes RAM and if you're storing
too many small files it would not affect
your disk it would directly affect your
name node slam that's why in production
clusters admin guys or infrastructure
specialist will take care that everyone
who is writing data to hdfs follows a
quota system so that you could be
controlled in the amount of data you
write plus the count of data and
individual writes on hdfs now how do you
copy data from local system onto sdfs so
you can use a put command or a copy from
local and then given your local path
which is your source and then your
destination which is your sdfs path
remember you can always do a copy from
local using a minus F option that's a
flag option and that also helps you in
writing the same file or a new file to
hdfs so with your minus F you have a
chance of overwriting or rewriting the
data which is existing on sdfs so copy
from local or minus put both of them do
the same thing and you can also pass an
argument when you are copying to control
your replication or other aspects of
your file now when do you use DFS admin
refresh nodes or RM admin refresh notes
so as the command says this is basically
to do with refreshing the node
information so your refresh notes is May
mainly used when say a commissioning or
decommissioning of notes is done so when
in node is added into the cluster or
when a node is removed from the cluster
you are actually informing Hadoop master
that this particular node would not be
used for storage and would not be used
for processing now in that case you
would be once you are done with the
process of commissioning or
decommissioning you would be giving
these commands that is refresh nodes and
RM admin refresh nodes so internally
when you talk about commissioning
decommissioning there are include and
exclude files which are updated and
these include and exclude files will
have entry of machines which are being
added to the cluster or machines which
are being removed from the cluster and
while this is being done the cluster is
still running so you do not have to
restart your master process however you
can just use this refresh commands to
take care of your commenting
decommissioning activities now is there
any way to change replication of files
on sdfs after they are already written
and the answer is of course yes so so if
you would want to set a replication
Factor at a cluster level and if you
have admin access then you could edit
your sdfs hyphen site file or you could
say Hadoop hyphen site file and that
would take care of replication Factor
being set at a cluster level however if
you would want to change the replication
after the data has been written you
could always use a set wrap command so
set rep command is basically to change
the replication after the data is
written you could also write the data
with a different replication and for
that you could use a minus D
dfs.replication and give your
replication Factor when you are writing
data to the cluster so in Hadoop you can
let your data be replicated as per the
property set in the config file you
could write the data with a different
replication you could change the
replication after the data is written so
all these options are available now who
takes care of replication consistency in
a Hadoop cluster and what do you mean by
under over replicated blocks now as I
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always and
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same node it would mean
that if your application is 3 we would
need at least three data nodes available
now say for example you had a cluster
with three nodes and replication was set
to three at one point of time one of
your name node crashed and if that
happens your blocks would be under
replicated that means there was an
application Factor set but now your
blocks are not replicated or there are
not enough replicas as per the
replication Factor set this is not a
problem your master process or name node
will wait for some time before it will
start the replication of data again so
if a data road is not responding or if a
disk has crashed and if name node does
not get information of a replica name
node will wait for some time and then it
will start re-replication of those
missing blocks from the available nodes
however while name node is doing it the
blocks are in under replicated situation
now when you talk about over replicated
this is a situation where name node
realizes that there are extra copies of
block now this might be the case that
you had three nodes running with the
replication of three one of the node
went down due to a network failure or
some other issue within few minutes name
node re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks
again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is a over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any node that depends on the load on a
particular node now we discussed about
Hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about mapreduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in mapreduce now we know that when
we talk about mapreduce the data which
has to be processed might be existing on
multiple nodes so when you would have
your mapreduce program running it would
basically read the data from the
underlying disks
this could be a costly operation if
every time the data has to be read from
disk so distributed cash is a mechanism
wherein data set or data which is coming
from the disk can be cached and
available for all worker nodes now how
will this benefit so when a map reduce
is running instead of every time reading
the data from disk it would pick up the
data from distributed cache and this
this will benefit your map reduce
so distributed Cache can be set in your
job conf where you can specify that a
file should be picked up from
distributed cache now let's understand
about these roles so what is a record
reader what is a combiner what is a
partitioner and what kind of roles do
they play in a mapreduce processing
paradigm Paradigm or mapreduce operation
so record reader communicates with the
input split and it basically converts
the data into key value Pairs and these
key value pairs are the ones which will
be worked upon by the mapper your
combiner is an optional face it's like
mini reduce so combiner does not have
its own class it relies on the reducer
class basically your combiner would
receive the data from your map tasks
which would have completed works on it
based on whatever reducer class mentions
and then passes its output to the
reducer phase partitioner is basically a
phase which decides how many reduced
tasks would be used aggregate or
summarize your data so partitioner is a
phase which would decide based on the
number of keys based on the number of
map tasks your partitioner would decide
if one or multiple reduce tasks would be
used to care of process so either it
could be partitioner which decides on
how many reduce tasks would run or it
could be based on the properties which
we have set within the cluster which
will take care of the number of reduced
tasks which would be used always
remember your partitioner decides how
outputs from combiner are sent to
reducer and to how many reducers it
controls the partitioning of keys of
your intermediate map outputs so map
phase whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your partitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduce tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face why is mapreduce slower in
processing so we know mapreduce goes for
parallel processing we know we can have
multiple map tasks running on multiple
nodes at the same time we also know that
multiple reduced tasks could be running
now why does then mapreduce become a
slower approach first of all your map
reduce is a batch oriented operation now
mapreduce is very rigid and it strictly
uses mapping and reducing phases so no
matter what kind of processing you would
want to do you would have to still
provide the mapper function and the
reducer function to work on data not
only this whenever your map phase
completes the output of your map phase
which is an intermittent output would be
written to hdfs and thereafter
underlying discs and this data would
then be shuffled and sorted and picked
up for reducing phase so every time your
data being written to hdfs and retrieved
from sdfs makes mapreduce a slower
approach the question is for a Maple's
job is it possible to change the number
of mappers to be created Now by default
you cannot change the number of map
tasks because number of map tasks
depends on the input splits however
there are different ways in which you
can either set a property to have more
number of map tasks which can be used or
you can customize your code or make it
use a different format which can then
control the number of
by default number of map tasks are equal
to the number of splits of file you are
process
so if you have a 1GB of file that is
split into eight blocks of 128 MB there
would be eight map tasks running on the
cluster these map tasks are basically
running your mapper function if you have
hard-coded properties in your mapred
hyphen site file to specify more number
of map tasks then you could control the
number of map tasks let's also talk
about some data types so when you
prepare for Hadoop when you want to get
into Big Data field you you should start
learning about different data
now there are different data formats
such as Avro parquet you have a sequence
file or binary format and these are
different formats which are used now
when you talk about your data types in
Hadoop these are implementation of your
writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type in
Java you have a equivalent in Hadoop so
end in Java would be in writable in
Hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writeable double
writeable Boolean writable array
writable map writable and object
writable so these are your different
data types that could be used within
your mapreduce program and these are
implementation of writable and writable
comparable interfaces what is
speculative execution now imagine you
have a cluster which has huge number of
nodes and your data is spread across
multiple slave machines or multiple
nodes now at a point of time due to a
disk degrade on network issues or
machine heating up or more load being on
a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another similar task running on
some other node for the same processing
so whichever task finishes first will be
accepted and the other task would be
killed so speculative execution could be
good if you are working in an intensive
workload kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take fear
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or having
knowledge of what are the resources
available so if speculative execution
has a property is turned on then the
task which was running slow a copy of
that task or you can say a shadow task
would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce Concepts so when
you talk about mapper identity mapper is
the default mapper which is chosen when
no mapper is specified in mapreduce
driver class so for every mapreduce
program you would have a map class which
is taking care of your mapping phase
which basically has a mapper function
and which will run one or multiple map
tasks right your programming your
program would also have a reduced class
which would be running a reducer
function which takes care of reduced
tasks running on multiple nodes now if a
mapper is not specified within your
driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduce class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old map reduce API in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple math
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to Second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in the mapreduce
program obviously we need to have the
input location we need to have the
output location so input location is
where the files will be picked up from
and this would preferably on sdfs
directory output location is the path
where your job output would be written
by your mapreduce program you also need
to specify input and output formats if
you don't specify the defaults are
considered then we need to also have the
classes which have your map and reduce
functions and if you intend to run the
code on a cluster you need to package
your class in a jar file export it to
your your cluster and then this jar file
would have your mapper reducer and
Driver classes so these are important
configuration parameters which you need
to consider for a map reduce program now
what is the difference or what do you
mean by map side join and reduce side
join map side join is basically when the
join is performed at the mapping level
or at the mapping phase or is performed
by the mapper so each input data which
is being worked upon has to be divided
into same number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so Maps I join you can understand
it in a simpler way that if you compare
it with rdbms Concepts where you had two
tables which were being joined it will
always be advisable to give your bigger
table as the left side table or the
first table for your join condition and
it would be your smaller table on the
left side and your bigger table on the
right side which basically means the
smaller table could be loaded in memory
and could be used for joining so map
side join is a similar kind of mechanism
where input data is divided into same
number of parties
when you talk about reduced side join
here the join is performed by the
reducer so it is easier to implement
than map side join as all the sorting
and shuffling will send the values or
send all the values having identical
keys to the same reducer so you don't
need to have your data set in a
structured form so look into your map
site join or reduce side join and other
joints just to understand how mapreduce
Works however I would suggest not to
focus more on this because mapreduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of mapreduce based processing has
decreased overall or across the industry
now what is the role of output committer
class in a mapreduce job so output
committer as the name says describes the
commit of task output for a mapreduce
job so we would have this as mentioned
our Apache Hadoop map reduce output
committer you could have a class which
extends output committer class
so mapreduce relies on this map reduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to set up the job initialization
cleaning up the job after the job
completion that means all the resources
which were being used by a particular
job setting up the task temporary output
checking whether a task needs a commit
committing the task output and
discarding that
method so this is a very important class
and can be used within your mapreduce
job what is the process of spilling in
mapreduce what does that mean so
spilling is basically a process of
copying the data from memory buffer to
disk when obviously the buffer usage
reaches a certain threshold so if there
is not enough memory in your buffer in
your memory then the content which is
stored in buffer or memory has to be
flushed out so by default a background
thread starts spelling the content from
memory to disk after 80 percent of
buffer size is filled now when is the
buffer being used so when your mapreduce
processing is happening the data from
data is being read from the disk loaded
into the buffer and then some processing
happens same thing also happens when you
are writing data to the cluster so you
can imagine for a hundred megabytes size
buffer the spilling will start after the
content of buffer reaches 80 megabytes
this is customizable how can you set the
mappers and reducers for a mapreduce job
so these are the properties so number of
mappers and reducers as I mentioned
earlier can be customized so by default
your number of map tasks depends on the
split and number of reduced tasks
depends on the partitioning phase which
decides number of reduced tasks which
would be used depending on the key
however we can set these properties
either in the config files or provide
them on the command line or also make
them part of our code and this can
control the number of map tasks or
reduce tasks which would be run for a
particular job let's look at one more
interesting question what happens when a
node running a map task fails before
sending the output to the reducer so
there was a node which was running a map
task and we know that there could be one
or multiple map tasks running on one or
multiple nodes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if in
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again in on some other note so
in Hadoop version 2 yarn framework has a
temporary demon called application
master
application Master is taking care of
execution of your application and if a
particular task on a particular node
failed due to unavailability of node it
is the role of application Master to
have this task scheduled on some other
node now can we write the output of
mapreduce in different formats of course
we can so Hadoop supports various input
and output formats so you can write the
output of mapreduce in different formats
so you could have the default format
that is text output format wherein
records are written as line of text you
would have sequence file which is
basically to write sequence files or
your binary format files where your
output files need to be fed into another
map reduce jobs
could go for a map file output format to
write output as map files you could go
for a sequence file as a binary output
format so that's again a variant of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a non-human
readable format DB output format now
this is basically used when you want to
write data to say relational databases
or say nosql databases such as hbase so
this format also sends the reduce output
to a SQL table now let's learn a little
bit about yarn yarn which stands for yet
another resource negotiator it's the
processing framework so what benefits
did yarn bring in Hadoop version 2 and
how did it solve the issues of mapreduce
version 1. so map reduce version 1 had
major issues when it comes to
scalability or availability because
sorry in Hadoop version 1 you had only
one master process for processing layer
and that is your job tracker so your job
tracker was listening to all the task
trackers which were running on multiple
machines so your job tracker was
responsible for resource tracking and
job scheduling in yarn you still have a
processing Master but that's called
resource manager instead of job tracker
and now with Hadoop version 2 you could
even have resource manager running in
high availability mode you have node
managers which would be running on
multiple machines and then you have a
temporary demon called application
master so in case of Hadoop version 2
your resource manager or Master is only
handling the client connections and
taking care of tracking the resources
the jobs scheduling or basically taking
care of execution across multiple nodes
is controlled by application Masters
till the application completes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of
containers so container is basically a
combination of RAM and CPU cores yarn
can run different kind of workloads so
it is not just map reduce kind of
workload which can be run on Hadoop
version 2 but you would have graph
processing massive parallel processing
you could have a real-time processing
and huge processing applications could
run on a cluster based on yarn so when
we talk about scalability in case of
your Hadoop version 2 you can have a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100
000 concurrent tasks and this is because
for every application which is launched
you have this temporary demon called
application Masters so if I would have
10 applications running I would have 10
app Masters running taking care of
execution of these applications across
multiple nodes compatibility so Hadoop
version 2 is fully compatible with
whatever was developed as per Hadoop
version 1 and all your processing needs
would be taken care by yarn
so Dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads allocating resources across
multiple machines and using them for
execution all that is taken care by yarn
multi-tenancy which basically means you
could have multiple users or multiple
teams
you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does yarn
allocate resources to an application
with help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an API which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
I mentioned managing the resource and
location in the Clusters when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
scheduler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources The Source manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components so you have a
scheduler which allocates resources to
various running applications so
scheduler is not bothered about tracking
your resources or basically tracking
your applications so we can have
different kind of schedulers such as
feed for which which is first in first
out you could have a fair scheduler or
you could have a capacity scheduler and
these schedulers basically control how
resources are located to multiple
applications when they are running in
parallel so there is a queue mechanism
so scheduler will schedule resources
based on requirements of application but
it is not monitoring or tracking the
status of application
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application Masters so it's application
manager which is basically then
launching a application Master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks so whenever a job
submission happens we already know that
resource manager is aware of the
resources which are available with every
node manager so on every node which has
fixed amount of RAM and CPU cores some
portion of resources that is your RAM
and CPU cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request
holding the sources and these resources
that is a combination of RAM and course
are nothing but containers we can
allocate containers of different sizes
within yarn hyphen site file so your
node manager based on the request from
resource manager guarantees the
container which would be available for
processing that's when your resource
manager starts a temporary demon called
application Master to take care of your
execution so your app Master which was
launched by resource manager or we can
say internally applications manager will
run in one of the containers because
application Master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how yarn is basically taking care of
your allocation your application Master
is managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with scheduler and
if a particular node crashes it is the
responsibility of App Master to go back
to the master which is resource manager
and negotiate for more resources so your
app Master will never ever negotiate
Resources with node manager directly it
will always talk to resource manager and
resource manager is the one which
negotiates the resources container as I
said is a collection of resources like
your RAM CPU Network bandwidth and your
container is located based on the
availability of resources on a
particular node so which of the
following has occupied the place of a
job tracker of mapreduce so it is your
resource manager so resource manager is
the name of the master process in Ado
question now if you would have to write
yarn commands to check the status of an
application so we could just say yarn
application find a status and then the
application ID and you could kill it
also from the command line remember your
yarn has a UI and you can even look at
your applications from the UI you can
even kill your applications from the UI
however knowing the command line
commands would be very useful can we
have more than one resource manager in a
yarn-based cluster yes we can that is
what Hadoop version 2 allows
you can have a high availability yarn
cluster where you have a active and
standby and the coordination is taking
care by your zookeeper at a particular
time there can only be one active
resource manager and if active resource
manager fails your standby resource
manager comes and becomes active however
zookeeper is playing a very important
role remember Zoo Giver is the one which
is coordinating the server State and it
is doing the election of active to
standby failover what are the different
schedulers available in yarn so you have
a fee for scheduler that is first in
first out and this is not a desirable
option because in this case a longer
running application might block all
other small running applications Your
Capacity scheduler is basically a
scheduler where dedicated queues are
created and they have fixed amount of
resources so you can have multiple
applications accessing the cluster at
the same time and they would be using
their own cues and the resources
allocated to them if you talk about Fair
scheduler you don't need to have a fixed
amount of resources you can just have a
percentage and you could decide what
kind of fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 access to the
cluster another team has 80 percent
however if the other team does not come
up or does not use the cluster in a fair
scheduler you can go up to maximum of
100 percent of your cluster to find out
more information about your schedulers
you could either look in Hadoop
definitive guide or what you could do is
you could just go to Google and you
could type for example yarn
scheduler let's search for yarn
scheduler and then you can look in
Hadoop definitive guide and so this is
your Hadoop definitive guide and it
beautifully explains about your
different schedulers how do multiple
applications run and that could be in
your fifo kind of scheduling it could be
in capacity scheduler or it could be in
a fair scheduling so have a look at this
link it's a very good link you can also
search for yarn untangling and this is a
Blog of four or this is a series of four
blocks where it's beautifully explained
about your yarn how it works how the
resource allocation happens what is a
container and what runs within the
container so you can scroll down you can
be reading through this and you can then
also search for part two of it which
talks about allocation and so on so
coming back
we basically have these schedulers what
happens if a resource manager fails
while executing an application in a high
availability cluster so in a high
availability cluster we know that we
would have two resource managers one
being active one being standby and
zookeeper which is keeping a track of
the server States so if a RM fails in
case of high availability the standby
will be elected as active and then
basically your resource manager or the
standby would become the active one and
this one would instruct the application
Master to a bot in the beginning then
your resource manager recovers its
running state so there is something
called as RM State Store where all the
applications which are running their
status is stored so resource manager
recovers a running state by looking at
your state store by taking advantage of
container statuses and then continues to
take care of your process now in a
cluster of 10 data nodes each having 16
GB and 10 cores what would be total
processing capacity of the cluster take
a minute to think 10 data nodes 16 GB
Ram per node 10 cores so if you mention
the answer as 160 GB RAM and 100 cores
then you went wrong now think of a
cluster which has 10 data nodes each
having 16 GB RAM and 10 cores remember
on every node in a Hadoop cluster you
would have one or multiple processes
running those processes would need RAM
the machine itself which has a Linux
file system would have its own processes
so that would also be having some RAM
usage which basically means that if you
talk about 10 data nodes you should
deduct at least 20 to 30 percent towards
the overheads towards the cloud database
Services towards the other processes
which are running and in that case I
could say that you could have 11 or 12
GB available on every machine for
processing and say six or seven cores
one multiply that by 10 and that's your
processing capacity remember the same
thing applies to the disk usage also so
if somebody asks you in a 10 data node
cluster where each machine has 20
terabytes of disks what is my total
storage capacity
is DFS so the answer would not be 200
you have to consider the overheads and
this is basically which gives you your
processing capacity now let's look at
one more question so what happens if
requested memory or CPU cores Beyond or
goes beyond the size of container now as
I said you can have your configurations
which can say that in a particular data
node which has 100 GB Ram I could
allocate say 50 GB for the processing I
out of 100 cores I could say 50 cores
for processing so if you have 100 GB RAM
and 100 cores you could ideally allocate
100 for processing but that's not
ideally possible so if you have 100 GB
Ram you would go for 50 GB and if you
have 100 cores you would go for 50 cores
now within this RAM and CPU course you
have the concept of containers right so
container is a combination of RAM and
CPU cores so you could have a minimum
size container and maximum size
container content now at any point of
time if your application starts
demanding more memory or more CPU cores
and this cannot fit into a container
location your application will fail your
application will fail because you
requested for a memory or a combination
of memory and CPU cores which is more
than the maximum container size so look
into this yarn tangling website which I
mentioned and look for the second blog
in those series which explains about
these allocation now here we will
discuss on hive Peg hbase and these
components of two which are being used
in the industry for various use cases
let's look at some questions here and
let's look how you should prepare for
them so first of all we will learn on
hive which is a data warehousing package
so the question is what are the
different components of a hive
architecture now when we talk about Hive
we already know that Hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structurized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using SQL queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language hi is one of
the data warehouse in package which
resides within a Hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbm mess
usually to store the metadata although
metadata can be stored locally also so
what are the different components of a
hive architecture so it has a user
interface so user interface calls the
execute interface to the driver this
creates a session to the query and then
it sends the query to the compiler to
generate an execution plan for it
usually whenever Hive is set up it would
have its metadata stored in an rdbms now
to establish the connection between
rdbms and Hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between Hive and Hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database stable indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this meta store is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to Hive so your meta store
stores the metadata information and
sends that to the compiler for execution
of a query what does the compiler do it
generates the execution plan it has a
tag now tag stands for direct cyclic
graph so it has a tag of stages where
each stage is either a metadata
operation a map or reduced job or an
operation on sdfs and finally we have
execution engine that acts as a bridge
between Hive and Hadoop to process the
query so execution engine communicates
bi-directionally with metastore to
perform operations like create or drop
tables so these are four important
components of Hive architecture now what
is the difference between external table
and manage stable and Hive so we have
various kinds of table in Hive such as
external table manage table partition
table the major difference between your
managed and external table is in respect
to what happens to the data if the table
is dropped usually whenever we create a
table in Hive it creates a manage table
or we could also call that as an
internal table now this manages the data
and moves it into warehouse directory by
default whether you create a manage
stable or external table usually the
data can reside in hive's default
Warehouse directory or it could be
residing in a location chosen however
when we talk about manage table if one
drops a manage table not only the
metadata information is deleted but the
tables data is also deleted from sdfs if
we talk about external table it is
created with an external keyword
explicitly and if an external table is
dropped nothing happens to the data
which resides in sdfs so that's the main
difference between your managed and
external table what might be the use
case if somebody asks you there might be
a migration kind of activity or you are
interested in creating a lot of tables
using your queries so in that case you
could dump all the data on sdfs and then
you could create a table by pointing to
a particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your manage
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs Also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition And Hive and why is
partitioning required in high life if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to set of data or to a
particular partition in Hive we can have
any number of partition keys so
partitioning provides granularity in
Hive table it reduces the query latency
by scanning only relevant partition data
instead of whole data set we can
partition at various levels now if I
compare rdbms with Hive in case of rdbms
you could have one column which could be
used for partitioning and then then you
could be squaring the specific partition
so in case of rdbms your partition
column is usually a part of the table
definition so for example if I have an
employee table I might have employee ID
employee name employee age and employee
salary as four columns and I would
decide to partition the table based on
salary column now why would I partition
it because I feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so I could split my
data into multiple partition based on a
salary column giving some ranges in Hive
it is a little different in Hive you can
do partitioning and there is a concept
of static and dynamic partitioning but
in Hive the partition column is not part
of table definition so you might have an
employee table with employee ID name a H
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like Chan Feb Etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does Hive
not store metadata information in a CFS
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
Hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of high would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate data
connection now this metadata which is
very important for Hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so Hive stores metadata
information in meta store using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access now if somebody asks what are the
components used in Hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation Optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in Java
or Java programming language and then
basically these user defined functions
are added to the class path now you
would have a logical plan generation
which basically looks at your query and
then generates a logical plan or the
best execution path which would be
required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
Optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components in Hive so somebody
might ask you if you are querying your
data using Hive what are the different
components involved or if you could
explain what are the different
components which work when a query is
submitted so these are the components
now let's look a scenario based question
Suppose there are a lot of small CSV
files which are present in a sdfs
directory and you want to create a
single Hive table from these files so
data in these files have Fields like
registration number name email address
so if this is what needs to be done what
will be your approach to solve it where
will you create a single Hive table for
lots of small files without degrading
the performance of the system so there
can be different approaches now we know
that there are a lot of small CSV files
which are present in a directory so we
know that when we create a table in Hive
we can use a location parameter so I
could say create table give a table name
give the column and the data types I
could specify the delimiters and finally
I could say location and then point it
to a directory on sdfs in this directory
might be the directory which has lot of
CSV files so in this case I will avoid
loading the data in the table because
table being Point table pointing to the
directory will directly pick up the data
from one or multiple files and we also
know that Hive does schema check on read
so it does not do a schema check on
write so in case there were one or two
files which did not follow the schema of
the table it would not prevent data
loading data would anyways be loaded
only when you query the data it might
show you null values if data which was
loaded does not follow the schema of the
table this is one approach what is the
other approach so let's look at that you
can think about sequence file format
which is basically a smart format or
binary format and you can group these
small files together to form a sequence
file now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and Fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
1 is storing the data in test text file
0.3 would be storing the data in
sequence file format so we say create
table give the specifications we say row
format delimited fields are terminated
by comma stored as sequence file then we
can move the data from test table into
test sequence file table so I could just
say in insert overwrite my new table as
select star from other tape remember in
Hive you cannot do insert update delete
however if the table is existing you can
do a insert overwrite from an existing
table into a new table so this could be
one approach where we could have lot of
CSV files or smaller files club together
as one big sequence file and then store
it in the table now if somebody asks you
write a query to insert a new column
that is integer data type into a hive
table and the requirement might be that
you would want to insert this table at a
position before an existing column now
that's possible by doing an alter table
giving your table name and then
specifying change column giving you a
new column with the data type before an
existing column this is a simple way
where you can insert a new column into a
hive table what are the key differences
between Hive and pick now some of you
might have heard high-visit data
warehousing package and pig is more of a
scripting language both of them are used
for data analysis or Trend detection
hypothesis testing data transformation
and many other use cases so if we
compare Hive and pick Hive uses a
declarative language called Hive ql that
is Hive querying language similar to SQL
and it is for reporting or for data
analysis even for data transformation or
for your data extraction big uses a high
level procedural language called Pig
Latin for programming both of them
remember use mapreduce processing
framework so when we run a query in Hive
to process the data or when we create
and submit a pick script both of them
trigger a mapreduce job unless and until
we have set them to Local motor Hive
operates on the server side of the
cluster and basically works on
structured data or the data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even I could say
semi-structured data Hive does not
support Avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
right serializer deserializer so we can
have Hive table related data stored in
Avro format in sequence file format in
parquet format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like Avro or sequence
file or parquet we might have to use
specific serializers deserializers for
Avro this is the package which allows us
to use Avro format Pig supports Avro
format by default Hive was developed by
Facebook and it supports partitioning
and Peg was developed by Yahoo and it
does not support partitioning so these
are high level differences there are
lots and lots of differences there
remember Hive is more of a data
warehousing package and Peg is more of a
scripting language or a strictly
procedural flow following scripting
language which allows us to process the
data now let's get more and let's get
more deeper and learn about Pig which is
as I mentioned a scripting language
which can be used for your data
processing it also uses mapreduce
although we can even have pick run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about big which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is Apache pick different
from mapreduce now we all know that
mapreduce is a programming model it is
it's quite rigid when it comes to
processing the data because you have to
do the mapping and reducing you have to
write huge which code usually mapreduce
is written in Java but now it can also
be written in Python it can be written
in Scala and other programming languages
so if we compare Pig with mapreduce pig
obviously is very concise it has less
lines of code when compared to mapreduce
now we also know that pick script
internally will trigger a mapreduce job
however user need not know about
mapreduce programming model they can
simply write simple scripts in Pig and
that will automatically be converted
into mapreduce however mapreduce has
more lines of code Peak is high level
language which can easily perform join
operations or other data processing
operations map reduce is a low level
language which cannot perform job join
operations easily so we can do join
using mapreduce however it's not really
easy in comparison to Pig now as I said
on execution every Pig operator is
converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every pick script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now map reduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a mapreduce
job or when it is triggered by Pink
script Pig works with all versions of
Hadoop and when we talk about mapreduce
program which is written in one Hadoop
person may not work with other versions
it might work or it might not it depends
on what are the dependencies what is the
compiler you are using what programming
language you have used and what version
of Hadoop you are working on so these
are the main differences between Apache
big and mapreduce what are the different
ways of executing pick script so you
could create a script file store it in
dot big or dot text and then you can
execute it using the big command you
could be bringing up the current shell
that is Pig's shell now that usually
starts with map reduce mode but then we
can also bring it up in a local mode and
we can also run pick embed it as an
embedded script in other programming
language so these are the different ways
of executing your big script now what
are the major components of pig
execution environment this is this is a
very common question interviewers would
always want to know different components
of Hive different components of pick
even different components which are
involved in Hadoop ecosystem so when we
want to learn about major components of
big execution environment here are some
so you have pick scripts now that is
written in pig latin using built-in
operators and user-defined functions and
submitted to the execution environment
that's what happens when you would want
to process the data using pick now there
is a parser which does type checking and
checks the syntax of the script the
output of parser is a tag dial direct a
cyclic graph so look in Wikipedia for
tag so dag is basically a sequence of
steps which run in One Direction then
you have an Optimizer now this Optimizer
performs optimization using merge
transform split Etc it aims to reduce
the amount of data in the pipeline
that's the whole purpose of Optimizer
you have a internal compiler so pick
compiler converts the optimized code
into a mapreduce job and here user need
not know the mapreduce programming model
or how it works or how it is written
they all need to know about running the
pick script which would be internally
converted into a mapreduce job and
finally we have an execution engine so
mapreduce jobs are submitted to the
execution engine to generate the desired
results so these are major components of
pick execution environment now let's
learn about different complex data types
in big big supports various data types
the main ones are Tuple bag and map what
is Tuple or Tuple as you might have
heard a tuple is an ordered set of
fields which can contain different data
types for each field so in Array you
would have multiple elements but that
would be of same types list can also
have different types your Tuple is a
collection which has different fields
and each field can be of different type
now we could have an example as one
comma 3 or 1 comma 3 comma a string or a
float element and all of that form a
tuple bag is a set of tuples so that's
represented by curly braces so you could
also imagine this like a dictionary
which has various different correction
elements what is a map map is a set of
key value pairs used to represent data
so when you work in Big Data field you
need to know about different data types
which are supported by Peg which are
supported by High which are supported in
other components of Hadoop so Tuple bag
map array array buffer you can think
about list you can think about
dictionaries you can think about map
which is key value pair so these are
your different complex data types other
than the primitive data types such as
integer character string Boolean float
and so on now what are the various
diagnostic operators available in Apache
pick so these are some of the operators
or options which you can give in a pick
script you can do a thumb now dump
operator runs the pig latin scripts and
displays the result on the screen so
either I could do a dumb and see the
output on the screen or I can even do a
dump into and I could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator in Pig and then
Pig also has different internal storage
like Json loader or pic storage which
can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or seen on the screen you also
have a describe operator now that is
used to view the schema of a relation so
you can load the data and then you can
view the schema of relation using
describe operator explain as we might
already know displays the physical
logical and mapreduce execution plans so
normally in rdbms when we use X-Plane we
would like to see what happens behind
the scenes when a particular script or a
query runs so we could load the data
using load operator as in any other case
and if we would want to display The
Logical physical and mapreduce execution
plans we could use explain operator
there is also an illustrate operator now
that gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze our script to
see how good or bad they are or would
that really serve our purpose we could
use illustrate and again you can test
that by loading the data using load
operator and you could just use a
illustrate operator to have a look at
the step-by-step execution of the
sequence of statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in Apache
pick now if somebody asks State the
usage of group order by and distinct
keywords in big script so as I said pig
is a scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation Name by H
now say I have a file where I have field
various fields and one of the field is a
relation name so I could group that by a
different field order by is used to
display the contents of relation in a
sorted order whether ascending or
descending so I could create a variable
called relation 2 and then I could say
order relation name 1 by ascending or
descending order distinct basically
removes the duplicate records and it is
implemented only on entire records not
on individual records so if you would
like want to find out the distinct
values and relation name field I could
use distinct what are the relational
operators and pick so you have various
relational operators which help data
scientists or data analysts or
developers who are analyzing the data
such as co-group which joins two or more
tables and then performs group operation
on the join table result you have cross
it is used to compute the cross product
that is a Cartesian product of two or
more relations for each is basically to
do some iteration so if it will iterate
through tuples of a relation generating
a data transformation so for example if
I say variable a equals and then I load
a file in a and then I could create a
variable called B where I could say for
each a I would want to do something say
group join is to join two or more tables
in a relation limit is to limit the
number of output tuples or output
results split is to split the relation
into two or more relations Union is to
get a combination that's it will merge
the contents of two or more relations
and order is to get a sorted result so
these are some relational operators
which are extensively used in pig for
analysis what is the use of having
filters in Apache pick now say for
example I have some data which has three
Fields here product quantity and this is
my phone sales data so filter operator
could be used to select the required
values from a relation based on a
condition it also allows you to remove
unwanted records from data file so for
example filter the products where
quantity is greater than thousand so I
see that I have one row wherein or
multiple rows where the quantity is
greater than thousands such as fifteen
hundred Seventeen hundred twelve hundred
so I could create a variable called a I
would load my file using pick storage as
I explained earlier big storage is an
internal parameter which can be used to
specify the delimiters now here my
delimiter is comma so I could say using
pic storage as and then I could specify
the data type for each field so here
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then B
I could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now Suppose there is a
file called test Dot dxt having 150
records in sdfs so this is a file which
is stored on sdfs and it has 150 records
where we can consider every record being
one line and if somebody asks you to
write a big command to retrieve the
first 10 records of the file first we
will have to load the data so I could
create a variable called test underscore
data and I would say load my file using
big storage specifying the delimit of s
comma as and then I could specify my
Fields whatever Fields our file have and
then I would want to get only 10 records
for which I could use the limit operator
so I could say limit on test data and
give me 10 records this is very simple
and we can extract 10 records from 150
records which are stored in the file on
sdfs now we have learned on Pig we have
learned some questions on hive you could
always look more in books like
programming in Hive or programming in
pick and look for some more examples and
and try out these examples on a existing
Hadoop setup now let's learn on hbase
which is a nosql database now edgebase
is a four dimensional database in
comparison to your rdbms which usually
are two dimensional so rdbms have rows
and columns but hbase has four
coordinates it has row key which is
always unique column family which can be
any number column qualifiers which can
again be any number per column family
and then you have a version so these
four coordinates make H base a four
dimensional key value store or a column
family store which is unique for storing
huge amount of data and extracting data
from hbase there is a very good link
which I would suggest everyone can look
at if you would want to learn more on
edgebase and you could just say hbase
mapper and this basically brings up a
documentation which features from map R
but then that's not specific to map R
and you can look at this link which will
give you a detailed explanation of HP is
how it works what are the Architectural
Components and how data is stored and
how it makes edgebase a very powerful
nosql database so let's learn on some of
the important or critical questions on
hbase which might be asked by the
interviewer in an interview when you are
applying for a big data admin or a
developer position role so what are the
key components of hbase now as I said
this is one of the favorite questions of
interviewers where they would want to
understand your knowledge on different
components for a particular service
edgebase as I said is a nosql database
and that comes as a part of service with
Cloudera or hortonworks and with Apache
Hadoop you could also set up a edge base
as an independent package so what are
the key comp opponents of hbase hbase
has a region server now edgebase follows
the similar kind of topology like Hadoop
now Hadoop has a master process that is
name node and slave processes such as
data nodes and secondary name node in
the same way hbase also has a master
which is H master and the slave
processes are called region servers so
these region servers are usually
co-located with data nodes however it is
not mandatory that if you have 100 data
nodes you would have 100 region servers
so it purely depends on admin so what
does this region server contain so
region server contains HPS tables that
are divided horizontally into regions or
you could say group of rows is called
regions so in edgebase you have two
aspects one is group of columns which is
called column family and one is group of
rows which is called region now these
regions or these rows are grouped based
on the key values or I would say row
Keys which are always unique when you
store your data in edgebase you would
have data in the form of rows and
columns so group of rows are called
regions or you could say these are
horizontal partitions of the table so a
region server manages these regions on
the Node where a data node is running a
region server can have up to thousand
regions it runs on every node and
decides the size of region so region
server as I said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing HPS
data on the Node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of
edgebase as I said you have hbh master
so you would always have a connection
coming in from a client or an
application what does edgemaster do it
assigns regions it monitors the region
servers it assigns regions to region
servers for load balancing and it cannot
do that without the help of Zookeeper so
if we talk about components of hbase
there are three main components you have
zookeeper you have etch master and you
have region server region server being
the slave process your Edge Master being
the master process which takes care of
all your table operations assigning
regions to the region servers taking
care of read and write requests which
come from client and for all of this
Edge Master will take in help of
Zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service so whenever a
client wants to read or write or change
the schema or any other metadata
operations it will contact H Master Edge
Master internally will contact Zuki
keeper so you could have hbase setup
also in high availability mode where you
could have a active Edge Masters and a
backup Edge Master you would have a
zookeeper Quorum which is the way
zookeeper works so zookeeper is a
centralized coordination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as 3 5
and 7 because zookeeper works on the
concept of maturity consensus now
zookeeper which is a centralized
coordination service is keeping a track
of all the servers which are alive
available and also keeps a track of
their status for every server with
zookeeper is monitoring zookeeper keeps
a session alive with that particular
server Edge Master would always check
with zookeeper which region servers are
available alive so that regions can be
assigned to the region server at one end
you have region server which are sending
their status to the Zookeeper indicating
if they are ready for any kind of read
or write operation and at other end Edge
Master is querying the Zookeeper to
check the status now zookeeper
internally manages a meta table now that
meta table will have information of
which regions are residing on which
region server and what rookies those
regions contain so in case of a read
activity
etch Master will query zookeeper to find
out the region server which contains
that meta table once etch Master gets
the information of meta table it can
look into the meta table to find out the
row keys and the corresponding region
servers which contain the regions for
those row Keys now if we would want to
understand row key and column families
in hbase let's look at this and it would
be good if we could look this on an
Excel sheet so row key is always unique
it acts as is a primary key for any
edgebase table it allows a logical
grouping of cells and make sure that all
cells with the same row key are
co-located on the same server so as I
said you have four coordinates for hbase
you have a row key which is always
unique you have column families which is
nothing but group of columns and when I
say column family is one column family
can have any number of columns so when I
talk about H base hbase is four
dimensional and in terms of hbase it is
also called as a column oriented
database which basically means that
every Row in one column could have a
different data type now you have a row
key which uniquely identifies the row
you have column families which could be
one or many depending on how the table
has been defined and a column family can
have any number of columns or I could
say for every row within a column family
you could have different number of
columns so I could say for my Row one I
could just have two columns such as name
and City within the column family for my
Row 2 I could have name City age
designation salary for my third row I
could have thousand columns and all that
could belong to one column family so
this is a horizontally scalable database
so column family consists of group of
columns which is defined during table
creation and each column family can have
any number of column qualifiers
separated by a delimiter now a
combination of row key column family
column qualifier such as name City age
and the value within the cell is makes
the hbase a unique four dimensional
database for more information if you
would want to learn on hbase please
refer this link which is hbase mapper
and this game gives a complete edgebase
architecture that has three components
of name node three components that is
name node region servers and zookeeper
how it works how Edge base Edge Master
interacts with zookeeper what zookeeper
does in coordination how are the
components working together and how does
edgeways take care of read and write
coming back and continuing why do we
need to disable a table so there are
different table operations what you can
do in hbase and one of them is disabling
a table now if you would want to check
the status of table you could check that
by is disabled and giving the table name
or is enabled and the table name so the
question is why do we need to disable a
table now if we would want to modify a
table or we are doing some kind of
Maintenance activity in that case we can
disable the table so that we can modify
or changes settings when a table is
disabled it cannot be accessed through
the scan command now if we have to write
a code to open a connection in hbase now
to interact with edgebase one could
either use a graphical user interface
such as Hue or you could be using the
command line hbase shell or you could be
using hbase admin API if you are working
with Java or say happy base if you are
working with python where you may want
to open a connection with hbase so that
you can work with advice
programmatically in that case we have to
create a configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like Edge table
interface to work on a new table you
could use H column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin API what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edgebase as I
said Works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one HP is
clustered to either Edge base cluster so
this replication feature in hbase
provides a mechanism to copy data
between clusters or sync the data
between different clusters this feature
can be used as a disaster recovery
solution that provides High availability
for edgebase so if I have hbase cluster
1 where I have one master and multiple
region servers running in a Hadoop
cluster I could use the same Hadoop
cluster to create a hbase replica
cluster or I could have a totally
different hbase replica cluster where my
intention is that if things are changing
in a particular table in cluster one I
would want them to be replicated across
different cluster so I could alter the
edge base table and set the replication
scope to 1. now a replication scope of 0
indicates that table is not replicated
but if we set the replication to 1 we
basically will have to set up ahbs
cluster where we can replicate hbase
tables data from cluster 1 to Cluster so
these are the commands which can be used
to enable replication and then replicate
the data of table across clusters can we
Import and Export in hbase of course we
can it is possible to Import and Export
tables from one edgebase cluster to
other hbase cluster or even within a
cluster so we can use the hbase export
utility which comes in this particular
package give a table name and then a
Target location so that will export the
data of hbase table into a directory on
sdfs then I could create a different
table which would follow some kind of
same definition as the table which was
exported and then I could use import to
import the data from the directory on
sdfs to my table if you would want to
learn more on hbase Import and Export
you could look at hbase import
operations let's search for the link and
this is the link where you could learn
more about hbase import export utilities
how you could do a bulk import bulk
export which internally uses mapreduce
and then you could do a Import and
Export into headspace tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
edgebase now we all know that hbase is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first returned to what we call as
right ahead log and also to mem store
which is write cache now once the data
is written involved and your mem store
it is offloaded to form an internal
edgebase format file which is called H5
and usually these edge files are very
small in nature so we also know that
sdfs is good when we talk about few
number of larger files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name nodes memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is the smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of H files
which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big Edge
file which internally would then be
written to sdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called Bloom
filter so how does Bloom filter work so
Bloom filter or hbase Bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell Bloom filter is named after its
creator button covered Bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in memory index
structure that reduces the disk reads
and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of hbase
which allows for faster access and
avoids disk syncs does edgebase have any
concept of namespace so namespaces when
you have similar elements grouped
together so namespace yes hbase supports
a namespace so namespace is a logical
grouping of tables analogous to a
database in rdbms so you can create
hbase namespace to the schema of rdbms
database so you could create a namespace
by saying create namespace and giving it
a name and then you could also list the
tables within a namespace you could
create tables within a specific
namespace now this is usually done in
production environment where a cluster
might be multi-tenant cluster and there
might be different users of of the same
nosql database in that case admin would
create specific namespace and for
specific name space you would have
different directories on hdfs and users
of a particular business unit or a team
can work on their edgebase objects
within a specific name space this is a
question which is again very important
to understand about the rights or reads
so how does right ahead log wall help
when a region server crashes now as I
said when a write happens it will happen
into mem store and wall that is your
edit log or write ahead log so whenever
a write happens it will happen in two
places mem store which is the right
cache and wall which is a edit log only
when the data is written in both these
places and based on the limitation of
mem store the data will be flushed to
create an edgebase format file called H5
these files are then come impacted and
created into one bigger file which will
then be stored on hdfs and sdfs data as
we know is stored in the form of blocks
on the underlying data nodes so if a
region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store Write cash crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does
edgebase recover from this as I said
your data is written into wall and mem
store at the same time HBS recovers
against that by writing to wall before
the write completes so whenever a write
happens it happens in mem store and wall
at the same time HBS cluster keeps a
wall to record changes as they happen
and that's why we call it as also an
edit log if edgebase goes down or the
node that goes down the data that was
not Flash from mem store to Edge file
can be recovered by replaying the right
ahead log and that's the benefit of your
edit log or write ahead log now if we
would have to write hbase command to
list the contents and update the column
families of a table I could just do a
scan and that would give me complete
data of a table if you are very specific
and if you would want to look at a
particular row then you could do a get
table name and then give the row key
however you could do a scan to get the
complete data of a particular table you
could also do a describe to see what are
the different column families and if you
would want to alter the table and add a
new column family it is very simple you
can just say alter give the HB stable
name and then give your new column
family name which will then be added to
the table what are catalog tables in
hbase so as I mentioned your zookeeper
knows the location of this internal
catalog table or what we call as The
Meta table now catalog tables in
edgebase have two tables one is hbase
meta table and one is hyphen root the
catalog table Edge base meta exists as
an hbase table and is filtered out of
hbase shells list command so if I give a
list command on edgebase it would list
all the tables which hbase contains but
not the meta table it's an internal
table this meta table keeps a list of
all regions in the system and location
of hbase method stored in Zookeeper so
if somebody wants to find out or look
for particular rows they need to know
the regions which contain that data and
those regions are located on region
server to get all this information one
has to look into this meta table however
we will not be looking into meta table
directly we would just be giving a write
or a read operation internally your
hbase master queries the Zuki cheaper
zookeeper has the information of where
the meta table exists and that meta
table which is existing on region server
contains information of row keys and the
region servers where those rows can be
found your root table keeps a track of
location of The Meta table what is hot
spotting in hbase and how to avoid hot
spotting now this is a common problem
and always admin guys or guys who are
managing the infrastructure would think
about it so one of the main idea is that
edgebase would be leveraging the benefit
of sdfs you are all read and write
requests should be uniformly distributed
across all of the regions and region
servers otherwise what's the benefit of
having a distributed cluster so you
would have your data stored across
region servers in the form of regions
which are horizontal partitions of the
table and whenever read and write
requests happen they should be uniformly
distributed across all the regions in
the region servers now hot spotting
occurs when a given region serviced by a
region server receives most or all of
read and write request which is
basically a unbalanced way of read write
operations now hotspot can be avoided by
designing the row key in such a way that
data being written should go to multiple
regions across the cluster so you could
do techniques such as salting hashing
reversing the key and many other
techniques which are employed by users
of hbase we need to just make sure that
when the regions are distributed across
region servers they should be spread
across region servers so that your read
and write request can be satisfied from
different region servers in parallel
rather than all read and write request
hitting the same region server
overloading the region server which
which may also lead to the crashing of a
particular region server so these were
some of the important questions of hbase
and then there are many more please
refer to the link which I specified in
during my discussion and that gives you
a detailed explanation of how which ways
works you can also look into hba's
definitive guide by O'Reilly or hbase in
action and these are really good books
to understand about hbase internals and
how it works now that we have learned on
hive which is a data warehousing package
we have learned on Pig which is a
scripting or a scripting language which
allows you to do data analysis and we
have learned some questions on a nosql
database just note it that there are
more than 225 nosql databases existing
in market and if you would want to learn
and know about more nosql databases you
can just go to Google and type no SQL
databases org and that that will take
you to the link which is for nosql
databases and this shows there are more
than 225 nosql databases existing in
market and these are for different use
cases used by different users and for
with different features so have a look
at this link now when you talk about
data ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which I would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
injection tools so when you talk about
different data ingestion tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scoop which is one of the
data ingestion tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on sdfs which could then
be used for Hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or Hive or pig or spark or any other
processing Frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say high or HMA
Stables scoop is mainly for structured
data it is extensively used when
organizations are migrating from rdbms
to a big data platform and they would be
interested in ingesting the data that is
doing Import and Export of data from
rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so let's
learn about some important questions on
scope which you may be asked by an
interviewer when you apply for a big
data related position how is scoop
different from Flume so this is a very
common question which is asked scoop
which is mainly for structured data so
scoop works with rdbms it also works
with nosql databases to Import and
Export data so you can import data into
sdfs you can import data into Data
warehousing packets such as Hive
directly or also in hbase and you could
also export data from Hadoop ecosystem
to your rdbms however when it comes to
Flume Flume is more of a data ingestion
tool which works with streaming data or
unstructured data so data which is
constantly getting generated for example
log files or metrics from server or some
chat messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or edgebase you could
be using Flume there could be other
tools also like Kafka or storm or chukwa
or some
and so on scoop however is mainly for
structured data you're loading data in
scope is not event driven so it is not
based on event it basically works on
data which is already stored in rdbms in
terms of Flume it is completely event
driven that is as the messages or as the
events happen as the data is getting
generated you can have that data
ingested using Flume scoop works with
structured data sources and you have
various scope connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as MySQL Oracle tb2 Microsoft SQL
Server you have different connectors
which are available Flume it works on
fetching streaming data such as tweets
or log files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms Flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
to many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of Flume you have components
such as your Source sync and channel
that's the main difference between your
scoop and flow what are the different
file formats to import data using scope
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into Scope
when you talk about scoop you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when I want to import data
from an rdbms I could get that data in
SD EFS using different compression
schemes or in different formats using
the specific arguments so I could
specify an argument which will write
string based representation of each
record to Output files with delimiters
between individual columns and rows so
that is the default format which is used
to import data in using scope so to
learn more about your scope and
different arguments which are available
you can click on scoop dot apache.org
you can look into the documentation and
I would suggest choosing one of the
versions and looking into the user guide
and here you can search for arguments
and look for specific control arguments
which show how you can import data using
scope so here we have common arguments
and then you also have import control
arguments wherein we have different
options like getting data as Avro as
sequence file as text file or RK file
these are different formats you can also
get data in default compression scheme
that is gzip or you can specify
compression codec and then you can
specify What compression mechanism you
would want to use when you are importing
your data using school when it comes to
default format for Flume we could say
sequence file which is a binary format
that stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as Java classes and scoop
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scoop you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as I mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
Avro parquet sequence file that is
binary format or machine readable format
and then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if I look in
the content and here I could search for
a scoop based file where I have listed
down some examples so if I would want to
use different compression schemes here
are some examples have a look at these
so I'm doing a scoop import I'm also
giving an argument so that scoop which
also triggers a map reduced job or I
would say map only job so when you run a
scoop import it triggers a map only job
no reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line mapreduce dot
framework.name so that you could run
your map only job in a local mode to
save time or that would interact with
yarn and run a full-fledged map only job
we can give the connection and then
connect to whatever rdbms we are
connecting mentioning the database name
give your username and password give the
table name give a Target directory or it
would create a directory same as the
table name which would work only once
and then I could say minus Z to get data
in a compressed format that is gzip or I
could be specifying compression codec
and then I could specify What
compression codec I would want to use
say Snappy these lz4 default I could
also run a query by giving a scoop
import and when I'm specifying a query
ad if you notice I have not given any
table name because that would be
included in the query I can get my data
as a sequence file format which is a
binary format which will create a huge
file so we could also have compression
enabled and then I could say the output
of my map job should use a compression
at record level for my data coming in
sequence file so sequence file or a
binary format supports compression at
record level or at Block Level I could
get my data in a Avro file where data
has embedded schema within the file or a
parquet file also so these are different
ways in which you can set up different
compression schemes or you can even get
data in different formats and you could
be doing a simple scope import for this
looking further what is the importance
of eval tool in scope so there is
something called as eval tool so scoop
eval tool allows users to execute user
defined queries against respective
database servers and preview the result
in the console so either I could be
running a straight away query to import
the data into mystfs or I could just use
scoop eval connect to my external rdbms
specify my username and password and
then I could be giving in a query to see
what would be the result of the query
which we intend to import now let's
learn about how scoop imports and
exports data between rdbms and sdfs with
the socket texture so rdbms as we know
has your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scoop import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scoop lib folder so
scoop import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks now that depends
on your scoop command you could be
specifying that you would want to do a
import only in one task or in multiple
tasks these multiple map tasks will then
run on a section of data from rdbms and
then store it in sdfs so at high level
we could say scoop will introspect
database to get gather the metadata it
divides the input data set into splits
and this division of data into splits
mainly happens on primary key column of
the table now if somebody might ask what
if my table in rdbms does not have a
primary key column then when you are
doing a scope import either you will
have to import it using one mapper task
by specifying hyphen hyphen m equals one
or you would have to say split by
parameter to specify a numeric column
from rdbms and that's how you can import
the data let me just show you a quick
example on this so I could just look in
again into the scoop command file and
here we could be looking at an example
so if if you see this one here we are
specifying minus minus m equals 1 which
basically means I would want to import
the data using one map task now in this
case whether the table has a primary key
column or does not have a primary key
column will not matter but if I say a
minus minus m is 6 where I am specifying
multiple map tasks to be imported then
this will look for a primary key column
in the table which you are importing now
if the table does not have a primary key
column then I could be specifying a
split by and then specify the column so
that the data could be split into
multiple chunks and multiple map tasks
would take it now if the second scenario
is your table does not have a primary
key column and it does not have a
numeric column on which you could do a
split by in that case and if you would
want to use multiple mappers you could
still say split by on a textual column
but you will have to add this property
so that it allows splitting the data
which is non-numeric all of these
options are given in the scoop
apache.org link going further how scoop
imports and exports data between rdbms
and sdfs with its architecture so as I
said it submits the map only job to the
cluster and then it basically does a
import or export so if we are exporting
the data from sdfs in that case again
there would be a map only job it would
look at multiple splits of the data
which is existing which your map only
job would process through one or one
table map task and then export it to
rdbms suppose you have a database test
DB in MySQL we if somebody asked you to
write a command to connect this database
and import tables to scoop so here is a
quick example as I showed you in the
command file so you could say scoop
import this is what we would want to do
you connect using jdbc now this will
only work if the jdbc connector already
exists within your scope lib directory
admin has to set up that so you can
connect to your rdbms you can point to
the database so here our database name
is test underscore DB I could give
username and then either I could give
password on the command line or just say
capital P so that I would be prompted
for the password and then I could give
the table name which I would want to
import I could also be specifying minus
minus M and specify how many map tasks
do I want to use for this import as I
showed in previous screen how to export
a table back to rdbms now for this we
need the data in a directory on hdfs so
for example there is a departments table
in retail database which is already
imported into scoop and you need to
export this table back back to rdbms so
this is the content of the table now
create a new Department table in rdbms
so I could create a table specifying the
column names whether that supports null
or no if that has a primary key column
which is always recommended and then I
can do a scope export I can connect to
the rdbms specifying my username and
password specify the table into which
you want to export the data and then you
give export directory pointing to a
directory on hdfs which contains the
data this is how you can export data
into table seeing example on this so I
could again look into my file and here I
have an example of import this is where
you are importing data directly into
Hive and you have scoop import where you
are importing data directly into hbase
table and you can then query your HBA
stable to look at the data you could
also do a export by running your map
only job in a local mode connecting to
the rdbms specifying your username
specifying the table where you would
want to export and the directory on scfs
where you have kept the relevant data
this is a simple example of export
looking further what is the role of jdbc
driver in scoop setup so as I said if
you would want to use scoop to connect
to an external rdbms we need the jdbc
odbc connector jar file now one or admin
could download the jdbc connector jar
file and then place the jar file within
the scoop lib directory wherever scoop
is installed and this jdbc connector jar
file contains a driver now jdbc driver
is a standard Java API which is used for
accessing different databases in rdpms
so this connect jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class and this driver class
enables the connection between your
rdbms and your Hadoop structure each
database vendor is responsible for
writing their own implementation that
will allow communication with the
corresponding database and we need to
download the drivers which allow our
scoop to connect to external rdpms so
your jdbc driver alone is not enough to
connect to scoop we also need connectors
to interact with different database so a
connector is a pluggable piece that is
used to fetch metadata analog scoop to
overcome the differences in SQL dialects
so this is how connection can be
established so normally your admins
would when they are setting up scoop and
Hadoop they would download say MySQL
jdbc connector and this this is how they
would go to the MySQL connectors if you
are connecting to mySQL similarly for
your other rdbms you could be say going
in here you could be looking for a
previous version depending you could be
going for platform independent and then
you could be downloading the connected
jar file now if you want our this jar
file you would see a MySQL connector jar
and if we look in com dot
mysql.jdbc.com.mysql.adbc.river so this
is the package which is within the
connector jar file and this has the
driver class which allows the connection
of your scoop with your rdbms so these
things will have to be done by your
admin so that you can have your scoop
connecting to an external rdbms now how
do you update the columns that are
already exported so if I do a export and
I put my data in rdbms can I really
update the columns that are already
exported yes I can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
Remains the Same the only thing I will
have to specify now is the table name
your Fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms what
is code gen so scoop commands translate
into your mapreduce job or map only job
so code gen is basically a tool in scoop
that generates data access objects Dao
Java classes that encapsulate an
interpret imported records so if I do a
scoop code gen connect to an rdbms using
my username and give a table this will
generate a Java code for employee table
in the test database so this code gen
can be useful for us to understand what
data we have in this particular table
finally can scoop be used to convert
data in different formats I think I
already answered that right if no which
tools can be used for this purpose so
scoop can be used to convert data in
different formats and that depends on
the different arguments which you use
when you do a import such as avrofile
parquet file binary format with record
or Block Level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then I think I can suggest
a link for that and we can say Hadoop
for match
I think it is Tech Mackie afro parquet
Let's see we can find out the Link tech
Maggie yeah this is a very good link
which specifies or talks about different
data formats which you should know such
as your text file format different
compression schemes how is data
organization what are the common formats
what do you have in text file structured
binary sequence files with compression
without compression what is record level
what is Block Level what is a Avro data
file what is a sequel what is a parquet
data file or a columnar format another
formats like orc RC and so on so please
have a look at this thank you all for
watching this full course video on big
data for 2022 I hope it was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video we'll be
happy to help you thanks again stay safe
and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here